Oh, mein Streamingrechner ist gerade abgeschissen. Ist das schlecht? Sehe ich keinen Chat?
Sekunde, ich muss den Rechner erstmal neu starten. Tastatur. Ist mein Streamingrechner abgeschissen?
Einfach so random. Einfach RIP. Press F. Einfach weg, Vara. Schneller als man F pressen kann, Vara weg.
Ich muss noch mal schnell mein Headset entwirren. So, Headset ist entwirrt. Perfekt.
Ich muss warten bis das Streamingrechner wieder gestartet ist.
Dann sehe ich wieder was, sonst sehe ich nichts. Deswegen habe ich jetzt hier den Chat auf, dass ich überhaupt was sehe.
So, Streamingrechner.
Ah, er kriegt nicht ein Windows. Ihr seht es auf dem zweiten Bildschirm gerade nicht.
Ich kriege gerade irgendwie 50.000 Popups, dass irgendwelche Updates fehlgeschlagen sind.
Der Rechner war überhaupt nicht an. Ich weiß gar nicht wann er versucht hat Updates zu machen.
Hier, Leute. Sign up to experience the best of Wubblors. So sieht es aus, Leute.
Sign up. Give follow. Give sub. Daddy can't subscribe für zwei Monate. Dankeschön.
Nice. Ich kann leider nichts drücken gerade, weil mein Streamingrechner noch nicht am Start ist.
Ich muss erstmal 50 Popups wegklicken. Dann vielleicht.
Jetzt, hä? Ah. Jetzt funktioniert es.
Sehr schön. Quit. Erstmal ganz ein Popup weg. Skype. Wo habe ich überhaupt Skype noch?
Welches Skype da installiert?
Der Witcher Soundtrack ist mir gerade zu relaxing. Wir brauchen was anderes.
Der ist auch hier. Witcher 3. Music.
Full Soundtrack. Das ist ein bisschen zu anstrengend.
Ähm.
Was haben die denn hier zu bieten? Relaxing. Wir brauchen irgendwas für den Hintergrund.
Blablabla.
Also wirklich. Die hatten den besten Soundtrack.
Beste.
Huge DLC.
Perfekt. Fast.
Übrigens. Ich bin ja immer noch da. Ah, jetzt funktioniert es. Jetzt sehe ich euch auch die Vorschau.
Ich bin ja immer noch der Meinung, dass der erste Witcher 3 DLC eines der besten Stories ist, die je ein Studio game-technisch auf den Bildschirm gebracht hat.
Ohoho.
Ah, jetzt schon ein bisschen. Nicht ganz so lahm. Vielleicht ein bisschen leiser.
Perfekt. So. Jetzt klappt es auch. Wie auf einen Schlag jetzt alle Leute ankommen, weil Switch gecheckt hat.
Twitch ein bisschen gebraucht.
Ja. Wir können mal gucken. Wenn die Witcher Musik zu nervig ist, dann passt.
Übrigens. Wisst ihr. Eine Frage. Habt ihr alle den Witcher gespielt? Habt ihr alle Witcher 3 mal gespielt irgendwann?
Zumindest mal eine Frage an die Leute, die Witcher 3 gespielt haben.
Was ist...
Ok. Tuning-Pack. Geht fort.
Was ist eure Lieblingsquest?
Also ich meine jetzt nicht. Ich meine jetzt nicht. Es muss keine kleine Quest sein. Ihr könnt meinetwegen sagen.
Keine Ahnung. Die Quest betritt es in Novigrad. Oder ihr könnt sagen, die Main-Quest. Oder der erste DLC Main-Quest. Irgendwas. Keine Ahnung.
Was war eure Lieblingsquest?
Also ich muss ganz klar sagen, für mich ist es die Plat and Wine Main-Quest.
Jo, mal mit der Pfanne.
Also für mich ist es eindeutig die Plat and Wine Main-Quest. Die ist richtig gut.
Und ich krieg ja immer noch fast Albträume hier. Wartet mal.
Children's Song?
Ja.
Es ist alles gruseliger, wenn das irgendwelche Kinder singen.
Der Sound ist schlecht.
Es ist echt gut hier. Bestes Theme im Game. Und ich finde auch die beste Main-Quest ever.
Da kriegst du schon fast Albträume von.
Das ist wirklich einer der besten...
Wie soll man sagen? Er ist nicht wirklich so antagonist. So einer der besten...
Tja, wie nennt man das so?
Der Gegner auch nicht wirklich.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das nennt. So einer der besten Bösewichte.
Aber hier, der Stream von hier, ist wirklich top.
Genau, der Teufel.
Michael, dankeschön. Vier Monate. Huge.
Das Schlimmste an Witcher 3 ist, dass es vorbei ist.
Ich hab das jetzt zweimal durchgespielt.
Und mir reicht's eigentlich. Aber ich würd's gern nochmal durchspielen.
Aber es gibt leider nicht mehr Content. Und das Spiel hatte schon unglaublich viel Content.
Auch das Ende von dem DLC. Ich mein, ich kann jetzt mal ein bisschen spoilern.
Das Game ist von 2015.
Das Ende vom DLC ist auch mega geil.
Wenn er dann einfach so random mit dem Totenkopf wegläuft.
Und vor allem in sein eigenes Musik-Theme pfeift.
Ich find das übelst gruselig gemacht.
Aber ich muss von die Story gespielt haben.
Beste DLC. Ich kann euch sagen, wer das noch nicht gespielt hat.
Zumindest den Blood and Wine DLC. Den müsst ihr unbedingt spielen.
Beste.
Nicht den Blood and Wine DLC. Ich mein Heart of Stone.
Ich hab die ganze Zeit Blood and Wine. Schwachsinn.
Heart of Stone hat so... Voll durcheinander gebraucht.
Ich mein, Heart of Stone müsst ihr unbedingt spielen.
Eines der besten. Ich hab die ganze Zeit Blood and Wine gesagt.
Eines der besten Quests. Einer der besten Storylines, die ich bisher in Games gesehen hab.
Was sind heute dran? Ja, genau. Ich wollt erstmal warten bis...
...ein Game läuft, Leute. 22%. Huge.
Lohnt es sich Richard Reil zu spielen? Ja. Du wirst kaum ein Game kriegen...
...für den mittlerweile ist es ja oftmals runtergesetzt.
Du wirst kaum ein Game kriegen, wo du für 29...
Na gut, ich glaube für 50 Euro so viel Singleplayer-Content und vor allem so viel guten Singleplayer-Content kriegst.
Das Gametrain ist am Start, ja. Gibt's nicht.
Also mir fällt kaum ein anderes Singleplayer-Game der letzten Jahre ein.
Übrigens Stripes hat abonniert. Dankeschön, hab ich gar nicht gesehen.
Mir fällt kaum ein anderes Singleplayer ein, was für 50 Euro so viel Content bietet...
...was in den letzten Jahren erschienen ist.
Tancer ist auch am Start, hab ich auch wieder nicht gesehen hier.
Der Zugucker ist auch da, 6 Monate.
Ja, und wenn ihr mal auf den Sale wartet, ist es eigentlich noch viel besser.
Dann ist es noch mal eine ganze Ecke günstiger.
Warum genau sollte man sich eigentlich den Expansion Pass kaufen?
Wenn man doch die Sachen auch so bekommt. Was auch immer, vollkommen egal.
Ihr solltet es auf jeden Fall spielen.
Der Hype-Train ist erfolgreich. Stufe 1, Emotes. Dankeschön. Huge.
Der Scamtrain war erfolgreich.
Habt ihr es eigentlich mitgekriegt, jetzt wo wir gerade sind, hier bei Twitch?
Habt ihr es eigentlich mitgekriegt, dass...
...das Overwatch jetzt auf YouTube streamt?
Seit ein paar Tagen ist das raus.
Als Hintergrund eignet sich der Witcher-Soundtrack tatsächlich nicht so gut.
Er ist entweder zu nervig...
...oder zu...
...zu relaxig.
So ein geiles Spiel und so ein geiler Soundtrack.
Das ist...
Welche Software findest du am besten...
...um Full-Images einer Maschine zu erstellen?
Muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich hab ewig, wirklich ewig keine Full-Images mehr erstellt.
Ich hab früher mal Clonezilla verwendet, aber das war irgendwie auch ziemlich sehr crap.
Davor hab ich auch mal mit Windows...
...hab ich mir die Maschine erstellt.
Ich hab die Maschine erstellt.
So was neu zu installieren ist ja kein großer Akt, das dauert 20 Minuten.
Ich kann dir leider nichts Gescheites zu sagen für Full-System-Images.
Weiß ich nicht.
Das war ja ein größerer Deal.
Blizzard verlager die gesamte Server-Struktur von Amazon AWS zu Google.
Ja, ich hab's mitgekriegt, da ist richtig viel Kohle geflossen, wobei ich sagen muss...
Ganz ehrlich, ich hab eh schon relativ wenig Overwatch League geguckt.
Ich hab eh schon relativ wenig Overwatch League geguckt, aber für mich ist es vorbei.
Also ich guck garantiert nicht auf YouTube jetzt irgendwie Overwatch League.
Und ich hab hier auf Twitter gelesen, weil Hearthstone wurde ja auch umgewurstet jetzt auf YouTube.
Und einer der bekanntesten Hearthstone-Caster hat gestern irgendwas gepostet,
dass der View-Count übelst Müll ist auf YouTube.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, da hätte man ja nie drauf kommen können vorher.
Wer hätte das nur erahnen können, dass der View-Count crap ist auf YouTube.
Aber da ist so viel Kohle geflossen, das ziehen die jetzt durch.
Leider, ich hab ab und zu ganz gerne mal Overwatch League noch geguckt, aber das ist jetzt vorbei.
Ich guck das garantiert nicht auf YouTube.
Und ich glaube, wenn man sich hier anguckt, 80% weniger Viewer auf YouTube als auf Twitch.
Das ist schon hart, oder?
Der Martin hat sein Abonnement gewechselt.
Huge.
Big-Prain-Entscheidung.
Das ist halt Fail.
Und dann kommt noch dazu, dass Blizzard irgendwie nicht ordentlich Werbung macht.
Also ich muss jetzt mal kurz die Fragen aus dem Chat noch durchgehen.
Und dann erzähle ich euch, was wir heute mal ausprobieren.
Weil ich hab hier einen gefundenen Block Nextcloud-Hub.
Es kam vor ein paar Tagen eine neue Nextcloud-Version raus.
Und die haben einen riesen Aufriss gemacht, hier auch marketingtechnisch,
dass sie jetzt eine Alternative sein wollen zur Office 365.
Unter allem, unter dem, was sie sonst noch so alles machen.
Ich wollte schon mal seit einer Weile wieder angucken, was da draus geworden ist.
Es hört sich übrigens so an, als sagt die Parry...
Guck mal hier.
Der hat es auch geschrieben hier.
Parry, Parry.
Das war in Witcher 3 tatsächlich OP.
Parry-Counter.
Da konntest du alles mitownen.
Der Soundtrack kann sich halt echt nicht entscheiden, wie laut und leise er sein soll.
Genau, ich muss mal kurz Streamfragen gucken.
Eiskräuter, das stimmt.
Die Viewerzahlen von der OWL waren eh schon nicht so gut.
Und es war auch massiv.
Also zumindest...
So wirklich Belege habe ich dafür nicht und hat auch wahrscheinlich sonst keiner.
Aber mal rein aus Aktivität über Reddit, über den Chat, über alles.
Weil drüber hat es sich nicht angefühlt wie ein Stream, der 120.000 Zuschauer hat.
Ich weiß nicht, wo die Zuschauer alle hergekommen sind.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Blizzard View botet hat im eigentlichen Sinn.
Aber in irgendeiner Art und Weise ein bisschen geboostet hat das ganze schon gemacht.
Aber OWL ist halt auch so ein Ding, das darf nicht failen aus Blizzard Sicht.
Und selbst wenn man mehr Geld reinsteckt als es bringt...
Ja.
Aber das ist ripp.
So, ich muss jetzt mal schnell hier noch die Fragen aus dem Chat mir angucken.
Laufen auf deinem NAS auch LXC-Container?
Ich habe da... Ja.
Also würden ohne Probleme laufen.
Ich habe aktuell 5 Docker-Geschichten drauf laufen.
Unter anderem halt hier Nextcloud, ein Wiki, ein Fileserver und ein Container,
der andere Container aktualisiert, die Base Images.
Und eine Übersichtswebseite und...
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, was noch...
Ich glaube, reicht gar nicht.
Ich glaube ein bisschen mehr.
Müssen wir gerade mal nachgucken.
5, 6 Sachen.
Ja, ja.
So, gucken, dass ich keine Subs übersehen habe.
Hm, nix, oder?
Ich habe nix mehr übersehen.
Habe ich...
Habe ich irgendwas übersehen, Leute?
Ach doch, hier der Michael 50 Billionen hat gefragt.
Max, wenn du dich eigentlich dazu entscheidest, weniger zu arbeiten,
im Stream sogar öfters...
Naja, ich arbeite ja schon weniger.
Ja, aber ob ich jetzt wirklich mal irgendwie auf drei Tage arbeite,
das ist hier keine Ahnung.
Ich würde ja auf der einen Seite gerne, aber auf der anderen Seite auch nicht.
Genau.
Ich bin da unentschlossen irgendwie.
Noch, noch.
Last Synth.
Ja, ich habe mir so ein Ding hier gekauft.
Das wollte ich nämlich heute mal ausprobieren.
Also, was wir heute vorhaben, ist folgendes.
Was wir heute ausprobieren, ist folgendes.
Ich habe mir eine Raspberry Pi 4 hier.
Ich habe mir so ein komisches, vor einer Weile schon mal so ein komisches,
aktiv gekühltes Gehäuse gekauft.
Das habe ich zusammengebaut.
Ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen...
Was, Plattchat?
Wo ist Plattchat?
Ja, hier.
Richtig Plattchat, Alter.
Richtig Plattchat.
Um mal aus meinem Overwatch-Meme-TXT-Dokument vorzulesen.
Plattchat, genau.
Erstmal Zapp-Oli-Chat.
Nein, sowas mache ich nicht.
Wollen wir SR-Schwanzvergleich machen?
Lass mal überlegen.
Was war denn mein höchster SR in Overwatch-Top 4?
4200 oder 4100?
Irgendwie sowas in dem Dreh.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Schon so lange her.
So, nein, nein, nein.
Ich kaufe auf Rechnung.
Gehe fort.
Also, wie gesagt, ich habe mir so ein komisches Gehäuse gekauft,
habe ich heute Morgen zusammengebaut.
Und ich kann euch gleich schon sagen, kauft dieses Gehäuse nicht.
Das Gehäuse ist Müll.
Man sieht es hier nämlich gar nicht.
Das besteht aus so komischen Platten.
Die legt man übereinander, macht dann Schrauben drüber.
Das Problem ist, dass die...
Also, ich habe es ja noch nie erlebt,
dass das Zusammenbau von so einem billigen Gehäuse derartig kompliziert ist.
Die haben sogar ein eigenes Video dazu gemacht,
wie man das Ding zusammenbaut, weil die Leute unfähig waren.
No Aim, No Brain, Winston-Main.
Nice.
Hier.
Installationsvideo.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal das Installationsvideo an.
Das ist grausam.
Passt mal auf, wie unnötig kompliziert der Zusammenbau von einem Gehäuse ist.
Der Switcher muss mal kurz die Klappe halten.
Guckt euch mal, wie unnötig komplizierter Kram ist.
Vorhin unten habe ich hier unten in die Küche gesetzt
und habe den Kram zusammengebaut.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe, glaube ich, für so ein Publikus,
ich habe 20 Minuten gebraucht, bis das funktioniert hat.
Und dann hatte ich den Lüfter noch falsch herum dran.
Weil der Lüfter, waren sie ja auch so wahnsinnig clever.
Und haben an dem Lüfter keinerlei Markierungen, in welche Richtung der Luftfluss ist.
In dem, hier guckt mal, in diesem Dokument, in dem Dokument steht drin,
wie rum man den Lüfter, wie rum man den Lüfter machen muss für richtigen Luftfluss.
Allerdings der Lüfter selbst hat keine, hat keine Pfeile, wie der Luftfluss ist.
Total crap Gehäuse.
Kauft euch das bloß nicht.
Wenn ihr euch ein gutes Raspberry Gehäuse kaufen wollt, dann kauft euch...
Moment, dann kauft euch das da.
Das ist gut.
Da wollte ich mir auch noch eins kaufen.
Alles, was ich bisher gesehen habe an Videos und sonst was drüber,
ist das hier wohl mit, mit das beste Gehäuse, was man sich, was man sich kaufen kann.
Das ist auch passiv gekühlt.
Ist, verteilt quasi die Hitze komplett über das ganze Aluminium Gehäuse.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, jetzt passen wir auf, wie unnötig komplizierter Kram ist.
Choose my name.
Du hast es, du hast es ja wenigstens gemerkt.
Wir hatten bei uns im Rechenzentrum, hatten wir Switche falsch rum eingebaut.
Mit Lüfter falsch rum.
Und es gab laufend irgendwelche Alarme.
Bis die Leute dann irgendwann mal auf die Nähe gekommen sind.
Hups, der Luftfluss ist ja falsch rum.
Jetzt guckt euch mal an, wie kompliziert, wie sinnlos kompliziert das ist,
dieses Gehäuse zusammen zu bauen.
Vor allem, was für ein kleines Micromanagement gefuddelt das ist.
Alter, mach die Schrauben raus.
Ah.
Guckt mal hier, guckt euch das mal an.
Für so ein poppliches Kackgehäuse.
Was ist das?
Was ist mit denen los?
Ist das Lego?
But why?
Warum kann man nicht einfach was machen, wo man den Raspberry Pi reinklipst und gut ist?
Sieht's gut aus?
Nee, sieht noch nicht mal gut aus.
Wartet mal.
Playback Speed.
Wir gucken dir mal so zu.
Ein bisschen schneller.
Du kommst dir wirklich vor, wie als baust du Lego zusammen anstatt das Raspberry Pi Gehäuse.
Es ist ohne Probleme händelbar.
Ich hab's ja auch in 20 Minuten gemacht.
Aber es ist halt echt schon ein bisschen übertrieben kompliziert für so ein kleines Poppelgehäuse.
Da hab ich jetzt den Lüfter falsch rum dran gemacht.
Da hab ich jetzt den Lüfter falsch rum dran gemacht erst mal.
Weil kein Pfeil drauf ist, auf dem Lüfter in welche Richtung der Luftfluss ist.
Ich kenne keine Lüfter, die keine Pfeile haben bis heute.
Und wenn das Ganze fertig ist, dann...
Ich hab's an 3,3 Volt angeschlossen.
Nee, den Lüfter hörst du gar nicht.
Also ich hab ihn auch an 3,3 Volt angeschlossen.
Den Lüfter kannst du an 3,3 Volt oder 5 Volt anschließen.
3,3 ist langsamer, aber reicht.
Wir gucken uns auch gleich mal die Temperaturen vom Raspberry an.
Und dazu kommt halt, dass das Gehäuse nicht mal gut aussieht.
Guck dich mal das Gehäuse an.
Also es ist ziemlicher Crap zusammenzubauen.
Es...
Es kostet relativ viel.
Es ist Crap zusammenzubauen und es sieht hässlich aus.
Also nehmt lieber, nehmt lieber das hier.
Nehmt lieber das hier.
Ohne Mist.
Das ist rund beste, beste Case.
Wenn du willst, Michael, können wir das machen.
Ja.
Können wir machen.
Luftfluss ist doch eigentlich immer dort, wo der Motor sitzt, Richtung Sticker.
Ja, hab ich auch, hab ich auch so eingebaut.
Aber ich hatte halt, ich hatte halt die...
Die Platte falsch rum.
Ah, hier ist ja die Platte, wo er den Gehäuse, wo er das, wo er das drauf hat.
Hier, und ich hatte die Platte andersrum gedreht.
Ich hab's so dreht, so, ich hab's so angebaut, wie der hier gemacht hat.
Allerdings andersrum.
Der Luftfluss war prinzipiell schon richtig, aber die Platte war falsch rum.
Ah, also, also auch, auch falsch.
Muss ich nochmal abmachen.
Also ich find's gar nicht gut.
So.
Ähm, genau.
Und was ich, was ich mir geholt hab, ist...
Die hab ich ja schon ne Weile hier rumliegen.
Die 970 Evo 1TB.
Ähm, dann hab ich mir dieses, dieses Pi, Pi-Gehäuse geholt, ein Raspberry Pi 4.
Aber Michael, erinnere mich nochmal, erinnere mich nochmal dran, ne?
Nicht, dass ich das nachher, nachher vergesse.
Ähm, so.
Und dann hab ich mir dieses Ding geholt, wo man, da kann man die SSD reinmachen.
Ich hab allerdings das doofe Gefühl, ich hab's nämlich vorher mal kurz angestöpselt,
dass es nicht richtig funktioniert.
Man sieht das hier gar nicht, wie's innen aussieht.
Ähm, ich hab das Gefühl, dass es nicht richtig funktioniert.
Weil...
Gucken wir mal, dass hier irgendwie von innen sieht.
Ja, so ungefähr sieht das von innen aus.
Das ist halt einfach so ein Board, wo man ne M2 SSD draufmacht.
Ich glaub aber nicht, dass es gut funktionieren wird, weil...
Ich hatt's vorhin mal kurz angeschlossen, für 5 Minuten bin aufs Klo gegangen, bin wiedergekommen.
Ey, das Gehäuse hat grad geklüht.
Oder fast geklüht.
Ich hab's in die Hand genommen, ich hab mich nicht verbrannt, aber es war schon unangenehm.
Also die NVMe SSD wird da ziemlich, ziemlich hot drin, ja.
So.
Ähm, das Heiß, was wir jetzt machen, ist, ich schnapp mir jetzt erstmal ne Micro SD-Karte.
Und nebenbei können wir schon mal das aktuelle Raspbian downloaden.
So, ich hab mir nämlich paar Sachen aufgeschrieben, die wir machen.
Während das Ganze downloadet und flasht, kann ich das Ganze dann in die Hand nehmen.
Während das Ganze downloadet und flasht, gucken wir uns nämlich mal das Werbevideo an von Nextcloud.
Was sie alles Tolles Neues haben.
Und dann könnt ihr euch ja mal überlegen, Chat.
Hier, wo, wo haben wir's?
Der Chat kann sich mal überlegen, wie wir Nextcloud installieren wollen.
Also, wir haben die Auswahl zwischen, wir können einfach ganz normal einen Raspbian installieren.
Und, ähm, das mit Office Alternative sag ich gleich nochmal was.
Ähm, wir können einfach einen Raspbian installieren und darauf mit dem offiziellen Installer-Script,
oder meinetwegen auch von Hand, ähm, den Gramm installieren.
Nextcloud ist PHP-Gramm.
Wir können aber auch, wir könnten einen LXC-Container machen.
Wir könnten einen Docker-Container machen.
Oder wir könnten einen Docker-Compose-File machen mit Nextcloud, was das Ganze dann für uns anlegt.
Und das Ganze checken wir doch irgendwie in Git ein oder so.
IamRoot.
Twitch Prime. Zwei Monate, Dankeschön.
BigBrainSub.
Docker auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Das funktioniert absolut problemlos. Funktioniert wunderbar.
Ist überhaupt kein Ding.
If your Raspberry Pi will not boot.
Was?
Ich hoffe, der bootet.
Okay, Download. Raspbian.
Hast du schon mal Docker und CUDA zusammen? Nee, hab ich noch nichts zusammen gemacht.
LXC und darin dann Docker mit Nextcloud? Nee, das ist zu nested.
Es funktioniert.
Man kann den LXC ohne Probleme nested dockern, aber das ist dann doch zu übertrieben.
Was sollte man mit einem Pi nicht machen?
Naja, als Desktop-Ersatz taugt er nicht sonderlich gut.
Es sei denn, man kommt damit aus, dass man, äh, ziemlich lahm webbraust
und ein bisschen E-Mails liest und ein bisschen Instant-Messenger macht.
Ansonsten ist halt alles, was Datenbank ist, auf dem Raspberry Pi nicht so der Wahnsinn,
wenn man das mit der onboard SD-Carder macht und man ein bisschen IO braucht.
Nicht so toll.
Aber nachdem man an einem aktuellen Raspberry jetzt auch eine SSD anschließen kann,
gibt's eigentlich nix so richtig Grundlegendes, was man auf dem Raspberry Pi nicht machen kann.
Der Raspberry Pi ist auch ein super Übungsteil, wenn Leute ein bisschen rum experimentieren wollen
mit Cluster-File-System oder irgendwelchen Distributed Storage-Geschichten wie Ceph
oder wenn Leute ein bisschen Kubernetes-Cloud-Geschichten, Cloud-Hype, Hyperscaler,
hab ich ja letztens gelernt, an sich das Ganze ein bisschen üben wollen.
Dafür ist das eine super Plattform.
Es gibt eigentlich nix, was du da grundlegend nicht drauf machen kannst.
Wo der Raspberry Pi halt relativ schnell schlapp macht, ist, wenn du da Sachen drauf laufen lassen willst
mit mehreren Usern gleichzeitig und was halt ein bisschen Performance braucht, dann nicht.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du Home Assistant für Heimautomatisierung drauf laufen lassen willst,
läuft das ganz gut, aber wenn da viele Sachen drin sind, wenn viel gelockt wird und sonst was,
da kommt der Raspberry Pi relativ schnell an seine Grenzen.
Stimmt, ja, wenn die Docker-Images nicht für arm sind, dann geht's nicht.
Das ist klar, aber Nextcloud geht ohne Probleme.
So, wir wollten eigentlich downen. Hab ich das jetzt schon gedownloaded?
Wo jetzt? Was ist denn das da oben für ein Knopf?
Hab ich jetzt schon downloaded oder nicht?
Firefox, wo habt ihr jetzt neuerdings die Downloads versteckt? Hier irgendwo, ne?
Das ist auch so ein Ding, wo ich mich permanent drüber beschweren könnte.
Dieses Menü, ich mein, sind wir auf dem Desktop oder sind wir auf dem Tablet?
Was ist hier los?
All Thin Clients für einen Terminal Server. Kann man machen, da läuft ja selbst auf dem Raspberry Pi da nicht so viel drauf.
Was ein bisschen doof ist, ist, wenn du Linux drauf verwendest oder wenn du das halt für Linux Clients machst,
Linux hat halt keine gescheiten grafischen Remote-Fähigkeiten.
Du kannst zwar so Sachen machen wie VNC oder ein bisschen besseres VNC, was Teile von der Grafikkarte verwendet.
Du kannst die billigste Variante, das SSHX-formel Ding, aber das ist nichts im Vergleich zum Beispiel,
was Microsoft neuerdings hat mit ihrem kompletten 3D-beschleunigten Remote-Desktop
oder auch was beispielsweise VMWare anbieten kann mit durchgereichten Grafikern oder auch so Tricks und sowas.
Da gibt es nichts in der Richtung.
Wenn man einfach nur eine Oberfläche braucht, die irgendwie geht, mag das ganz gut funktionieren.
Was verwendest du denn?
Umut, was nimmst du denn als Oberfläche für deine Terminal?
Oder meinst du mit Terminal Server wirklich Text? Aber wahrscheinlich meinst du schon GUI, oder?
XRDP ist tatsächlich ganz okay. X2GO ist auch ganz nett, aber das kann man leider.
Leider braucht es noch eine Weile, bis es da ist, wo die anderen sind, die ich da gerade erwähnt habe.
Funktioniert und tut es gut. Ich habe auf der Arbeit jahrelang X2GO verwendet.
Funktioniert wunderbar.
Je nach Desktop.
Okay, also Moment. Wir wollten das ganze flashen. Wo habe ich... Ich brauche mal eine SD-Karte.
Wo ist meine SD-Karte? Hier, huge.
Wobei...
Kann man die Raspberry Pis nicht mittlerweile sogar von USB booten?
Raspberry Pi 4.
Booten mit ohne SD-Karte von USB. Easy, zeig her.
Pi 4 hat noch keinen USB-Boot, das heißt das Video ist gar maß.
Stimmt, ja, du hast recht. Habe ich letztens sogar gelesen. Das Video ist gar maß.
Okay, wir skippen mal kurz drüber, was der Typ macht.
Okay, jetzt ist schon mal Windows.
Monkeys!
Monkeys, Alter, was ist da los?
Seht ihr das Gleiche, was ich auch sehe?
Monkeys, Monkeys, Monkeys, Monkeys, Monkeys.
Monkeys, Monkeys, Monkeys.
Es ist Magenta Cloud. Das ist die erste Usage von Magenta Cloud.
So in the wild, die ich je gesehen habe.
Okay, machen wir weiter. Was macht der denn?
Da typo... Was treibt der da?
Was macht der da?
Was macht der denn da?
Er ist schon im Internet 6.0.
Ach, jetzt checke ich, was der macht.
Der richte die SD-Karte so ein, dass sie dann USB bootet.
Ja, das ist ja noob, das kann ich auch.
Man kann natürlich einen Bootmanager, wenn das so will, starten von der SD-Karte.
Der dann die USB bootet. Ja, das, das geht natürlich.
Aber dann kann ich auch gleich von der SD-Karte booten und einfach meine SSD mounten später.
Das macht dann keinen großen Unterschied, weil die SD-Karte, die verreckt halt genauso beim Stromausfall ganz gerne mal.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was der da treibt.
USB boot Raspberry Pi 4. Gibt es da, gibt es da irgendwas? Forum Raspberry.
Was? Evelink auf dem, was ist das?
Was hier? Zeig mal.
Ah, USB.
Was genau?
Sonoff, wer benutzt denn den Sonoff bitte schön ohne ihn zu flashen?
Gibt es da, gibt es wirklich Leute, die das machen?
Ja, anscheinend derjenige, der das Video aufgenommen hat.
Ja, genau, das funktioniert. Du kannst die Boot-Partition auf der SD belassen, die Root-Partition auf die SSD verfrachten.
Okay, wir machen jetzt erstmal Standard. Wir flashen den Kram jetzt erstmal, stinkt noch mal, auf die Micro SD-Karte.
Wenn ich sie in den Card-Reader rein kriege.
Ich kriege die Micro SD-Karte nicht in meinen Reader rein.
Funktioniert nicht. Ah, jetzt. Perfekt. Ah, jetzt. Excellent, excellent.
Auf, USB. Connect, jawoll.
Was? Was? Hab ich nicht.
Edger ist kaputt. Warum?
Edger ist RIP. Okay.
Jetzt erleben wir mal neu.
Ist das eine Linux-VM auf einem Windows-PC?
What the fuck, Alter? Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Wisst ihr was, Leute? Ich remove das mal kurz. Ich weiß nicht, was der da für Schmerzen gerade hat.
Es sieht auf jeden Fall kaputt aus. Ich meine, wir können es auch die Ideen, ja?
Ich hoffe, kein Unterschied. Aber warum geht das nicht? Ich glaube, ich muss mal ein Update machen.
Ich glaube, ich muss mal updaten. Ich habe schon lange die VM nicht mehr geupdatet.
Wir machen das jetzt einfach mal. Oh, was? Konflikt? Ah, yes. Excellent.
What? Oh je.
Was hat der denn für Schmerzen?
Ich weiß nicht, was wir machen. Wir machen jetzt den Loop-Style. Wir deinstallieren das einfach.
Oh, prägt. Was? Cura? Na gut, brauche ich die eh nicht. Kann weg.
Weg. VM. Ich will hier eh nichts realisiert drucken in der Stream-VM.
Yes. What? Lipdmx? What the hell? Was willst du von mir?
Was ist das? Warum habe ich das überhaupt installiert?
Hab ich das? Da habe ich gar nicht installiert.
Hallo?
Wir installieren den Kram jetzt einfach mal. Den ist weg damit. Zack. Jetzt aber.
Darf ich jetzt updaten? Yes. Excellent. Jetzt funktioniert es.
Xserver kaputt. Ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist, was ich da eigentlich gerade deinstalliert habe.
Warte mal, das müssen wir jetzt mal gucken.
Wo ist denn? Habe ich nicht ordentlich copy-pasted?
Ja. Was ist das überhaupt? Dxdmx.
Dxdmx. Unterlesung ist das alles auch immer so schön benannt.
Extreme Multi-Head. Ach, da kann man verschiedene Monitore zusammen zu einem großen machen.
Widescreen, ja. Extreme Multi-Head. Six-Head. Fast schon 11-Head.
Das was Chillfreaks sagen, wieso? Ich habe es jetzt deinstalliert, ich brauche den Kram eh nicht.
Ohje, es ist installiert. Java 8. MonkaS.
Ja, lass wir ihn mal installieren.
Und alles nur um eine SD-Karte zu flashen. Ich meine, wir könnten die SD-Karte auch DD'en, ja.
U-Gym. Sieben Monate. 11-Head, aber sowas von.
Leider war ich so blöd und habe mir mein Programm eingebaut, dass es Aspect Ratio immer gleich lässt.
Sonst könnte ich jetzt einen 11-Head machen hier, aber es geht leider nicht.
Weil der den Kopf nicht skaliert.
Low Programming Skills hat nicht gereicht.
Allerdings muss man sagen, es ist komplizierter die Sachen so zu machen, dass die das Seitenverhältnis beibehalten wird, als einfach nur immer gleich groß wie Fenster zu machen.
Also eigentlich ist die Implementierung von mir mehr 5-Head als wenn ich jetzt einen 11-Head machen könnte.
Falls man mir überhaupt noch irgendwie folgen kann, was ich gerade überhaupt sage.
Max, kannst du bei Twitch Top Cheerer und Top Geschenkgeber einstellen?
Also das ist ja zurzeit nur Top der Woche, wäre Top of All Time nicht besser.
Ich kann das mal gucken, die Sache ist bloß die.
Ich hab das bei mir ausgeplantet, ich seh das gar nicht.
Ich hab hier Dings, ich hab hier FFZ installiert und ich hab in FFZ und...
By the way, das kann ich jedem auch nur empfehlen zu machen. Sollen wir jetzt nicht so laut sagen.
Ich hab alles ausgeschaltet in FFZ.
Twitch Overlays sind ausgeschaltet, Donator sind ausgeschaltet, Cheerer sind ausgeschaltet, alles ausgeschaltet, ich seh nix.
Das Einzige was ich seh ist Chat mit allen Emotes bei der Twitch TV FFZ und Stream, fertig.
Beste.
Den ganzen Crap der da mittlerweile rumspuckt auf Twitch, was irgendwelche Stream Overlays angeht,
irgendwelche Voting Geschichten, irgendwelche anderen Sachen, die den Chat halb locken.
Der Hype Drain, alles weg.
Ich brauch eine puristische Viewing Experience.
Das Cam Drain.
Ähm, ist der Soundtrack fertig?
Es ist übrigens Musik an, falls man das nicht hört, aber...
Wisst ihr was, immer ein bisschen Wupp Wupp Wupp. Wupp Wupp Wupp geht immer.
So, Wire... Warum hab ich denn überhaupt WireGuard installiert hier drauf?
Haben wir mal zusammen WireGuard installiert, Leute? Kann das sein?
Wir haben mal im Stream WireGuard gemacht, ne?
Schon mal Chatterino 2 ausprobiert, ne?
Was ist Chatterino 2? Chat client for Twitch, ich will das im Browser haben.
Wenn ich das nicht im Browser hab, ist doof.
Ich will das neben dem Browser sehen im Stream.
Doch doch, ich glaub wir haben WireGuard mal im Stream, da kann nämlich gleich hier...
WireGuard weg.
WireGuard... Kann man eigentlich sowas hier machen?
Ne, ne, das geht nicht.
WireGuard... Man konnte ihm doch aber sagen...
Ja, den ganzen Mist.
Alles fort, ist die Schalte.
So, und jetzt reboot ich mal, dann hab ich wenigstens die aktuelle Colonel Version alles drauf.
Gucken, was wir für einen Colonel installiert haben.
5.4, ist das LTS, passt. Reboot.
Du wolltest doch mal WireGuard Tutorial, wann wollte ich das?
Wir haben uns das im Stream zusammen angeguckt, ziemlich sicher.
Ich glaub wir haben einen Raspberry, oder wir haben uns...
Haben wir uns nicht einen DigitalOceanVM gemacht dafür?
Und dann irgendwie WireGuardVPN oder sowas?
Ich kann mich da nicht immer dran erinnern, ich mein...
Ich bin jetzt ja auch schon ein paar Jahre hier am Start.
Ich kann mir das auch nicht alles merken, was wir alles schon gemacht haben.
Aber ich glaube, ziemlich sicher haben wir WireGuard schon gemacht.
So.
Los, mal gucken.
Alles, alles nur um der SD-Karte zu... zu dingsen, ne?
Ja, install.
Jawoll.
Ah, yes.
Ach guck Leute, jetzt funktioniert's. Easy.
Wir brauchen ja erstmal einen 500 MB RAM verwendeten...
500 MB RAM verwenden, damit wir eine SD-Karte flashen können.
Muss, muss sein.
Excellent.
Ha. Outplayed.
Select Image.
Das Ding bescheuert.
Wo geht denn das hier auf? Soll nicht hier aufgehen?
Soll gefälligst hier aufgehen.
Wie heißt das WireGuard Video? Ich hab kein WireGuard Video gemacht.
Ich hab nen... wir haben nen Stream, wir haben das im Stream installiert.
Ziemlich sicher.
So, haben wir das Richtige.
Transient, Boot, Root, FS.
Okay, da ist schon irgendein Respion Zeug drauf wahrscheinlich.
Egal. Flash.
Bam.
Wow.
Monkeys.
Wo geht denn das heute alles nicht richtig?
Was ist denn heute los?
Was ist denn heute, was ist denn heute kaputt?
Kann das sein, dass der Download kaputt ist?
Nee, den ZIP muss man nicht anpacken.
Das Ding ist schlau genug, das kann den Kram selbst... selbst entpacken.
Okay, wir laden es nochmal neu runter.
Vielleicht ist der Download wirklich... vielleicht ist der Download kaputt gewesen.
Geht ja schnell, guckt euch das mal an.
Easy.
30 MB die Sekunde.
Das ZIP muss man nicht anpacken.
Gibt es einen speziellen Grund, warum du Tritzen benutzt und nicht Jay?
Ich glaube der ursprüngliche Grund war, weil Tritzen die gleichen Kommandozeilenparameter backwards hatte wie Jaurt damals.
Und weil es schöne farbische Ausgabe hatte.
Also seht ihr manchmal bin ich auch absolut Noobstyle bei der Auswahl von Software.
Einfach was, was ich bedienen kann, wie das alte und hübsche Konsolenausgabe hat, nehme ich.
So.
Jetzt aber, ha?
What?
Was hat der denn für Schmerzen?
Die Fahrtwindows.
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Dann doch die Idee.
Was hat der für Schmerzen, was ist mit dem los?
Ah, kann das sein, dass das Ding irgendwie versucht, irgendwelche Magic, irgendwas zu mounten oder so?
Dass der im Hintergrund irgendwas mountet?
Hier, wo ist es denn? Wo ist hier SS? Nö, ne?
Der versucht nichts zu mounten?
Das hatte ich noch nie.
Was ist das Problem?
Wir können mal, wir können mal gucken, also wenn man gucken will, ob man was richtig runtergeladen hat, macht man da einfach mal eine
eine Hashware drüber und gucken uns das an.
Was sagen die dann hier? Haben die hier, haben die hier offi, hier?
Shard 256 Brammer.
Und dann mal vergleichen.
Ist das richtig?
Guckt hier?
Richtig.
Na dann dehnen wir den Kram doch, meinetwegen.
Ich weiß nicht, frag mich nur, warum es nicht funktioniert.
Die Idee beste.
Kann das sein, dass du Etcher mit Zulu, hab ich das nicht gemacht?
Hab ich das nicht gemacht?
Das muss ich machen, ja? Ja, ja?
Na klar hab ich das nicht gemacht, ich hab's hier drüber gestanden.
Ja logisch, ja Leute, ihr habt recht, muss das mit Zulu starten, sonst geht's nicht.
Korrekt.
Huge.
Wahnsinns Chat wieder hier.
Big Brain.
Deluxe Chat.
Guckt, jetzt geht's auch.
Jetzt kommen die ganzen Besserwisser wieder an, ey.
Ja man, nicht das hier in den Sinn. Mach doch ein anderes Kommando.
Ich glaube, ich hab das mit Zulu ausrufezeichen, ausrufezeichen, sogar mal ein Video gezeigt.
Aber das ist einfach ein Unterschied zwischen, man weiß, dass es prinzipiell existiert, zu...
Man denkt jedes Mal dran.
Oin Guldilo. Huge Fehlermeldung von Etcher, ja.
Ja das wär auch sinnvoll, wenn das Ding fragen könnte, so nach dem Motto, ah, Rootberechtigung.
Weil, eigentlich müsste das können.
Ich hab doch auch Dings hier.
Wenn ich hier versuche, was zu installieren, das geht glaub ich auch, guck mal.
Ah nee, was soll man, ich lass es jetzt mal bleiben.
Ich müsste so ein grafisches Sudoding eigentlich installiert haben.
So, ist geflasht? Nee, flash noch.
Sudo minus I bringt doch in dem Fall nix.
Sudo minus I krieg ich ne Rutsche. Jetzt müssen wir, jetzt gleich müssen wir Sudo minus I machen.
In dem Fall hat mir Sudo minus I ja nicht so viel gebracht.
Ich mein, ich hätte Sudo minus I machen können, danach Etcher starten, danach weiter machen können in der Rutsche, weil wir brauchen jetzt eh ne Rutsche.
Was wir jetzt machen müssen ist, hier in der Tat, Sudo minus I und wir müssten mounten.
Was war das nochmal?
SDB?
Ja, hm?
SDB.
Mount. Def. SDB.
Äh, SDB1.
So, das ist die Boot-Partition von meiner SD-Karte.
Und weil es ein Raspberry ist und man uns danach per SSH drauf einloggen wollen, muss ich sagen, touch SSH, sonst funktioniert das Ganze nicht.
Ich würde euch ja prinzipiell per Capture-Card sogar an den Raspberry anschließen, aber das brauchen wir nicht, weil wir werden an dem Raspberry eh nichts, nichts machen großartig, außer uns per SSH einloggen.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich guck hier gerade auf dem Schreibtisch rum, ich glaube, ich finde auch auf die Schnelle mein, äh, was ist das, mini HDMI zu normalem HDMI nicht.
Jetzt können wir nicht das anschließen.
Okay, touch SSH, unmount, den ganzen Crap.
So, dann können wir fertig.
Gut, ähm, jetzt kann ich die SD-Karte rausholen und in den Raspberry stecken und dann gucken wir mal, ob das Ganze funktioniert.
Ich muss es mal kurz neben hin legen.
Das ist übrigens die billigste 16G Mikro SD-Karte, die ich habe hier.
Was macht das Sync-Command, das stellt sicher, dass auch alles aus dem Buffer auf die Platte geschrieben ist.
Eigentlich brauchst du es nach dem unmount nicht.
Ich bin mir eigentlich relativ sicher, dass das beim unmount automatisch passiert.
Aber ich hab mir das so angewöhnt.
Lustigerweise mach ich das nur unter Linux, unter Windows, bin ich doch nie auf die Idee gekommen, sicher entfernen zu machen vom USB-Stick.
So, ich muss jetzt mal kurz auf meinem Router schauen, was das Ding für eine LP gekriegt hat.
Pi add 1221682, Punkt, Moment.
So, und was ist das erste, was wir jetzt machen, wenn wir uns auf den Raspberry Pi eingeloggt haben?
Wir waren ja schon ein paar Mal drauf, Leute, wisst ihr es noch? Was ist das erste, was wir machen?
Chat enttäuscht mich nicht.
Passwort ändern, nein, das machen wir nicht.
Update, ja, das ist das zweite, was wir machen.
Das ist das zweite, was wir machen.
Resize, nee.
Gut, SSHD aktivieren, nee.
Key kopieren, Spatzgranate hat gewonnen.
Spatzgranate hat gewonnen.
Also ich hab keinen Bock, immer das Passwort einzutippen.
Bam, so sieht's aus.
Spatzgranate hat offiziell jetzt das größte Brain zur Zeit.
Kann sich heute noch ändern im Laufe des Streams.
Huge Brain Chat heute, ja, ja.
Excellent Chat.
Ist die Musik zu laut oder passt so?
Kann das immer schlecht anhand von diesen komischen Graphen erkennen, ob das jetzt passt oder nicht?
Passt, okay.
So, sind wir eingeloggt.
Ich guck mal, was für ein Kernel drauf ist.
41975V7L.
Ah ja, alles klar.
Update.
Ist die, haben die jetzt standardmäßig eigentlich schon in 64 Bitkernel?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das wird ja dann hier irgendwo stehen.
Hier wird es ja wahrscheinlich irgendwo stehen, wenn das 64 Bit wäre.
Den kann man installieren, nicht standard?
Okay.
Was muss ich installieren für den 64 Bit Kernel?
Wissen Sie das?
Wollen wir mal ausprobieren.
Wir machen erstmal ein Upgrade.
Ah, jetzt alles upgraden.
Okay, nee, muss mal gucken.
Kann man den schon verwenden?
5464Bit Kernel.
Install.
Lesbian Kernel for testing.
Was?
Nee.
Stimmt nicht.
Tillmun?
Okay.
Gucken wir mal, geil.
Ah, yes.
Wo, wo, wo macht das denn?
Hier.
Oh, das scheint mir ganz schön kompliziert zu sein.
Das ist wohl nicht getan, einfach nur mit Abinstall Kernel x64 oder sowas.
Ja, dann lassen wir es erst mal.
Für unsere Zwecke auch vollkommen unerheblich jetzt.
Das 64 Bit oder 23 Bit System ist vollkommen egal, wo wir Nextcloud installieren wollen.
So.
Äh.
Okay.
Was auch immer.
Okay, danach starten wir neu.
Nee, danach installieren wir erst noch ein paar Sachen.
Die wir eh brauchen.
Ach, wir haben das Nextcloud Hub Video noch nicht gesehen.
Genau.
Ich wollte euch ja erzählen, warum ich Office 365 Alternative sage.
Weil, die sagen das selbst.
Morris, sieben Monate, dankeschön.
Pock, huge.
Ups.
Falsch geklickt.
Die werben jetzt damit, das kam erst vor ein paar Tagen raus.
Die werben jetzt damit, das Nextcloud heißt ja nicht mal Nextcloud, sondern Nextcloud heißt jetzt Nextcloud Hub.
Und, ähm, sie sind viel geiler als bisher.
Leute.
Meint ihr, das ist ein Hottes Grill, was da spricht?
Okay.
Okay, jetzt hab ich nicht aufgepasst, Leute.
Jetzt hab ich nicht aufgepasst.
Oh, nochmal.
Das ging bisher auch schon.
Real wahrscheinlich, ja.
Sieht aus wie immer.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Hat die gerade gesagt, die Suche funktioniert standardmäßig?
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Die Suche hat bisher nie richtig funktioniert.
Die Suche hat nie richtig funktioniert bisher, die war immer kaputt.
Also, Volltext-Suche hat glaube ich noch nie ansatzweise funktioniert.
Filesuche ging so, aber Volltext-Suche war teilweise so kaputt, dass du nicht mal, ähm, deine eigenen To-Do's und Notes durchsuchen konntest nach einem Wort.
Was die Anwendung halt komplett überflüssig macht.
Wozu brauch ich eine Notiz-Anwendung?
Ohne, ohne Suche.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Ja, ich wollte auch schon...
Line-Dancing interessiert mich persönlich auch immer.
Unglaublich.
Ei, was?
Eidonex, Stufe 1, Dankeschön.
Big Prane, Big Prime-Sub.
Nee, gar kein Prime.
Gar kein Prime, richtig.
Ein echter, ein richtig echter.
Huge, Dankeschön.
Mit Karl und Micky.
Meint ihr, das ist die Sprecherin in dem Video?
Bestimmt nicht, oder? Das ist Marketing.
Prom, Moment, das ist auch noch, äh, das ist das noch in Deutschland hier?
Prom Nürnberg to Berlin Tief.
Mach mal wieder was auf YouTube.
Ja, ich mach ein Video über Chrome, äh, über Chrome-Funktionen demnächst.
Ich weiß, ich hab's letzte Woche schon erzählt.
What the fuck?
Pass mal auf.
Wo ist McCree, Alter?
Oh, jetzt, jetzt wollen sie auch reden.
Ja, da bin ich, das will ich mir immer heute ausprobieren.
Ich weiß, dass ich kein Office verwende, aber ich will mal wissen, ob das auch nur ansatzweise funktioniert.
Äh, Dom PC, ich glaube, das ist einfach diesmal alles default dabei.
On-Premise, das heißt nichts anderes wie, dass es auf eurem eigenen Rechner laufen kann.
Das ist ja mittlerweile, braucht es einen eigenen Namen.
Man kann nicht einfach sagen, so nach dem Motto, ich installier's bei mir, nein, On-Premise, On-Premise.
Und die richtig coolen Leute, die sagen nicht On-Premise, die sagen On-Prem, weil's irgendwie cooler klingt.
So, haben wir geupdatet.
Also, was wir auf jeden Fall brauchen, ist mal wieder ein T-Max, ein Vim.
Was brauchen wir sonst noch?
Hardtop.
XFS, Tools.
Keine Ahnung, gucken wir mal, können wir das immer noch installieren, weil wir was verbrauchen.
Aber eine Vim brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Ascii-Quarium, ich glaube, Ascii-Quarium ist nicht standardmäßig drin.
In Crespian.
Nano kann überhaupt nicht größer Vim sein, weil Nano und Vim überhaupt nicht die gleiche Kategorie abdecken.
Du kannst mit beiden Basic Texts bearbeiten, aber Vim ist halt deutlich umfangreicher und Nano richtet sich halt an Leute, die einfach nur was editieren wollen.
Das kann man so gar nicht miteinander vergleichen direkt.
Wenn man einfach nur öffnen will, editieren will, speichern will, ohne sich damit zu beschäftigen, ist Nano sicherlich der bessere Editor.
Aber wenn es um Funktionen geht, kann Nano und Vim nicht das Wasser erreichen.
Und VSCode auch nicht, weil VSCode nicht auf der Commando-Zeile läuft.
Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum ich noch so viel Vim verwende, einfach weil es auf jedem Server drauf ist.
Und weil du mal easy irgendwelche Sachen auf der Commando-Zeile editieren kannst.
Okay, wir rebooten mal schnell.
Und dann schauen wir mal.
Also, was haben wir jetzt gesagt? Wir wollen das Ganze mit Docker installieren, ne?
Da muss ich mir irgendeinen, mit Docker oder wollen wir das ganz pro irgendwie mit einem Docker-Compose-File machen?
Aber als erstes muss ich jetzt mal meine SSD anstöpseln und gucken, ob die ordentlich funktioniert.
So.
Sehr gut.
Wir ändern die 5-Hat-Variante, ja. So, ich stöpsel mal die SSD an und wir gucken uns das an.
SSD ist dran. Das Ding müsste jetzt als 1TB Platte drinstehen hier.
Da, hier, SDA.
1TB Platte, also MKFS, XFS auf DEV SDA, da wird jetzt meckern, dass schon was drauf ist.
Und das wird überschrieben.
So, SSD ist formatiert, dann können wir das Ding mal mounten.
Mal gucken.
Warum hängt denn das beim Mounten? Das hört sich schon mal nicht gut an.
Oder es fühlt sich schon mal nicht gut an, wenn es schon beim Mounten hängt.
Ich habe euch gesagt, der USB-Adapter macht einen kack Eindruck. Ich glaube, das spackt.
Ich glaube, das spackt rum.
Guck mal, das hängt schon beim Mounten.
Der USB-Adapter ist, glaube ich, einfach Müll hier, der da.
Wie gesagt, ich habe es vorhin mal in die Hand genommen. Ich habe mir fast die Finger verbrannt.
So heiß ist die SSD geworden.
Wir geben dem nochmal eine Chance. Ich meine, vielleicht hat er ja beim ersten Mounten,
musste er irgendwelche Dinger unter der Haube noch anlegen, aber normalerweise ist das überhaupt kein Problem.
Du formatierst das Mount, das geht instant.
Dass es jetzt hängt, ist schon mal höchst verdächtig.
Nee, es muss nicht SDA 1 sein.
Ich habe direkt auf das Device das Ding formatiert.
Das sieht nicht gut aus.
Okay, wir gucken mal kurz ins Lock rein.
Was ist das hier?
Device reset.
Das liest sich nicht gut, Leute.
Er hat gemountet, guck mal.
Keine Partition angelegt.
Partition overrated.
So, okay.
Da sind wir. Touch, Qt, Chat.
Aja, ja.
Ja, anscheinend funktioniert der Kram jetzt.
So, dann schauen wir doch mal,
was die Festplatte so hergibt, über USB.
Erst mal PV installieren.
Wir schauen mal, wie schnell das Ganze ist.
Wir gucken mal kurz, wie schnell das Ganze ist.
Hier blub.bin.
Wie schnell ist die SSD?
Die ist...
Hab ich gemountet?
Ja, sie blinkt.
Äh.
Leute, der Adapter hat Schmerzen.
Ich sage euch, das spakt rum.
Uiuiuiuiui.
Moment, ich brauche den passenden Sound dazu.
Ich brauche den passenden Sound dazu.
Yoshi.
Moment.
Nein.
Ich brauche den.
Wo gibt es den Sound?
Nein, das nicht.
Den Sound gibt es nicht.
Aja, ja.
Okay.
Ha. Sound.
Yoshi.
Nee, leider finde ich den Sound nicht.
Das spakt ein bisschen rum mit dem Adapter, würde ich sagen.
Das sieht nicht gut aus, Leute.
Die Karte ist wie verrückt am Blinken.
Ich lege da mal meine Hand drauf.
Ich gucke mal, wie warm das Ding wird.
Das ist ziemlich warm, aber ich glaube nicht,
dass es daran liegt.
Nee, ich habe keinen anderen M2-Adapter mehr.
Aber ich habe noch massig USB auf SATA.
Ich mache da einfach ein normales SATA-SSD dran und gut ist.
Ja, ich habe noch genug.
Daran wird es nicht scheitern, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Aber es könnte auch sein,
dass es ein Bug ist mit diesem USB-Dings.
Was auch immer dahinter steckt.
Wo steht es denn hier?
Hier ist ein UAS-Treiber-Geschichten.
Haben deine SATA-Adapter ein Netzteil?
Ich habe eins mit Netzteil, ich habe welche ohne Netzteil.
Für SSDs geht eigentlich das ohne Netzteil.
Das sieht nicht gut aus hier, Leute.
Warum ist der warm gegen das jetzt auf einmal?
Okay, das sieht nicht gut aus.
Also entweder ist meine SSD im Arsch,
das glaube ich nicht.
Oder das spackt rum mit dem Adapter.
Ich gehe davon aus, es spackt rum mit dem Adapter.
Ach so.
Vielleicht ist die jetzt im Arsch.
Man kann das doch bestimmt...
Wie deaktiviert man den Kram?
Wie deaktiviert man das?
Was?
Adapter mal woanders testen, kann ich machen?
Nee, kann ich nicht machen.
Weil in der VM macht der Adapter...
Spacken diese Sorte Adapter auch rum.
Das weiß ich.
Also das habe ich schon ausprobiert.
In der VM warke das auch nicht.
Und in der VM hatte ich ähnliche Probleme.
Deswegen weiß ich, man konnte diesen Kram deaktivieren.
Hier das da.
Man konnte diesen Mist deaktivieren.
Wobei mir das jetzt schon ein bisschen zu...
Gefrickel aussieht.
Ist eine NVMe?
Ist das DE-Overkill?
Ja.
Ist sie.
Ich will die auch nicht für den Raspberry auf Dauer verwenden.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur mal gucken.
Ah, hier.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur mal gucken, was das so hergibt.
Ich glaube, ich muss den Raspberry wieder einschalten.
Okay, also was muss man machen?
Ja genau, das ist doch die gleichen Probleme, die wir haben.
Ah nee, also ich glaube, Powerprobleme habe ich nicht.
Ich habe das offizielle 5V, 3A Netzteil.
Das reicht auf jeden Fall.
Außerdem würde das Ding meckern, wenn er zu wenig Strom kriegt.
Okay, also was muss man hier machen, um das auszuschalten?
Wendel-ID?
Okay, das machen wir jetzt.
Ich schalte mal den Raspberry Pi aus.
Vielleicht kann ich ihn auch runterfahren.
Ich kann euch übrigens mal einen Trick zeigen.
Wenn ihr ein Linux-System habt, wo ihr noch per SSH draufkommt.
Ich muss gleich mal nachgucken, was man genau machen muss.
Wenn ihr ein Linux-System habt, wo ihr noch per SSH draufkommt,
aber das Ding höchstwahrscheinlich hängt und nicht mehr richtig runterfährt.
Ihr könnt dem Linux-System sagen, einfach Power ausschalten.
Und zwar, da muss man nachgucken.
Ich kann aber den Fahrt immer nicht merken.
Genau, man kann das da echoen nach...
Im Prinzip dahin.
Dahin kann man das echoen und dann schaltet das Ding sich automatisch Power aus.
Ohne, dass man jetzt irgendwie auf Streamboard-Interface muss oder so.
Ich habe es ehrlich gesagt auf dem Raspberry Pi noch nie ausprobiert,
aber am Raspberry Pi funktioniert es auch.
Jetzt hat er gar keine Chance hängen zu bleiben.
Okay, also was müssen wir jetzt machen?
Achso, wir sollen uns die Hersteller-ID und sowas abschreiben.
Okay, machen wir.
Erst mal warten, bis das Ding wieder neu gestartet ist.
Ach, da ist er.
Wie ist er schon wieder da?
Da ist er wieder.
Ich glaube es dann.
Ging aber schnell.
High-Speed-Pi.
Aber wir starten erst mal was, dass wir nicht immer rausfliegen.
So, die SSH hat er wieder erkannt.
Also jetzt brauchen wir...
Was brauchen wir?
D-Mask, USB...
Wir können doch einfach so gucken, oder?
Ja.
Warte, was da?
Uuuh!
Nee, was war das?
LS, USB, Tree?
Man konnte sich doch irgendwie...
Ah, Tree, genau.
Man konnte sich doch irgendwie so ein...
Die Weißbaum malen lassen.
Warum haben die alle überall andere Kommandos für?
So.
Also wo hat er denn mein...
Mein SSD erkannt?
Wo ist mein SSD?
Hier.
Was da, ha?
Na gut, dann stoppst du nicht mal ab und wieder dran.
Aber trotzdem...
Ich kann mir die Befehle für LS, USB und...
Wie ging das nochmal? LS, USB und dann...
LS, USB, Find, SSD...
Genau.
Man konnte sich doch so einen Baum malen lassen, irgendwie.
Tree? Und man muss ihm jetzt allerdings sagen, dass er alles auch anzeigt.
Das ist übelst, wir...
B, Tree...
Minus...
Das haben wir doch gerade.
Oder ist es das?
Das ist es doch hier, oder?
Das ist doch die SSD hier.
Ok, also was müssen wir jetzt machen?
ID, Vendor and ID Products.
Wo ist...
Ach, hier oben!
ID Vendor und ID Product.
Das kennen wir doch bestimmt mal mit LS, USB raus.
Was ist...
Was minus Paint Tree?
Ja, das ist es.
Ok.
Das brauchen wir.
Hast du doch in dem, ich hab's ehrlich gesagt nicht gesehen.
Sitzt nicht drinnen.
Aber die zwei Sachen müssten es sein.
So und dann muss man was mit dem Zeug machen?
Was, das da, ok, ohje, mal gucken ob das funktioniert.
Na ob das funktioniert, da hab ich ja so meine Zweifel ob das klappt.
Ja hab ich ja gerade gemacht, ich hab ja gerade hier nach Vendor geguckt, da war nix, gibt's
nix.
Ok, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt ob das funktioniert.
Ok also, hallo?
USB Storage Query, sowas erzählt der Typ hier doch auch, dass man das da reinschreiben
soll.
Ach nee, das muss man da vorschreiben oder, Moment, Moment, Moment, das muss man, das
muss man da vorschreiben.
Oder?
Ja, ja, naja, ok, wartet mal, wie war das nochmal hier mit, ähm, das da, das da brauchen
wir.
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt ob das was bringt.
Ja, save, reboot, ok Leute, jetzt bin ich mal, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das, ob
das klappt.
Ich hab, ich, ich, ich hab meine Zweifel ob das funktioniert.
Muss man danach noch irgendwas machen?
Hab ich was vergessen?
Muss ich mir noch, irgendeinen Bootloader updaten oder so?
Scheint nicht.
SSD via USB Controller in NVMe, NVMe über USB, die blinkt schon mal wie verrückt meine
SSD, die blinkt schon mal wie verrückt.
Aha, aha, aha, ich seh jetzt hier nichts von UUAS oder so, ok, mount, mount, mal gucken,
vielleicht gehts jetzt, ja, def, sda, nach MNT, der Scheiß hängt schon wieder.
Ok, ich nehm doch mal ne andere SSD, vielleicht, das wird jetzt auch noch ne, das ist auch
noch ne Möglichkeit, vielleicht wirds zu warm.
Ich hab noch ne billig, äh, ne billig SSD hier rumlegen, die nehmen wir jetzt einfach.
Ja, hätte sein können, dass das funktioniert, achso hier, check that it works, ok, ok, wir
checken ob es worked, ja, UAS is blacklisted for this device, using USBs, also es hat funktioniert,
es hat funktioniert was wir gemacht haben, ok, wir testen jetzt einfach noch mal was
passiert wenn wir, wieviel, mal gucken wieviel IO wir kriegen, schreiben, der Adapter ist
voll für nen Arsch, Leute, kripp, voll für nen Arsch, voll für nen Arsch, ich hätt
den T-MAX starten sollen, hätte ich jetzt gucken können was passiert, ja guck mal,
der Spaktrum, kannste knicken, kannste knicken, oder, oder nicht, oder doch, ich hol mal die
andere SSD, das war keine, das war keine, sondern nicht gute die ich hier hab, das ist
ne Sandisk, äh, ja, Sandisk 240G, irgendwas, so eine hier, das die ich jetzt noch hab,
ja, so ein Ding da, genau, so ein Teil, das ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig toll, aber für
unsere Tests reicht es auf jeden Fall aus, guck mal, jetzt funktioniert es, jetzt funktioniert
es, aber allein schon das der immer die USBs Sachen resettet, das ist doch nicht normal,
da ist doch irgendwas im Argen, da ist doch irgendwas im Arsch, ich mein jetzt kriegen
wir, das passt jetzt über USB, ja, weil das könnte ein bisschen schneller sein, aber
das geht, 250 MB die Sekunde, da kann ich mit leben, vielleicht mag er jetzt doch, vielleicht
hat er nur mal kurz gebraucht, vielleicht hat er sich kurz verschluckt und jetzt ist
ok, da probieren, probieren wir es doch mal aus, vielleicht mag er jetzt ja doch, also
wenn er, wenn er es jetzt halbwegs schnell löscht, dann, ne, für den Arsch, ich nehm
jetzt, ich nehm die andere USB, die andere USB SSD, voll, voll für den Arsch, ja, spackt
übelst rum der Adapter, so ein Pfeil ist normalerweise in der Millisekunde weg, das ist nicht normal
hier, das spackt übelst rum, ich warte jetzt bis er das hier oben hingekriegt hat, dann
mount ich das Teil und dann schließen wir hier die billige SSD an, was aber auch egal
ist, weil für Tests, ganz ähnlich 240G, selbst wenn das, selbst wenn das nur, keine
Ahnung, 80 MB die Sekunde hat oder so, ist immer noch besser als eine SD Karte, ok, ja
guck, der hat wieder resettet, weg damit, Bam, guck mal sogar das, sogar das an-mounten
schwuppelt übelst rum, wenn wir gerade dabei sind, wir können nebenbei, können wir nochmal
hier gleich Docker für euch installieren, Compose, warum bitteschön ist MediaWiki suggested,
wenn ich Docker Compose installiere, MediaWiki, hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun, da BastiW
schreibt, ähnliches hatte ich bei einer Samsung MVME USB Adapter auch, ja kann sein, es könnte
ja auch sein, dass das irgendein Kernelback ist oder so, ich weiß ja nicht, ich meine,
das ist ein Zusammenspiel jetzt von Controller in der SSD, Controller auf dem Adapter, USB
Hub, Raspberry Firmware, Linux, das ist alles dabei, das kann überall in die Hose gehen,
ja, gut, ich stöpsel mal um, ich mach mal die billige SSD dran, wir müssen übrigens
noch testen, wie warm der Raspberry Pi wird, hier da ist die andere, wir müssen noch testen,
wie warm der Raspberry Pi wird, V, GAN, Temp, wie ging das, Pi, GAT, CPU, Temp, das ist
immer so ein Kommando, was ich mir nicht merken kann, V, hier, VC, GAN, Raspberry Temp, so
rum, jemand, der sich sowas merken kann, ok, also wir starten hier oben mal unseren, was
haben wir, 35 Grad aktuell, ok, 35 Grad, dann gucken wir mal, wie die Auslastung vom
System ist und hier unten starte ich mal ein bisschen Rechenlast, ja, was weiß ich, hoch,
hoch das da, so, so, das rechnen wir jetzt aus, was, BC nicht drauf, ai ai ai, scanning,
wow, was, pending kernel, wo soll der auf einmal herkommen, ich hab doch alles geupgraded,
what, das hab ich noch nie gesehen, was, das, Virus, genau, das wirds sein, was, das hab
ich noch nie gesehen, was ist das, ich weiß nicht, ich kann restarten, ich hab meine Zweifel,
was, dass der Restart irgendwas bringt, weil wir haben geupgraded und gerestartet, kam
mit docker, hat, echt jetzt, ne, docker macht aber meine kernelversion nix, ja, ne, der hat
es gemerkt beim docker installieren, aber das ist nicht die Ursache, ok, also gucken
wir mal, wie warm das ganze wird, was machst du, ich, ich gucke gerade, also jetzt gerade
im Moment, ähm, gucke ich, wie warm mein raspberry pi 4 wird, wenn ich ihn was ausrechnen
lasse, wenn ich alle 4 kerne mal 100% auslasse, gucken, wie warm er wird, wir hatten das jetzt
schon mal ausprobiert, das letzte mal waren wir bei 85 Grad und dann ist er abgekackt,
oder ist er abgekackt, ne, ich glaub, ich glaub, der ist nicht abgekackt, der ist einfach
nur, einfach nur eingebrochen und hat runtergetackt, ich glaub, abgekackt ist er nicht, ich kann
mich gar nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern, zumindest hatten wir das letzte mal Probleme,
was die Temperatur angeht, ne, ne, abgekackt ist er nicht, ähm, jetzt sollte er deutlich
unter 85 Grad bleiben, der hat immer eine Lüfter drüber, der hat, der hat passiv Kühlkörper
drauf und eine Lüfter drauf, also der kann jetzt gar nicht zu warm werden, ja, 50 Grad,
ist doch okay, ich meine, es ist immer noch ganz schön, oh, es geht hoch, Leute, es geht
hoch, ich hol mir gleich das, äh, der Bauer, äh, der Bauer, äh, CPU-Köpf-Kit und mach
Flüssigmetall auf meinen Raspberry Pi und dann mach ich ne Wasserkühlung drauf, genau,
ich muss aber erstmal meine CPU-Köpfen, sonst geht das nicht, CPU-Köpfen und Flüssigmetall
drüber, Lüfter auf Low, ja, ja, ja, Lüfter ist auf niedrigste Stufe, Stickstoff, können
wir auch machen, geht doch, 53 Grad für 100% CPU-Last ist okay, das ist, das ist in Ordnung,
ich würd mal sagen, selbst wenn es hoch geht auf 55, 56 unter Volllast, wenn es ne Weile
läuft, das ist doch in Ordnung, vollkommen okay, okay, dann rebooten wir nochmal, wenn
der der Meinung ist, wir sollen rebooten, kannst du gleich mal ein, äh, Crypt Setup Benchmark
machen, ähm, kann ich machen, aber der fällt, also, haben wir schonmal gemacht im Stream,
der fällt ziemlich schlecht aus, ich kanns machen, wenn du willst, aber der fällt, der
fällt schlecht aus, weil die, ähm, die Crypto-Geschichten in der Arm-CPU nicht aktiviert haben, weil
die wahrscheinlich Passent sparen wollten, ursprünglich dachte ich ja, das liegt daran,
weil es kein 64-Bit-Respion ist, aber die haben wohl die Crypto-Extensions gar nicht
in der CPU drinne, also wenn du willst, kann ichs installieren und machen, aber ich kann
dir sagen, das Ergebnis ist crap, hier, wir rebooten mal, vielleicht bringts ja doch was,
das von den Körnern hat er eben erwartet, hier, eindings, L5, äh, okay, dann, dann,
äh, ja, das ist naheliegend, ne, man denkt erst, das liegt am 2-3-Spurt-Betriebssystem,
ist das nicht, ich hab, ich hab dann in irgendeinem Forum gefunden, dass die quasi die Arm-CPU
haben, aber entweder haben sie die Crypto-Sachen nicht lizenziert, und, oder es ist gar nicht
erst drauf, keine Ahnung, okay, was genau will der mir eigentlich sagen, mit 15993-8+,
ist V8+, ist das der 64-Bit-Körner, kann das sein, kann das sein, dass das der 64-Bit-Körner
ist, und das der 23-Bit-Körner, ich mein, das ist die Arm-Architektur-Version, ja, aber
der Raspberry Pi hat ja V8, ähm, nicht zu verwechseln mit dem JavaScript, V8, kann man,
warte mal, Absearch-Körner, gibt's denn da, eigentlich alles für, ne, ne, eh, Firmware,
oh fuck, was war das, Firmware, Firmware, Colonel musste, konnte man ja nicht suchen,
Colonel hat ja nix gebracht, muss man Firmware suchen, ups, äh, ja, ist das Package, wo die
Colonel drin ist, wo ist da, wo der Colonel drin ist, Firmware, ne, ha, ja, ja, ja, ja,
äh, wie heißt das Paket für den Colonel, ja, ich, ich bilde mir ein, das heißt Linux-Firmware,
Linux-Hutter, aber, aber da findet er weder, weder noch, weder so noch, ne, also wenn nach
Das war ja mein ursprünglicher Ansatz, da ich nach Hedder suche, aber da hab ich nix brauchbares.
Ah hier, da sind wir doch.
So, was haben wir da jetzt alle so zur Auswahl?
V8.
Ne.
Ich weiß, was wir von Colonel drauf haben.
Das scheint nicht der Richtige zu sein.
Weiß nicht, was der für Schmerzen hat.
Wir könnten mal ein Update machen.
Travel Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Huge Brain Sub.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was das andere für, was V8 plus, was das sein soll.
Pie.
Was ist das überhaupt?
Ok, ist, V8 ist doch glaube ich der neue V64 Spit Quads.
Ok Leute, wir installieren jetzt den V64 Spit Quads.
Einfach, weil es geht.
Wir installieren jetzt den V64 Spit Quads.
Also, angeblich, angeblich geht das so.
Wollte ich eh schon mal die ganze Zeit ausprobieren.
If you want to switch to V64 Spit Quads.
Add arm V64 Spit Quads gleich 1.
Ah, guckt hier.
V8.
Das ist der V64 Spit Quads.
Ok, also, was muss man...
Wo muss man das eintragen?
In die Config?
Gut, config txt.
Es gibt noch kein Eintrag für...
Vorher Update machen.
Hab ich mir auch überlegt, aber wir haben ja quasi das neueste...
...Freust aus dem Image schon drauf.
Weiß nicht, ob das so sinnvoll ist, wenn ich das noch update vorher.
Ich meine, das ist Firmware Update.
Wir können das machen.
Die Meckern ja überall rum sagen, eigentlich sollen wir das machen.
Die Meckern ja überall rum sagen, eigentlich sollen wir das gar nicht ausführen.
Weil Beta Software und sonst was.
Was erst danach?
Was denn? Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Would you like to proceed? No.
Wir machen das jetzt mal so, wie ich das ursprünglich vorhabe.
Wir tragen das jetzt mal ein und rebooten.
Ähm, so.
You can still...
So, und was muss man dann? Rebooten?
If that false kernel loading system is ok.
Erst danach?
Ich bin jetzt zu sich auch.
Kasho?
Die wooden
勝利
5 4 install 64 bits
ne ne deprecate war was anderes
stimmt ja borty gute idee
herrn lacht da ist es alles da
ok wie gut
aber kann ich ja mal tippen mal gucken was jetzt passiert entweder startet er nicht mehr
oh ist wieder da leute ist wieder da
hat funktioniert wir haben 64 bitkörnl
sehr gut ich bin ja fast geneigt leute soll ich die soll ich die andere ssd
noch mal anstöpseln und gucken ob die jetzt funktioniert ich glaube nicht dass es überhaupt
irgendeinen einfluss darauf hat ehrlich gesagt aber vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht hat es
irgendwas gebracht komm ich stöpseln mal kurz an
ok ok es hängt alles gut wir müssten sich noch mal probieren wir müssten sich noch mal
probieren das hat da hat keinen einfluss darauf gehabt also der mit dem adapter kommt
da nicht klar guckt hier der spack drum der hat der hat richtige schmerzen mit dem adapter
weiß auch nicht was was er für probleme hat aber große anscheinend große probleme
hat einfach nicht den iq von twitch chat sonst wird es funktionieren ich würde ich würde ja
gerne abrechnen und die ssd wieder raus stöpseln aber ich lasse ihn mal ich lasse ihn mal fertig
fertig machen spack da nämlich rum die setting device nee das ist für den arsch das ist ja
doof aber wir nehmen die billig ssd die billig ssd und gut ist gut docker docker haben wir
schon docker compose docker zeug haben wir schon installiert na ja gut no happy meal for you sieben
monate aktuell im sieben fortlaufenden monat huge sup ok andere ssd wieder
also ja super speed gen 1 usb ja die benahmung von usb haben wir ja schon öfters festgestellt
sind ein bisschen undurchsichtig spinning frog ist auch am start der name passt irgendwie gut
dazu oder spinning frog ok also jetzt kann man den kram auch nee nee nee wir müssen erst mal
erst mal fall system drauf machen auf sda ja ich weiß dass da schon was drauf ist aber es
mir egal mount guckt leute das geht auch gleich viel schneller jetzt ist die ssd auch nicht kaputt
das ist jetzt das ist jetzt die billig ssd und die funktioniert lustigerweise für gleich bämen
funktioniert instant ist aber nicht so schnell wie die andere guckt klappt auch sofort der adapter
ist kacke oder halt die kombination aus adapter controller raspberry pi firmware linux was auch
immer an irgendeiner stelle geht es auf jeden fall ordentlich schief bei der anderen ssd jetzt
sieht man nämlich auch wie schnell das hier eigentlich geht wenn es geht ok also wir haben
gesagt wir wollen nextcloud installieren und wir hatten uns jetzt entschieden dafür wir wollen das
ganze per docker und docker compose machen also zumindest der chat will das will das machen per
docker docker compose da machen wir das doch ich war mir könnten das ganze jetzt auch nicht
als gut machen das wäre prinzipiell eigentlich die empfohlene variante man muss sich unbedingt
immer mehr unter root machen als irgendwie notwendig ist aber ich meine warum nicht wir
schmeißen das ding danach eh gleich wieder weg
freenas ja freenas habe ich bei mir nicht nicht mehr im einsatz ich hatte mal ganz kurz aber ich
konnte mich damit nie richtig anfreunden seitdem habe ich ganz normal zfs auf meine
deluxe aber drauf komme ich auch super mit klar was bedeuten compose im zusammen mit docker
zeige ich dir docker compose ist im prinzipen ganz kleine ach so ja doch zeigt er an im prinzip
ist ein ganz kleines hilfstuhl was aus einem jammel feil quasi docker konnte also du definierst
in dem jammel feil das machen wir jetzt einfach mal hier du definierst in dem jammel feil was
der für container anlegen soll und dann sagst du nur noch docker compose ab und der startet die
ganzen sachen für dich also es ist kein unterschied unter der haube ja und da auch ein ganz normaler
docker container nur dass man halt nicht den container von hand starten muss und man auch
sich seine config datei begabt kann und einfach auf dem anderen rechner doch komposed absagen
kann es ist direkt wieder da ja jammel ist pepega format aber was willst du machen mittlerweile
werden wir es am lieben bei so schlecht ist jammel auch gar nicht ich meine ich bin ruby fan und
wenn ich noch dran erinnern kann früher unter rails da hat man alles mit jammel gemacht die
ruby hat das jammel jammel geliebt alle also ich gucke mir mal das offizielle docker compose feil
für nextcloud aber ich habe ja eins ich habe ja eins ich würde einfach meins nehmen insecure
ja wir wollen insecure haben ich will ich will weder maria db ich will weder maria db noch
sonst was ich will zum testen so eine billige sq light und gut ist also was machen die hier
services bla bla bla postgres sonst was nee leute wisst ihr was wir nehmen wir nehmen wir nehmen
mein docker feil oder mein mein compose feil für nextcloud kann ich nämlich einfach copy
pasten und gut ist und da kann ich wie gesagt ich benutze ich benutze einfach das eingebaute
eingebaute sq light datenbank für nextcloud und das war es und wir installieren einfach
aktuelle 18er version 18 ist das von glaube von nextcloud das ist das nämlich total einfach
services zack was macht der für riesen einrückung da standardmäßig das wollen wir aber net
nextcloud ich habe das neu noch nicht getestet aber es gibt noch einen weiteren grund warum
ich keine free nas verwende weil ich will ja noch mehr machen auf meinem rechner als
da nass drauf laufen zu lassen bisschen feilserver ist so nebensache bei mir neben den ganzen
anderen dingern also nextcloud dann muss man ihm sagen was er für ein image verwenden
soll leute falls man da jetzt was anderes machen muss und irgendjemand von euch in letzter
zeit letzter zeit mal nextcloud ins credit hat und ich jetzt irgendwie mist eingeben
müsst ihr mir das sagen weil ich schreibe weil mein docker mein docker compose feil ist
noch von version 17 ich würde jetzt einfach version 17 durch version 18 ersetzen und hoffen
dass alles funktioniert so jetzt müssen wir ihm sagen was er verwenden soll als als
ordner wo er sein zeug drinne speichert weil wenn man das nicht angeben dann speichert
er alles in seinem magic feilsystem quasi im container drinne was man zwar auch drauf
zugreifen kann dann irgendwie unter war ne wo ist das war run links fs docker irgendwas
aber es ist viel angenehmer man gibt den verzeichnis an wo er seine dateien ablegen soll hat nämlich
auch den großen vorteil wenn ich das ganze upgrade dann ist es einfach immer da muss
mich darum nichts großartig kümmern aber man muss sagen selbst das schützt ein nicht
davor dass irgendwelche update upgrade scripts scheiße bauen also sprich backups sind nie
verkehrt also ich kann noch so viel vercontainerisieren oder verdef opsen oder was auch immer wenn
die eigentliche anwendung irgendwie kacke baut und man zeug kaputt macht kann ich mich
nie großartig davor schützen deswegen ist es immer gut wenn man vor einem upgrade oder
generell nicht vor einem upgrade wenn man regelmäßig wenn es von den wichtigsten sachen
irgendwie den backup macht das ist auch ein vorteil von so einem docker compose feil das
ist halt die einfachste variante wenn man jetzt nicht irgendwelche wenn man jetzt nicht
sich gerade ein kubernetes cluster oder sowas daheim hinstellen will und man einfach sein
kram in der config datei definiert und man sagt ab und es läuft alles wieder sofern man
natürlich die files von den einzelnen container gebackupt hat ok volumes was nehmen wir da
jetzt hier mnt nex cloud oder so und das ganze muss in dem container selbst dann gemontet
werden nach nach ww html weil das dort ist wo nex cloud sein sein zeug halt macht und
ich glaube das war schon ich muss bei meinen meinen compose feil reingucken ich glaube
das war es schon mehr muss man nicht machen das ist halt ganz praktisch jetzt kann ich
dieses feil nehmen sag einfach docker compose ab und der startet mir den kram so wie es
sein muss ich muss allerdings noch unter mnt mal nex cloud verzeichnis anlegen und jetzt
sage ich docker compose ab und da sollte eigentlich alles hochfahren aber noch minus d dass er
das ganze im hintergrund macht was habe ich kaputt gemacht ich habe es zerstört leute
ich glaube ich habe ne minus vergessen jetzt aber so jetzt startet er den kram und dann
schauen wir mal ob das ganze funktioniert und ob es denn die versprechen halten kann
und die sie da in ihrem marketing video angepriesen haben wo wir gerade beim thema sind was findet
ihr eigentlich besser unrate oder freemass ganz ehrlich weder noch ich nehme einfach
ne ganz normale linux server mach mir dann samba drauf und gut ist mehr brauchst du
net mit der nächsten ubuntu version kommt angeblich ja auch quasi dass man installieren
kann auf zfs wenn ich das richtige erinnerung habe das haben wir irgendwas gesagt und nimmst
ubuntu machst zfs drauf installierst den samba server fertig weder freemass noch wozu
weil ich finde man beschränkt sich damit irgendwie zu sehr auf so einem ubuntu server kannst
du alles machen was du machen willst und ich weiß dass man unter freemass theoretisch auch
irgendwelche bsd container laufen kann lassen kann und unter unrate gibt es quasi auch
irgendwie so ein docker install gedöns ich denke mal wenn man einen gui braucht ist unrate
nicht verkehrt aber mein fall ist es nicht ich installiere mir am liebsten ubuntu server
macht zfs drauf installieren und installieren den samba für fileserver und fertig und dann
alles was ich sonst noch so brauche was ist eine nextcloud hub das ist die 18e version
von nextcloud die haben sich jetzt umbenannt und sind angeblich viel krasser und besser
als vorher gegen das docker compose logs ok es läuft leute es läuft nextcloud ist am
start und jetzt sehen wir auch schon mal einen großen vorteil von diesem ganzen oder auch
nicht ah kann das sein dass ich vergessen habe den port anzugeben worauf das lauschen soll
80 warum zeichnet es nicht an ich jetzt scheuert ne geht auch nicht huge habe ich was vergessen
zu exposen oder so weil angeblich angeblich sollte auf port 80 laufen wie kein teller drauf
zum thema zf erst bekommst du irgendeine art von benachrichtigung wenn eine platte ausfällt
können ich machen habe ich aber nicht gemacht
braucht man das echt also ich habe mein aktuelles compose file genommen da ist das nicht drinnen
und es funktioniert trotzdem der lauscht gar nicht gerade aktuell hier ports doch tatsächlich
braucht man lull lull lull ich weiß übrigens warum es nicht funktioniert warum sie mein
ich weiß besser gesagt ich weiß warum es in meinem aktuellen docker compose file funktioniert
aber hier nicht weil ich noch eine load balancer beziehungsweise in proxy davor habe das habe
ich hier nicht also muss man ihm wahrscheinlich hier sowas noch sagen der port also muss man
ihm sagen port 80 80 80 80 ab stimmt das jetzt schauen wir mal aha netz der port 80 da ist
er da ist er und da ist die next cloud steht auch irgendwie die version drinne es wäre
natürlich auch wo kämen wir denn dahin wenn im installer bildschirm die versionsnummer
drin stehen würde ok user admin 123456 ok guck ja das ist die version 18 hier kalender
task talk mail und only office only office ist diese geschichte die angeblich so für
für nahe halt für office 365 konkurrenz sorgen soll bin leider noch ein bisschen skeptisch
aber wir gucken uns das ganze an ich habe es noch nie ausprobiert auch bei den alten
versionen nicht hat hatte eine erfahrung mit euch habt ihr das schon mal getestet hier
und die office ob das was taugt läuft ganz gut wie gesagt ihr wisst ja ich verwende überhaupt
kein office wenn sich nicht vermeiden lässt für nix ich bin jetzt was office anwendung
angeht nicht gerade der experte
installt ja war immer im docker immer im eigentlichen docker compose file was ich bei mir gerade
auf dem server lesen habe auf dem server liegen habt da ist da ist noch eine load balancer
davor also noch noch ein proxy davor deswegen hat es mit den ports kann ich hingehauen
finde sie feil besser als next cloud sie feil wollte ich auch noch mal ausprobieren habe
ich noch gar nichts mitgemacht läuft das next cloud zeug sein über apache ja also anscheinend
ist stand ein bisschen apache davor weil irgendwas muss den pp krab ja starten community documents
aber bin ja mal echt gespannt wie gut das funktioniert wir können sie hier einfach
ausprobieren ich meine ich kann es nicht von außen freigeben dass ihr drin rum tippen
könnt allein schon aus dem grund weil dann irgendwelche leute direkt wieder irgendwie
titten und dick pics rein copy pasten das war ich jetzt schon ich kenne den twitch chat
deswegen mache ich einfach mal zwei browser fenster auf nebeneinander und wir arbeiten
es zusammen keine eier ja picks ich leute ich kenne im discord den weeps bm channel und
ich weiß was da einige posten ich weiß auch dass sofort sobald ich das freigeben würde
die leute komische komische dinger posten würden garantiert stimmt wo ist das die baro
eigentlich aha was ist der unterschied zwischen cola borra und on the office ich habe mich
dann null mit beschäftigt ehrlich gesagt was macht er da eigentlich im hintergrund so
lang macht er macht auch gar nix vielleicht sollte man was dort bei cpu machen ok doch
installiert scheint ja hochkomplex zu sein was er da installiert was ist liegt was was
habe ich wieder liegt leute der provokateur was habe ich liegt von ks installiert dass
er installiert wikipedia wahrscheinlich weil wir könnten ja mal gucken was er so macht
ist das install ist das da sehen wir ein bisschen iow und zeugs oh er ist fertig siehst du
man muss ihn bloß anthronen mit man guckt mal nach was er so macht schon funktioniert
ist das da eigentlich ist fertig kommt kaum gucken wir nach was er macht ist er fertig
excellent blauer hintergrund exquisite gehört das so kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen dass
das so gehört das gehört im leben doch nicht so oder next next start huge da sind wir
vor ein jahr png das wollte ich schon immer mal excellent leute excellent ich meine das
könnte aus dem game sein mittlerweile kann man das schwierig noch unterscheiden welches
texture pack ist das rtx on hat er hier eindeutig das eindeutig rtx on so wie macht man denn
jetzt die geschichte mit zusammenarbeiten im bei text dokumenten ok das heißt wir brauchen
auf jeden fall schon mal einen zweiten user dass wir das ordentlich testen können users
dann machen wir mal hier einen anonymen anonymen tap auf dass man das auch ausprobieren kann
neuer user ja kann max passwort huge passwort 123456 email brauchen wir nicht passwort
8 charakters der ist noch so secure 123456789 jawoll was rein was ist da los ich darf das
passwort nicht nehmen wenn programme mitdenken wollen immer huge security ok dann das passwort
wird jetzt ja ja 123 ausrufe zeichnen perfekt perfekt ausrufe zeichnen ok also log in max
ah ja ja 123 ausrufe zeichnen so jetzt muss ich mal gucken wie das funktioniert ich mache
es mal komplett noob style ja ich gucke es mir gar nicht an ich mache einfach mal so
wie ich das jetzt intuitiv wie ich das machen würde also ich würde ein text dokument anlegen
oder document hier document lege ich an hier keine ahnung cute chat cute document what
ripp ripp geht nicht warum nicht es ist immer stimmt überhaupt nicht wir haben extra 16
bitcoin installiert guck mal wir haben wir das stimmt überhaupt nicht das ist jebait
nextcloud vielleicht muss man aber speziell das angeben aber 32 spit docker läuft docker
als 32 mit kein schimmer ich würde davon ausgehen wo sehe ich das überhaupt ich habe
keine dieses problem hat sich mir noch nie gestellt wo sehe ich das überhaupt na docker
ist egal es ist egal was docker für eine für eine version hat für was es ist egal
was docker für eine für eine für eine architektur hat wichtig ist was nextcloud was der container
hat und wahrscheinlich ist der container 32 spit docker info aber das ist eigentlich
egal was docker läuft ja arsch 64 nextcloud docker 64 bit 64 ah guck mal da da muss ich
irgendwas angeben kann das sein wie machen wir das jetzt wie wie wie verklicke ich dem
jetzt dass der 16 spit 16 spit starten soll so ported architektur das muss man bestimmt
irgendwo angeben ich brauche arm 64 v8 kann man das irgendwie angeben irgendwo wie gibt
man das an ich würde jetzt ja ich würde ja eigentlich erwarten dass der standardmäßig
das nimmt was ich installiert habe leute habe ich habe ich den graben schon installiert
bevor wir das auf 64 bit kernel geswitcht haben oder danach echt habe ich das davor
gemacht ah ja gut daran könnte das natürlich liegen dann dann schmeißen wir das jetzt
noch mal alles weg dann löschen wir es einfach noch mal sehr easy docker war vor kernel switch
das image manifest support platforms von was ist das
ah muss die jamme also sprich sowas hier im endeffekt muss man das irgendwie hinter
das image machen neue emotes da kann ich nur das hier zu sagen docker compose
okay wir gucken jetzt noch mal schnell wenn man den kram jetzt startet noch mal neu funktioniert
only office überhaupt auf armen kein schimmer ich hätte eigentlich erwartet dass wenn man
wenn die offizielle docker container haben muss sie das fett bewerben dass das einfach
geht
nach muss man das davor schreiben muss man das so machen vielleicht soll das so machen
ich habe das noch nie gemacht das problem hatte ich bisher nie so vielleicht ah ah yes excellent
exquisite docker pull
schauen ob das jetzt klappt das ist für mich neuland hier leute so wie das internet für
uns alle nahezu alle zumindest was breitbandausbau angeht ich hatte das problem noch nie dass
ich die das dass meine container der falschen architektur wie geht das überhaupt wie geht
das geht doch gar nicht leute das kann doch das kann doch eigentlich gar nicht sein ich
kann doch gar kein container 32 bitt starten auf dem 64 bit kernel wie soll das gescheit
von wie soll das gehen na wobei doch 32 bitts nachher auf dem 64 bit kernel wüsste ja wahrscheinlich
funkt ich habe mich da nie mit beschäftigt das müsste ja wahrscheinlich gehen weil normalerweise
also bei den ganzen container geschichten ist es ja so du verwendest ja immer den host kernel
das heißt du kannst eigentlich da gar nichts spezielles machen vielleicht geht es auch
einfach vielleicht ist die die fehlermeldung einfach auch kacke gewesen nextcloud 18 doch
mal mal raspberry only office schau mal mal aha was der doch
was
die fehlermeldung ist einfach nur kacke die fehlermeldung ist einfach nur müll auch mal
erst wer erst rühren sie rühren sie die werbetrommel ja und wahrscheinlich einer
der am meisten eingesetzten plattform geht nicht leute wisst ihr was wir machen habe ich
noch genug platz wir machen uns einfach eine ubuntu vm das wird eng das wird eng mit der
ubuntu vm leute das wird knapp habe ich noch ein bisschen was löschen monka festplatte
voll machen wir einen clean up her kann ich machen naja hälfte grenzen oder clean up system files
und jetzt nicht so wirklich viel zu cleanen was es hier gibt oder hält sich hält sich in grenzen
328 b who cares juck das macht jetzt auch nicht fett dabei quatsch das liegt ich weiß ja woran
es liegt ich habe einfach so viel kram installiert aber ist kein problem mit wir kommen mit acht
gigabyte mit acht gigabyte kommen wir aus für den ubuntu das war kein problem was okay das
funktioniert hier drauf schon mal nicht das natürlich doof das hätten wir vielleicht mal
das hätte man vielleicht mal von Anfang an nachgucken müssen aber installiert es ist kein
problem wir installieren uns einfach wir installieren uns einfach nur ubuntu vm alles kein ding
ubuntu server download wir brauchen den alternate installer weil der neue ubuntu server installer
krepp ist kommen wir nehmen den arten wir nehmen den lts aber reicht für unsere zwecke auch wobei
nie wir nehmen den wir nehmen leute wir nehmen den da haben wir eine neuere docker version bild in
was ubuntu live iso moment nein nein nein warum lädt das live iso unter
ja den brauer dass sie das mittlerweile so versteckt haben in der acht quatsch nicht arm
ja den brauer
dauernd also zeug ja hier deep in weg haben wir schon mal ein bisschen mehr Platz bitte
okay naja nachdem der raspberry pi jetzt ja eh nur rum steht können wir noch mal soll
ich noch irgendwas will irgendjemand noch mal was getestet haben auf eine raspberry
pi 4 will er irgendwie noch was wissen was was er vielleicht wissen muss dass er sich ankauft hast du deinen
neuen rechner schon zusammen nähen und ich ich lasse es auch erst mal ich lasse es auch erst mal
ja ich weiß dass der next cloud container nicht ab ist wir können ja auch nicht verwenden weil
die die office geschichte auf armen plattform nicht funktioniert ich lasse ihn jetzt einfach
im hintergrund mal laufen und wir schauen mal wie warm das ding wird
wir können was ist bench cpu wie ging das noch mal
cpu suspension ist besser als mein komisches improvisiertes improvisiertes bc zeug die gut
läuft in der minecraft sehr auf dem pay wahrscheinlich ziemlich gut hast du einen
kühler auf raspberry pi ja ein passiv kühler unter drüber in den lüfter habe ich heute
zusammengebaut das gehäuse das hier guck aber das kreuz wie gesagt kann ich nicht empfehlen
gefällt mir nicht ok das geht das geht relativ schnell 20.000 prime numbers dürfte dürfte
zackig gehen was für ein os hat denn das ist man manjaro manjaro linux hat so was wie ein
endlos benchmark so ein hit wie macht man denn unter linux habe ich mich noch nie habe ich mir
noch nie angeschaut linux generate cpu heat ich will das ding einfach so so heiß wie möglich wird
stress
bm stress das will ich haben ab install stress
die stress cpu 4
jetzt gibt stress cpu 4 reicht das einfach so easy
macht das ding da am moment ich habe mein bc da noch laufen
wir lassen jetzt mal laufen und gucken wie warm da wird wir lassen jetzt einfach während
wir während wir nextcloud installieren auf der ubuntu kiste lassen wir einfach mal hier im
hintergrund den raspberry pi laufen und mal schauen wie warm der maximal wird
taugt der wasser als retro pi auf dem 3er liefen n64 nicht besonders toll der 4er ist ein bisschen
schneller als der 3er aber das sind jetzt keine welten dazwischen cpu mäßig also generell so
groß ein riesen upgrade ist die hardware nicht das größte der größte unterschied zwischen
raspberry pi 3 und 4 ist eigentlich netzwerk netzwerk aus bi auch und so was der jetzt zum
ersten mal annehmbar schnell ist wenn ich wirklich schnell ist aber annehmbar schnell cpu und der
rest ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel schneller als vorher also sprich wenn der kram vorher nicht
richtig lief ist die chance dass es nachher auch nicht richtig läuft recht hoch ok hat er jetzt
hat er jetzt downgeloaded download ubuntu server iso mir fällt kann ein iso ist das sprechen dass
die coolen leute nicht dann auch eher iso aus also dass das ubuntu iso für den router iso iso
was das das das ist ein terminal mit zsh ja und für vms das ist vor allem
workstation was man jetzt auch hier gleich sehen wird weil die erstellen jetzt eine
neue ubuntu vm wir haben leider nicht so viel festplatten platz also müssen bisschen ein
bisschen genügsam sein ich gebe dem ding mal eine acht gigabyte platte was wird jetzt als
nächstes gemacht naja wir installieren jetzt nextcloud noch mal auf einer ubuntu vm dass
ich eben diese dieses collaboration zeug testen kann was ich ja eigentlich vor hatte so 15
next installieren wir selbst next ubuntu 64 bin nächstes zwei cpus bei reicht wird 1000 ja
gut natt wunderbar kein pritsch pritsch network dass man auch ordentlich drauf zukramen kann man
weiß ja nie genau next next next zwanzig g bis sie bis sie bis sie groß war 12 12 g single
fall disk space now aber nicht allocate next finish gut schauen wir mal schauen wir mal
wie das jetzt unter ubuntu funktioniert das geht jetzt relativ schnell weil es dann auch
performance mäßig auf einem desktop bis sie schneller läuft und wir eigentlich nichts
großartig machen muss außer install install und gut ist iso iso start englisch ist ok
install ubuntu server denkst du das neue s rock x 5 7 0 d 4 1 2 t 90 als möglich kleines server
board nachdem ich selbstverständlich genau weiß was da drauf ist sage ich einfach mal ja muss ich
mal gucken portugalina they said in an official blog post they want to be an alternative to
office 365 but i don't think it will be an alternative also aber das ding war englisch
install your language europe ich will eigentlich nur deutsch dings hier ich will eigentlich nur
meine meine passende tastatur auswählen yes yes yes yes haben wir kein french keyboard kein
baguette keyboard next weiter wubbler aus englisch alle deswegen habe ich aber sprache nicht
eigentlich im streben wie hat der öttinger mal erzählt and in my home country barten württemberg
we say we are all sitting in one boat also besser als der krieg ich das noch in tote tasten
eliminieren ja hausnahme ubuntu passt test 123456 huge passwort yes auf jeden fall wollen wir das
week passwort verwenden mark week pass passports also next cloud hub ist ein office 365 welches
man selbst das sagen sie das sagen sie ich glaube es ja nicht wirklich das sagen sie halt zumindest
in ihrem blog post wie schön schnell das installiert im vergleich zum rest arena so lang sind wir
eigentlich schon die zeit geht immer rum ist richtig schön schnell im vergleich zum rest
arena flutscht jetzt flutscht richtig
ok nein kein proxy weiter was macht eigentlich unser respekt gerade von der tastatur her
was habe ich für scheiß von der voller temperatur her 53 grad ok wärmer wird es wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr auf dem raspberry funktioniert nicht auf dem raspberry da funktioniert die
only office geschichte nicht kann es da kann ja mach automatisch dns server ssh aber kein dns warum
ubuntu ich mag weil ich ubuntu server mag ich mag ubuntu server bin ubuntu fan außer auf dem
desktop lustigerweise auf der arbeit haben wir nur rettet was viele im enterprise umfeld haben da
ist rettet ziemlich ziemlich weit verbreitet war vielen hostern ist es tatsächlich debian
das stimmt ich persönlich mag ubuntu server einen großen vorteil der ubuntu server hat gerade
von heim gebrauch ist finde ich dass viele sachen dabei sind die das gewöhnt ihr doch mal bitte
umfeld ab so 2019 was sprichst du als im enterprise umfeld heißt also wie willst du es denn sonst
nennen man könnte natürlich auch in der hutschlinux am server hinzulegen klar kann man alles machen aber das ist dafür nur wirklich nicht gedacht
er hat auch mord heimer sagt bei ihm auf der arbeit gibt es auch noch rettet das
lot ist das ist es lottricks linux rettet kannst du bei vm eigentlich komprimierte disk images erstellen mit
kvm kann man zum beispiel die dinger ich glaube die sind sogar standardmäßig schon komprimiert
kennst du eine gute möglichkeit sich selbst segnierte sicherheitszertifikate für ein
das auszustellen zu generieren brauche das für web darf für windows explorer solange man da nicht
in ein letzter encrypt nehmen kann fällt mir da nichts gutes ein dazu also ich weiß wenn du
es selbst komplett aufstellen also wenn du selbst komplett ausstellen kannst dann ist kein problem
weil dann musst du einfach nur in dein trust store unter windows eben die ca rein machen mit
der du es ausgestellt hast dann kannst du einfach open ssl einfach mit open ssl keys generieren
das ist kein ding wenn du ein richtig echtes gültiges zertifikat brauchst da fällt mir
eigentlich bloß letzten kript ein oder geld ausgeben kann man mit pyson auch klar
ja wie gesagt wenn ihnen gültiges zertifikat brauchen jetzt irgendwas was was dann auch
eine browser akzeptiert dann kommt der netz encrypt nicht vorbei was haben wir für eine ip
143 step auf was war es 143 huge secure passport so da sind wir erstmal update machen und dann
klar man nächstes laut rauf fahren hast du studiert max nie habe ich nicht ich habe 2007
ausbildung gemacht ist schon bis hierher wenn ihr auch wuppe wuppe old
also wenn du wie gesagt wenn du letztendlich verwenden kannst dann ist das würde ich dann
mit was machen das ist relativ simpel mit zertbord mit zertbord kannst du nämlich auch über dns
challenge dir für interne sachen was ausstellen ohne dass der webserver öffentlich stehen muss
du brauchst halt nur die domain die muss dir gehören bzw du brauchst zugriff auf den dns
server der für die domain zuständig ist dann kannst du das machen was machst du auf der
arbeit wenn dich das interessiert kann ich dir empfehlen ich habe ein video zugemacht auf
youtube das da da lasse ich mich 14 minuten drüber aus was ich auf der arbeit mache also
wenn sie interessiert kannst du einfach angucken ja zertbord geht ohne zugriff von außen das
funktioniert du kannst mit ich kann es dir mal zeigen nicht aber ich kann jetzt kann
dir zeigen was du machen musst du kannst mit letztendlich kannst du dns challenge machen
das funktioniert dann folgendermaßen mal gucken ob sie irgendwie gescheites bild oder so für
gibt ja das bild ist jetzt nicht wirklich schön so halb so halbweg also schönes bild
ist es nicht das geht du brauchst aber den dns aber dafür die domain zuständig ist das
ist wichtig oder du machst dir du machst hier in eine kostenlose domain bei einem dünn dns
anbieter aber du brauchst auf jeden fall ein dns der für die domain zuständig ist und dann
gehst du in zertbord und sagst du möchtest als challenge dns verwenden und dann gibt er dir
einen token aus und dieses token musst du auf deinem dns als txt record hinterlegen und dann
sagst du eben ja habe ich gemacht weiter aber vorher würde ich erst mal testen ob es auch
funktioniert und wenn du es als txt record hinterlegt hast dann checkt er das das heißt
man braucht kein webserver öffentlich habe ich für mein ganzes zeug gemacht ja das ist
richtig das habe ich für mein ganzes zeug intern gemacht und ich habe es auch so automatisch
ich mache ja ich nehme ja mittlerweile den cloudflare dns für mein zeug der ist kostenlos
der cloudflare dns der hat eine ziemlich gute api und ich habe es dazu eingerichtet dass die
paar services die ich habe die laufen halt hinter einem reverse proxy und der reverse proxy ist so
eingestellt dass der automatisch die zertifikate über let's encrypt dns challenge erneuert weil
zertbot hat nen cloudflare plugin genau also ich nehme zertbot mit dem dns cloudflare plugin
und dann macht er das automatisch ja ne eben nicht sag ich doch grad er macht das automatisch
peter einfickert bester dankeschön für den sub huge mit dem cloudflare plugin für dns
challenge ist überhaupt kein ding machst du stellst du dir einmal aus und dann guckt der
automatisch bei mir nach und update den kram paar tage bevor es ausläuft überhaupt kein problem ich
habe das jetzt schon seit einem halben jahr oder neun monaten oder so laufen und ich wusste
noch nicht einmal zertifikate wieder von hand
choose my name das funktioniert nicht das muss öffentlich erreichbar also nicht erreichbar das
muss öffentlich auflösbar sein weil ja der dns der der let's encrypt server also der let's encrypt
zertifikat ausstellungsdienst der macht ja einen look ab und guckt danach liegt auf dem dns server
der für diese domain zuständig ist wo ich ein zertifikat ausstellen soll liegt dort
nen txt record mit dem geheimen mit dem geheimen token mit dem geheimen passport quasi drinne
ich mache keine wildcard zertifikate könnte man machen habe ich aber nicht weil das ist
ganz gut integriert in das gar nicht diese ganze docker und reverse proxy geschichte
sobald ich neuen container anlege mit neuem namen dann stellt er automatisch
let's encrypt zertifikat für diesen container aus das ist echt praktisch ok also ab install
docker compose wir machen es das gleiche wir machen das gleiche wie auf dem raspberry wir
kopieren uns jetzt nehme ich einfach den kram ist die maus überhaupt an lull ich habe wie gesagt
ich habe früher wildcard zertifikate gemacht aber so finde ich viel praktischer man muss
ein bisschen aufpassen mit let's encrypt wenn man gar so sehr viel probiert und neu erstellt
man gerät auch ab und zu mal gerne an das wochen limit für domains wenn man zu viel rum probiert
aber an sie an sich sind die limits bei let's encrypt ziemlich großzügig ich habe also ich
verwende zwei sachen ich verwende für alles was nicht container ist eigentlich immer nginx aber
für alles container zeug nämlich mittlerweile traffic weil es super integriert ist das ist
halt total einfach damit da sagst du einfach hier container mit diesem label und dann dann
kannst du sogar automatisch let's encrypt zeug machen lassen und sowas das ist halt echt praktisch
also traffic für alles was container ist und nginx für alles was so ist für für sachen die von
außen erreichbar sind prinzipiell nginx das geht auch also man kann man kann ein bisschen
tricksen das haben wir ich verwende plane docker ich habe daheim kein kubernetes oder
irgendwas anderes weiß ich was ich mache ich habe docker compose file dass ich den kram halt
wieder herstellen kann mit meiner ein wie gesagt ich habe ja bei mir daheim hier mein setup schon
deutlich entschlagt im vergleich zu den letzten jahren das jetzt nur noch eine kleine kiste die
hier übrig geblieben ist von dem von dem kleinen also in dem rack ich habe es ja mal im video
gezeigt da ist jetzt nicht mehr die große kiste ist weg und da brauche ich keinen keine
irgendwelche hypervisor nicht hypervisor hyperscaler nennt man sie ja keine orchestrierung
geschichten und sonst was da ist nur botu server drauf da ist man docker compose file drauf und
da ist ein system ssd drinne und eine platte für backups und und und zeug fertig war es also ich
habe es deutlich vereinfacht jetzt zum spielen ist es cooler stimmt spielen ist das natürlich
nice das paste so eins müssen wir bloß noch mal weg machen das hier so und jetzt kommt der moment
der wahrheit gucke ob es funktioniert moment was ich da mache ist blödsinn wir tun mal so
als sind wir noch auf meinem raspberry mal gucken ob die nächste laut jetzt funktioniert
ja ach genau was ich sagen wollte zuletzt ein kryptos haben wir einmal ja auch schon im stream
gemacht es gibt ja die variante dass du dass man ein bisschen trickst also sprich man kann sich bei
einem entweder hat man eine domain und wenn man kann oder wenn man keine domain hat kann man
sich bei irgendeinem dns anbieter einfach eine anlegen ja zum beispiel dac dns wie einer ist
übrigens auch mein bevorzugter dns wenn ich wenn ich ein verwende dann den hat eben auch
jemand im chat geschrieben da kann man sich da eine domain anlegen und dann stellst du dir die das
das zertifikat stellst du dir aus für die domain und danach biegst du einfach intern in einem dns
das um auf eine interne ip und fertig
und und schon kann es das zertifikat intern verwenden aber ich kann euch prinzipiell zu
empfehlen weil die domain sind alle schwierig zu merken der domain kostet nicht mehr viel
bezahlst du keine ahnung 7 7 euro im jahr für eine für eine domain die nicht gerade punkt die
ist oder irgendwas was begehrt ist du zahlst sieben euro im jahr hast du eine eigene domain und
ihr könnt den größten bullshit ever in diese in diese kontaktfelder reinschreiben das juckt
die überhaupt nicht da ist es das juckt die überhaupt nicht ihr braucht kein ihr braucht kein wie nennen sie das wie
heißt das noch mal diese who is protection brauchst du nicht schreibt einfach irgendein bullshit rein
ich habe die domains jetzt schon ein paar jahre es hat noch keinen gejuckt dass ich da absolut
unrealistische dinger reingeschrieben habe ja ich weiß theoretisch braucht man es und und
theoretisch muss man es auch und theoretisch könnte einem auch die domain weggenommen werden was
nicht macht aber du gehst ja die die domain anbieter wären bescheuert euch zu sperren deswegen
wenn ihr euch sperren bezahlt ihr kein geld mehr ok also atmen 123456 yes finish auf geht's ex
excellent so jetzt muss es funktionieren jetzt muss es funktionieren wir sind auf x64 wir sind
auf einem aktuellen ubuntu wir haben alles installiert was wir installieren müssen ha top was macht
der da im hintergrund er folgt sich atmen mit schlechtem password punktiert aber neue user
nicht ja man muss kommt man muss halt manchmal kompromisse eingehen sie habt ihr gesehen wie
viel schneller das ist hier drauf als er auf dem raspberry pi start next cloud ok also news document
jetzt funktioniert es leute jetzt funktioniert also ich habe meine domain hier kann ich aber auch
nur bedingt empfehlen ich habe die damals genommen weil die mit abstand die billigsten waren die
waren so übertrieben billig muss man hier ein bisschen was zu machen die waren so übertrieben
billig da habe ich mein brain ausgesetzt ja so bevor wir anfangen müssen wir erstmal noch
neuen user anlegen user was hier new user ja max password was hatten wir für ein password 123 ich
kann ja mal schreiben ja ja ja ausrufe zeichen yes incognito window ja ja ja 123 ausrufe zeichen
achso ok also jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wie gut das funktioniert da mal gucken ob das wirklich
eine alternative zu office ist ich bin ja ich bin ja noch sehr skeptisch ja aber sie sagen das ja
selbst kann man das hier irgendwie einklappen ne ah perfekt was ist nächst laut wenn ich fragen
darf der name cloud ist ein bisschen irreführend eigentlich ist es einen file sink sowas sowas
wie sowas wie dropbox ja es ist im prinzip einen file sink mit einem web interface was
bisschen was kann also cloud ist ist eigentlich gar nicht mehr so die richtige bezeichnung dafür
so also wir haben jetzt hier q chat wie kann man das scheren scheren hier scheren mit scheren mit
max jawoll jetzt ist es geschehen jetzt müsste ich es hier sehen oder ja ja ja so und jetzt kann
man kann man es jetzt zusammen bearbeiten guckt mal leute das funktioniert richtig gut
sowas kann man da drin jetzt machen also ihr wisst ja ich verwende kein office ich kann es
nicht oft genug sagen also dementsprechend habe ich auch kein kein plassen schimmer davon was man
jetzt mal schönes ausprobieren könnte hier meine sie wort art wort wort art cute chat also als
erstes brauchen wir erst mal image copy image kann man das hier einfügen loading image braucht
so eine excel schulung leute das habe ich geschickt um schiff mit der excel schulung auf
der arbeit ich habe einfach nix mehr geschrieben hier das funktioniert so schon mal nicht gibt
das ganze auch transparent war es haben wir schon mal das erste problem das scheiß funktioniert
nicht funktioniert schon mal net schon mal kaputt funktioniert das so ne
das leute so popelige sachen wie bilder einfügen funktionieren schon mal nicht was sollen was
sollen das geben wenn es fertig ist wir sollen das verwenden wenn bilder einfügen nicht funktioniert
ok save image dann gucken wir erst mal ja dann gucken wir erst mal ob man das vielleicht so
hochladen kann nehmen bild was im next cloud filesystem zu finden das wird schon das das
muss ja funktionieren aber trotzdem fail dass es nicht klappt wie würde ich denn hier jetzt
ein bild hinzufügen feil wie fühle ich wie fühle ich denn hier ein bild ihr wisst ja ich
bin der absolute office profi was so was angeht insert insert image from feil excellent excellent
musik down los muss man da ja ja da ist es hier das funktioniert und hier das auch aktualisiert
ok wo ist mein fenster hin das fenster ist einfach verschwunden
wie sehr lasste das eigentliche raspberry aus keine ahnung das läuft ich auf dem raspberry
wir haben es probiert auf dem raspberry zum laufen zu bekommen aber es wird nicht unterstützt auf
Okay also das gemeinsam editieren funktioniert ganz okay, wenn ich hier hinten was mache.
Ach guck mal hier sieht man auch wo man editiert.
Ist so eigentlich ganz nett.
Okay so Insert Image, oh Chart, das ist für die ganzen Business Leute ist das unglaublich
wichtig.
Wir brauchen Charts.
Leute Stonks brauchen wir, richtige Stonks, also Pie Chart, Pie Chart, okay, oh Kokona.
Okay, okay, okay, also, Alter wie editiert man das, okay also ist das hier orange, blue,
ne, bestes Chart überhaupt, da wäre man sonst nie drauf gekommen, oh blau ist orange und
blue ist, oh das ist, das ist, das ist brainfuck jetzt Leute, kann man das overlayen, kann
ich jetzt, kann ich jetzt aja ja klein machen und da oben drüber machen, ne, ne, ne, das
wäre zu nett, das wäre zu, zu advanced, Chart Title, Lull W größer keck W, okay es funktioniert
prinzipiell, ne, mir gefallen die Listen hier oben nicht wirklich, oh Word Art Leute wir
brauchen ein Word Art unbedingt, Word Art ist huge, important für alle Business Stonks
Leute die brauchen das, Word Art, jawoll, beste, ohne Word Art geht gar nichts hier,
share es mal public und lass den Chat editieren, das ist bei mir im Internet, ich könnte es
nicht mal public share, Word Art, das ist aber kein richtiges Word Art, richtiges Word Art
muss gebogen sein und hässlich, ja genau Churok, das muss gebogen sein, geht das vielleicht,
ne, aber ist doch ganz nett, also wenn man Office Sachen braucht, kann man es doch dafür
verwenden, so wir machen jetzt mal, wir machen jetzt mal ne Präsentation, mal gucken ob das
funktioniert, ich muss übrigens im Chat ein paar Dinge übersehen, ich muss mal kurz Chat
hochscrollen, ne oder, hab doch nix großartig übersehen, also falls ich was übersehen
hab, muss ich jetzt noch mal kurz in Chat schreiben, na klar neugst laut Internet Zugriff, wer
das hier, das ist mir zu advanced Office Magic hier, zu advanced Office Magic, oh Leute es
funktioniert, man kann doch ein hässliches Word Art machen, ja, jawoll, da hab ich drauf
gewartet, das brauchen wir, das muss so richtig scheiße aussehen, erst dann ist das ein gutes
Word Art, so und jetzt müssen wir mal den Chat probieren, genau den Chat müssen wir
probieren, cute Chat, send, und wo weiß ich jetzt, dass ich ne Chatnachricht gekriegt hab,
geht nicht, Leute Chat ist kaputt, RIP Chat, geht nicht, seht ihr das Leute, Chat ist kaputt,
cute Chat, ja, also Chat, Chat geht nicht, Chat ist hinüber, aber man kann doch hier
oben bestimmt Chatten irgendwie, facks, jetzt guck mal hier oben hab ich jetzt nen Kontakt
gefunden, ne, aber was bringt es mir, dass ich nen Kontakt gefunden hab, wenn ich damit
überhaupt nix machen kann, guck mal, ich hab nen Kontakt gefunden, mit dem ich absolut
nichts machen kann, wo ist der da, all contacts, new contact, es könnte auch sein, das liegt
daran, weil ich Admin bin, warte mal, ich leg mir nochmal nen User an, noch nen zweiten
Test User, facks zwei, aja ja, eins, zwei, drei, funktioniert die, die Suche probieren
wir dann gleich, die Suche war nämlich bisher immer Müll, ups, aja ja, eins, zwei, drei,
eins, zwei, drei, eins, zwei, drei, eins, zwei, fünf, spazieren die, die mlests Instrumental
zeige, download safe, next, next, next, create document, presentation machen wir jetzt, so
scheren wir mit max 2, shared mit max 1. Perfekt. Ah, exzellent. Presentation, da ist es. Okay.
Funktioniert, sehr gut. Soll ich ein bisschen kleiner machen? Wie man sieht. So, wie kann
man das jetzt schön hässlich machen? Äh. Äh. Igitt. Das sieht ja wirklich aus wie 1995,
äh. Also wenn ich so eine Präsentation zu sehen bekomme, da muss ich ja, da muss ich
instant Kotzreflex, äh. So, geht dann, geht dann hier da. Igitt sieht das eklig aus. Meine
Güte. Bäh. Insert. Textart. Wir müssen, wir müssen hässliches Wordart hin machen.
Okay, das sieht hier schon wieder ganz anders aus als beim anderen. So, geht der Chat hier
jetzt? Chat. Chat. Du Chat. Nö. Warte, der Chat, der Chat ist RIP. Der Chat ist RIP,
der funktioniert nicht. Das ist ja schon mal sehr, ähm, ernüchternd. Dass nicht mal so
grundlegende Sachen funktionieren. Was machen die Temperatur vom Raspberry? Gucken wir mal.
Jetzt mal 64 Grad. Uplog. Oh Leute, das kann sein mit Uplog. Bevor ich jetzt den Kram hier
flame. Ähm. Nee, nee. Nee. Aber wir reloaden das trotzdem mal ohne Uplog. Wir, wir, wir
reloaden das mal ohne Uplog. Und gucken, ob es dann funktioniert. Chat sollte auf der
rechten Seite zu sehen sein. Wat? Der Chat sollte hier zu sehen sein, oder? Warum sollte
ich hier was in den Chat schreiben und es nicht hier sehen? Das wäre ja komplett wir. Außer
rechts sehe ich auch nichts hier, Chat. Cute, cute Chatt. Huge Presentation Mode, Leute.
Bam. Nee, nee, nee. Also der Chat ist, der Chat ist kaputt, der funktioniert nicht. Contacts.
Warum ist in den Contacts, wie, wie edde, wie edde ich denn Leute zu meinen Contacts? Wie
fun, wie funktioniert das? Okay, verschieben wir den Kram hier mal. Wie funktioniert das
überhaupt? Ähm, hier. Kann man auch nicht anklicken, oder? Wie, wie edde ich Leute zu
Meinen feinen kontext da kam immer nix an klicken
Im kontaktentap nicht ich will ich will ich will ich will max 1 n
Weil hier oben ist ja max 1 aber aber mit dem kann ich ja überhaupt nix machen da kann ich auch nicht chatten oder so
Chat
Ok dann schauen wir mal ob die ob die volltextsuche funktioniert
Ok hier haben wir ne README, README, ok README MD also da schreiben wir es mal, LULW ist größer, KEKW
Twitch, Chat, Chat Beste, Omega LUL speichern
Open sidebar, wie man das machen kann. So jetzt haben wir das gespeichert, jetzt hoffe ich dass ich das über die suche finde
Sollen wir mal über die suche
Suche, Chat, die suche ist immer noch Müll
Ach ne Moment hat er das jetzt gefunden
Ich glaube da hat es gefunden, vergesst mal, ich glaube da hat es gefunden
Ne ne das ist noch das alte
Vielleicht, ja ich gucke mal gleich beim admin account ob man das irgendwie aktivieren muss was ist das hier oben eigentlich warum
Warum steht das da immer noch da?
Kann das mal weggehen
Was ist das da oben warum steht das da
Da
Hä was ist das hier oben warum steht es hier oben da
Was ist das überhaupt warum warum warum warum steht das da
Ach weil ich in dem ordner drinne bin oder was ah ok
Eieiei ok das ergibt Sinn, Chat
Nope die suche ist immer noch kaputt
Die suche ist immer noch kaputt
Ok ich lösch mal den ganzen kram da standardmäßig drauf ist vielleicht vielleicht geht es ja nicht nicht richtig
Äh ne ähm Moment wie löst man überhaupt noch mal
Ne actions
Massive brain
New folder kann man mal notes geben wir mal rein jetzt machen wir es ganz einfach neues textdokument
Chat punkt txt ganz billig
123 chat twitch chat LUL
poggers
POG
So das heißt er sollte jetzt ja was finden wenn ich jetzt chat suche sollte er das hier finden
Chat na gut jetzt findet er die die datei wollen wir ja nicht nach twitch muss ich suchen
Ok
Das
Ne das steht immer da das steht der findet es nicht die die die volltext suche ist ist kaputt
Die volltext suche ist kaputt
Die funktioniert wieder nicht das war das ist immer das ist eines der
Meiner größten problem mit nextcloud gewesen dass die volltext suchen nie funktioniert und wozu brauche ich sowas ohne volltext suche ich weiß
noch nicht wo man soll klickt
Keck
Ok die suche funktioniert nicht
Vielleicht müssen wir die suche noch einschalten
Und vielleicht müssen wir auch den chat noch einschalten also werden wir noch mal atmen mit big brain passport
Example md haben wir hier documents kann ich mal noch documents vielleicht suchen
Dokument doch doch sollte er eigentlich auch finden
Ne
Also die suche ist nach wie vor müll vielleicht muss man aber noch irgendwas aktivieren search
Suche
Seht ihr es irgendwo also ich sehe meine suche hier unten ich habe
Overview
Vielleicht hier vielleicht muss man den kram noch irgendwie einschalten
Support
Sharing
Steht da irgendwas von chat
Dark mode
Ne da kann man nur das da ändern
Security
Wie aktiviert man die suche
Watt
Ich dachte das ist mittlerweile alles eingebaut
Ich will nicht 20 Sachen dazu installieren müssen
Und ich will garantiert mir keinen Elasticsearch selbst installieren müssen
Ich meine, sind die noch bei Trost?
Ich will mir noch keinen Elasticsearch selbst installieren müssen, dass ich meine Datei durchsuchen kann
Dann muss es irgendwie anders funktionieren
Okay, was gibt es denn noch für Apps?
Also Contacts ist ja schonmal irgendwie komisch
Ich dachte mir, ich kann Max jetzt eine Chatnachricht schreiben
Aber irgendwie irgendwie nicht
Wir müssen bestimmt noch irgendwelche Talk Apps und so installieren
Talk ist ja Talk halt
Wow, ein Error funktioniert ja erst rein
Ah, jetzt einfach zweimal klicken
Chat
Das geht schon mal gar nicht mehr, die Chat App
Okay, wir haben Talk, dann probieren wir das jetzt aus
Talk, wo ist Talk? Hier, Talk
Max
Hallo, Max
Achso, ich muss mich erst mal einloggen
Ob das jetzt funktioniert
Ah, hier
Und man kriegt es auch hier oben angezeigt
Okay, das ist tatsächlich ganz nett
So, kriege ich jetzt eine neue Nachricht zugestellt
Wenn ich jetzt hier oben sage, keine neuen Message
Ach komm, Leute, warum kriege ich keine
Warum No Notifications, ich habe eine neue Chatnachricht gekriegt
Das ist so hakelig, der Kram
Das ist doch nicht ernsthaft eine Alternative zu irgendwas, was funktioniert
Muss ich im Talk Reiter sein, ja, es wäre total beknackt, wenn ich im Talk Reiter sein muss
Hier hat das erkannt, dass ich neue Messages brauche
All Messages, Chat Notifications
Ist an
Oh, gibt nichts
Was, ich habe, ich habe doch nicht Notifications disabled
Ich habe gesagt, Dismiss all Notifications
Ich habe keine Notifications disabled
Okay, um
Tja, wie machen wir das jetzt, okay, mal mal add
Add Max
Blob
Hallo
WTF
Add Max
Ah, das klappt, guckt, das funktioniert
Wenn man, wenn man erwähnt wird, funktioniert, okay
Das ist, das ist sogar in Ordnung
Jetzt kann ich die Notifications nicht mehr dismissen
Ach, jetzt, okay, View Chat
Ja, gut, doch, das ist ganz okay
Start Call, ich rufe mich jetzt mal selbst an
Ah, yes, excellent
Excellent Talk
Nachrichten vom Admin brauchen wir eigentlich, ne, das ist komplett overrated
Was natürlich viel cooler wäre, wenn man das sehen könnte
Während man gerade editiert, ne
Also sprich, wenn wir hier gerade, wenn man hier gerade am editieren ist
Machen wir das Ganze noch mal
Ich share, ich share noch mal was
Shareen wir noch mal mit, äh, mir
Vielleicht geht das jetzt, wenn man, wenn man schon zusammen im Chat ist
Man könnte, man könnte einfach so machen, ne
Lul
Also hier, add Max
Alterlar, was geht
Hallo
So wirklich konsistent ist das Ganze nicht
Was, Chat rechts?
Ah, hier
Discuss this file
Discuss
Ja, aber man kriegt ja davon überhaupt nichts mit
Ach guck mal
Da ist die Notification
Nice
Dismiss
Weißt, ich kann jetzt auch hier sagen
Ah, ne, Moment
Wie bin ich da jetzt hier noch mal drauf gekommen
Ah, hier, comments, Chat
This file sucks
Ah, yes
Excellent
Pfeifert
Nein
Geht Emojis? Nein, geht nicht
Ah, ja, gut
Ah, ja, okay, also
So behelfsmäßig, wenn man, wenn man unbedingt Office braucht
Und Part 2 keine Kohle ausgeben will für was
Dann kann man das verwenden
Kann das sein, dass der Chat
Dass dieser Chat hier dann da landet
Ne, der Chat hier funktioniert einfach mal prinzipiell gar nicht
Und hier kann ich ja auch nicht in den
Kann ich hier in den Chat
Ah
Ja, so funktioniert das
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt hier, hier rumeditieren
Also ich kann jetzt hier rumeditieren und neben sehe ich den Chat
Ich editiere jetzt hier mal rum und wenn jetzt der Admin was schreibt
Dann bist du fertig
Dann ploppt das hier auf
Das ist doch ganz gut
So viele Chats bin verwirrt
Ja, ich finde auch die Oberfläche könnte ein bisschen
Noob freundlicher gestaltet werden
Ich meine, es gibt einen Chat hier, der nicht funktioniert
Der ist einfach defekt, der geht einfach gar nicht
Der ist einfach nicht vorhanden, der Chat
Es gibt den Talk Chat
Und es gibt den Chat zu einem jeweiligen Pfeil
Das ist schon ein bisschen verwirrend
Was gibt es denn sonst noch für Apps
Ich meine, es wäre cool, wenn hier oben einfach irgendwie Chatnachrichten dann gezeigt werden
Bloop, neue Chatnachricht, kannst du nachgucken
Es gibt in der Mobile App keine, so echt nicht
Wenn es keine SYNC Option, also wenn man nicht SYNCen kann mit der Mobile App
Warum soll man die Mobile App überhaupt verwenden
Nee, Spreadsheet mache ich nicht, das ist mir zu office-mäßig jetzt
Hä, wie, es kann nur Daten SYNCen, aber es gibt keine SYNC Option?
Verstehe nicht
Wenn man Daten SYNCen kann, hat es doch die Option zu SYNCen
Was?
Oder meinst du, es gibt keine Optionen für dieses SYNCronisieren
Also sprich, man kann nichts einstellen beim SYNCronisieren
Ok Leute, ich muss euch sagen, diese Präsentationsvorlagen, die sehen echt schlecht aus
Die sehen wirklich grausam aus
Boah, wie gehts
Geh fort
So, wir gucken mal, was es sonst noch so für Apps gibt
Was man sonst noch mal ausprobieren könnte
Also das ist ja alles beim Alten hier geblieben
Ich muss euch sagen, es fühlt sich ein bisschen lahm an
Es fühlt sich lahm an, die Oberfläche
Man darf nicht vergessen, das ganze läuft quasi hier auf einer VM
Direkt auf dem gleichen Rechner, also
Das müsste sich eigentlich ziemlich schnell anfühlen
Das sind 1 zu 1 Gruppen von den Powerpoint Vorlagen
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich von Powerpoint 2003 oder so
Also mittlerweile, ich komme ja gerade in den
Genuss, aktuell auf der Arbeit eine Powerpoint Präsentation machen zu dürfen
Mit Powerpoint
Also da bin ich ja schon ganz heiß drauf
Kann mich kaum halten
Vor Freude auf Powerpoint
Und das neue Powerpoint 365
Muss ich zugeben, auch als jemand, der echt nie Office verwendet
Ist ganz in Ordnung
Die Design Vorschläge, die es bringt, sind
Meistens besser als das, was man gebaut hat
Man hat Emojis und
Wichtigste Sache natürlich bei Präsentation
Man hat Emojis und Imagefonts und so
Das neue Powerpoint ist schon ganz gut und läuft halt auch im Browser
Okay, wir gucken jetzt mal, was es für Apps zum Thema Suche gibt
Office und Text Search
Hier, Search haben wir
Full Text Search
Was davon muss ich jetzt aktivieren?
Ich mache neuerdings in jede Präsentation mindestens ein Emoji irgendwo rein
Ich find das wirkt irgendwie 2020
Hier, Enable
Enable
Okay, ist exzellent
Okay, das heißt wir legen jetzt mal ne neue Textdatei an
Search.txt
Oh, ohje, was hab ich jetzt angelegt?
Das muss auch funktionieren, lulw
Bra
Jetzt haben wir das gespeichert und jetzt suchen wir mal
Stop
Da muss man jetzt bestimmt noch irgendwelche Settings auswählen
Also ich würde jetzt eigentlich erwarten, wenn ich jetzt hier nach
lulw suche, finde ich die Datei, mach ich aber nicht
Das heißt jetzt gehen wir mal in die Settings und schauen ob man da noch irgendwas zur Suche einstellen muss
Das war Elastic Search glaube ich, hier auf Full Text Search
Nee
Das ist doof, das ist echt blöd, ich hab keinen Bock mein eigenes Elastic Search zu installieren
Dadurch, dass ich ne Full Text Suche habe, echt nicht
Sowas muss, ja und außerdem könnte man doch ganz simpel einfach
Text durchcrepen, zumindest Bild in anbieten oder, so ne ganz simple Suche die einfach
Alle, alle, alle Text durchcrept für dich würde doch schon reichen
Die meisten Leute haben da ein paar Megabyte Daten drinne und da ist es ultra schnell die Sachen zu crepen
Nextcloud wirkt, wirkt doch, ich mein ich verwende das halt einfach für File Sync schon seit Jahren
Und dafür ist es gut im, also im Kern ist das, funktioniert das
Aber alle anderen Features die jetzt da dabei kommen und so
Ich merke nach ne halben Stunde verwenden, dass es einfach hakt
Das ist, dass es nicht so polished ist irgendwie
Weiß nicht, es ist nicht angenehm zu verwenden das meiste
Für File Sync ist es gut ja, also sprich die Kerndisziplin mit File Sync das ist in Ordnung
Das klappt und auch sich so die basic Sachen im Webinterface anzeigen lassen ist okay
Ich verwende das im Endeffekt nur für File Sync und für Kalenderkontakte
Also so die Kerndisziplin funktioniert
Ab Bundles, was gibt es denn hier sonst noch?
Deck, was ist denn Deck?
Ein Kanban Board, oh das ist was für die agilen Leute unter uns
Chat, seid ihr agil? Seid ihr bereit für das Kanban Board?
Agile, Agile Cute Chat
Huge Agile
Social Sharing, Twitter, Announcement Center, Dashboard
Was ist denn Zenodo?
Brauche ich alles nicht
Ah, ich müsste mir echt ein eigenes Elastic Search installieren dafür, dass es funktioniert
Komisch
Meine Backup Strategie für den privaten Nextcloud, meine Backup Strategie aktuell ist total simple
Ich habe in der Zauberkiste ist eine System SSD drin und eine Magnet Festplatte
Also eine normale, eine Magnet Festplatte
Eine normale Festplatte und es hängt einfach am USB Anschluss nur eine Festplatte dran
Wo nachts einmal R Synced wird
Also richtig, richtig old school Pepega Backup
Es wird einfach einmal nachts R Synced, fertig
Und auch nicht alles
Gameplay Aufnahmen und so zum Beispiel nicht
Nur wichtige Sachen, das ist nicht so viel
Einmal nachts R Synced, fertig
Ich habe das zurückgefahren
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja hier die letzten Jahre den übelst fetten Aufbau gehabt
Mit einem 4 HE 8 Kern Server
Mit 3 x 10 TB ZFS Platten drauf
Mit Offside Backup, mit Geschiss und allem
Und ganz ehrlich, es ist mir für daheim, ich meine es ist cool
Letztendlich macht mir es immer noch Spaß
Auch wenn ich da jetzt schon seit einer ganzen Weile in dem Bereich arbeite
Aber es macht mir auch immer noch Spaß privat mit sowas rumzuspielen
Aber es war einfach extrem offer kill für mich daheim
Kein 3 2 1, naja so halb
So halb, ich meine das Nextcloud Zeug, also die wirklich wichtigen Sachen
So wie der Passport Save, meine privaten Notes, Notizgeschichten und den ganzen Kram
Der ist über Nextcloud gesynced auf zwei Rechner plus auf dem Serverlink
Das sind ja schon mal drei
Und dann ist es halt noch auf eine Platte gespiegelt, das wars
Also das Offside 1 gibt es aktuell nicht
Was man machen könnte ist, es ist ja nicht viel
Das sind ja, lass es mal ein Gigabyte an Sachen sein
Das ist wahrscheinlich viel zu viel
Ich könnte das ohne Probleme Offside backupen
Da wenn es Haus abfackelt habe ich ein Problem aktuell
Dann ist mein Passport Save und Zeug weg
Da müsste ich erstmal ewig recovern
Aber im Kern scheint der Kram ja zu funktionieren, was sie anpreisen
Wirklich rundes Gefühl gibt es mir immer noch nicht hier, wenn ich das ausprobiere
Also rund fühlt sich nicht an
Und was ich halt immer noch enttäuschend finde ist, dass keine Suche eingebaut ist
Ich will mir kein eigenes Elastic Search installieren dafür
Was hältst du vom Programm wie Drivebooster, weiß gar nicht was das ist
Was ist Drivebooster?
Was ist das?
Eobit
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich sowas haben will
Was ist das?
Oh ne
Das ist Müll
Ja
Shaun D, das ist Müll
Du musst mir nur dieses UI angucken, das ist definitiv Müll, braucht kein Mensch
Ach du Scheiße, ne bloß nicht
Bloß auf gar keinen Fall
Installier das bloß nicht auf deinem Rechner
Ich finde es arbeiten einfach zu wenig Leute am Next Door
Ich glaube auch, dass das Problem ist, weil was man sieht ist
Das im Ansatz, im Ansatz ist alles da
Es fehlt so das Finish irgendwie
Das zu sagen, oh das macht richtig Spaß zu verwenden
Und es ist intuitiv und es macht einfach was es soll
Out of the box und das fehlt noch so ein bisschen
Aber das fehlt auch schon, das fehlt Nextcloud schon immer und das hat owncloud auch schon immer gefehlt
Was du meinst, dass Office im Namen, da wir nicht mehr braucht es keinen Office im Namen haben
Ich bin ja eh Office Hater
Ich verwende für nichts Office
Außer wenn es sich gar nicht anders vermeiden lässt
Und für die Geschichte auf der Arbeit verwenden wir aktuell auch nur PowerPoint
Weil ich das mit jemand anderem zusammen mache
Und der hat die Sache schon angefangen in PowerPoint
Was fehlt da zum Beispiel eine funktionierende Volltext Suche, die Out of the Box halt einfach sucht
Ohne dass ich mein eigenes Elastic Search betreiben muss
Wenn ich im Detail gucke fehlt da wahrscheinlich noch eine ganze Ecke mehr
Vor allem in Details ja
Ich finde es auch nicht so hundertprozentig schlüssig, dass es drei verschiedene Sachen gibt, wo man chatten kann
Der eine Chat funktioniert gar nicht, der eine Chat ist eine eigene App
Und der andere Chat ist pro Datei, das könnte man bestimmt schöner integrieren
Ja so klein sind so Kleinigkeiten
80% ist gut, 80% ist durchdacht
Es fehlen aber einfach so die letzten 20% um das Ding wirklich zu polieren
Man darf aber eins, muss man natürlich an der Stelle auch nochmal sagen
Es ist kostenlos und für das was sie die letzten Jahre über gemacht haben
Darf man ja auch nicht komplett jetzt irgendwie so übersehen wegwischen
Ist es natürlich toll was sie hingekriegt haben
Unterm Strich ist es bei mir halt so
Ich bin vielleicht auch ein bisschen immer sehr pingelig bei sowas
Aber bei mir muss ich halt auch kostenlose und auch Open Source Software an dem messen
Was ich halt unabhängig davon ob ein Software was koste oder nicht
Was ich halt gerne benutzen würde
Also sprich das was für mich halt sinnvoll ist
Und wenn das halt teilweise sehr hakelig funktioniert dann sage ich halt das es teilweise hakelig funktioniert
Ich meine warum gibt es drei Chats, warum gibt es einen Chat der überhaupt nicht funktioniert
Warum gibt es keine Out of the Box Suche die funktioniert ohne dass ich mal ein eigenes Elastic Search betreiben muss
Warum sehen die Vorlagen für die Präsentation aus wie von 2005
Was sie das stimmt aber man darf nicht vergessen
Das war schon immer so also bei Out Cloud und Next Cloud du hattest immer schon das Gefühl
Ich verfolge das jetzt seit 5 Jahren also schon ewig das Projekt
Du hast immer das Gefühl dass das was drinne ist zu 80% gut funktioniert und auch okay ist
Aber die letzten 20% fehlen und es kommt halt immer mehr dabei
Aber so der Polish kommt irgendwie nie
Auch dass sich die ganze Oberfläche unglaublich träge anfühlt ja
Man darf nicht vergessen es ist hier ist nichts drinne
Das sind die Beispiel Dateien und zwei User
Und dann gibt es solche Dinger wo man nicht so genau weiß warum
80% gut und im Kern macht es das was es soll nämlich Filesync, Kontakte und Kalender
Dafür ist es okay die anderen Sachen wenn man die anderen Sachen so als Beiwerk betrachtet dann ist in Ordnung
Auch eine Sache kann ich euch noch mal zeigen die ich halt schon lange lange vermisse
Und zwar Notes die die Notiz App was ist denn Quick Notes
Ach so die Notiz App wir müssen mal gucken ob das mittlerweile funktioniert
Ja was sie mir ist klar warum das so ist mir vollkommen klar
Dass die nicht die Ressourcen von Microsoft keine Frage
Ich erwarte ja auch nicht dass sie das jetzt machen nur weil ich das sage
Aber trotzdem muss ich egal welche Software wenn ich die verwende irgendwie auch
Daran messen mit was ich mir halt was ich mir so was ich halt gerne verwenden will
Ich habe halt gewisse Ansprüche egal ob die Software kostenlos ist oder was kostet
Und ich hätte beispielsweise gar keine Schmerzen damit da was für zu bezahlen
Generell ist es ist es bei mir bei vielen Sachen so dass ich aktuell den ich nehme den einfacheren Weg
Der der für mich am wenigsten Zeit braucht und der für mich am besten zu bedienen ist
Zum Beispiel ich lade mir keine Filme mehr per Torrent sonst was runter
Ich habe mir einfach ein Netflix und Amazon Prime Video Account gekauft
Funktioniert kostet Geld hat vieles was mir auf den Sack geht auch
Aber ist das was am einfachsten tut
So und eine Sache die mir immer bei dem Notizprogramm auch offen auf den Keks gegangen ist
Dass man hier Sachen schreiben konnte
Hallo 1 2 3 blub
Dass man die Dinger nicht durchsuchen konnte
Hier zum Beispiel 1 2 3 Bäm findet keine Notizen
Und Notizen die man nicht durchsuchen kann ist halt doof
No search result für 1 2 3 da ist offensichtlich nichts da
Oder habe ich das nicht gespeichert oder was was ist
Ich meine und so brauche ich ein Notizprogramm in dem ich nicht suchen kann
Es ist halt unsinnig
Wie viel Gigabyte stehen da denn zur Verfügung
240 G haben wir gerade dranhängen an SSD
Ach ne das ist ja in der Vm fast nix 8G oder so
Mir persönlich wäre es lieber man würde halt die basic Funktion wirklich mal richtig richtig
Also Talk ist so eine Sache brauche ich nicht unbedingt
Auch die ganzen Chat Funktionen ist nice brauche ich auch nicht unbedingt
Für mich persönlich wäre es halt einfach am besten
Das GUI wird sich halt richtig schön schnell und responsive anfühlen
Vielleicht auch ein bisschen intuitiver bedienbar sein
Weil vieles ist schon ein bisschen hakelig
Vor allem die Suche die eingebaut ist wäre unglaublich wichtig
Any Cuties in Chat
Nicht nur in Chat
Die Suche die eingebaut ist
Ach es gibt viele Kleinigkeiten
Gibt es denn Clouddienst für Massenspeicher als Privatperson ohne Kreditaufzüge
Kommt drauf an wie viel du haben willst
Gibt jede Menge
Ja ich will es jetzt auch nicht zu sehr flamen
Ich habe es ja schon gesagt
Weil man sich überlegt mit wie wenig Leuten die da dran arbeiten
Und was sie in den letzten Jahren geschafft haben ist es natürlich schon
Eine große Leistung das ganze Ding hier auf die Beine zu stellen
Aber ich habe trotzdem das Gefühl es wird sich auch ein bisschen zu
Ein bisschen zu sehr auf Features konzentriert
So nach dem Motto wir müssen da neue Sachen einbauen
Office Collaboration und Gedöns
Wohingegen die Notiz App noch nicht mal Notizen durchsuchen kann
Was sie komplett unbrauchbar macht
100TB
100TB ist saumäßig viel
Das kostet Kohle
100TB sind nicht ohne wenn du die Cloud mäßig
Also je nachdem wie du drauf zugreifen willst natürlich
Wenn du das nicht irgendwie als File System mounten willst
Wenn dir irgendwie Zugriffe über Web UI oder so reichen
Da gibt es bestimmt Varianten
Aber ich habe meine Zweifel dass es einen ordentlichen Anbieter gibt
Wo man 100TB kostengünstig hosten kann
Vor allem der auch eine gewisse Performance hat
Dass ich die im Zweifelsverlauf wieder runter kriege
Da wirst du mit irgendwelchen kostenlosen Sachen nicht sonderlich weit kommen denke ich
Es gibt zwar Sachen wie ich glaube Amazon
Nee Amazon hat nicht mehr Unlimited
Es gibt ein paar Anbieter die haben Unlimited
Aber da weiß ich nicht ob man da mit 100TB wirklich weit kommt
Naja aber du musst ja keine Elastix
Es gibt mit Sicherheit kleine Suchmaschinen die man integrieren könnte
Da müssen wir mal auf GitHub gucken
Es gibt bestimmt irgendwelche Go Geschichten die wahrscheinlich 5MB groß sind
Und auf jedem x-bliebenen Linux laufen
Alternativ könnte man was anbieten was einfach die Dateien durchkreppt
Das wäre total simpel
Das würde natürlich nicht für PDFs richtig funktionieren
Und auch nicht für Powerpoint Geschichten oder so
Aber es würde für Markdown und Text und Notes schonmal ordentlich funktionieren
Das wäre ja schonmal was
Ich erwarte gar nicht dass ich Bilder nach Text oder sowas durchsuchen kann
Aber dass Notizen durchsuchbar sind das würde ich schon erwarten
Weil das macht das Notizprogramm komplett überflüssig
Ich meine wenn ich hier viele Notizen angelegt habe
Und ich suche jetzt die Notiz wo 0W drin steht und da findet nichts
Das ist halt unbrauchbar als Notizprogramm
Die einzige Möglichkeit die ich da eventuell habe
Ich weiß gar nicht ob das mit Notizen funktioniert ist
Dass ich mir ein eigenes Elasticsearch hause
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf
Ja ich weiß dass es einen OCR gibt
Aber das erwarte ich gar nicht dass das out of the box da ist
Könnte ich eventuell machen? Will ich gar nicht
Ich will es einfach nur benutzen
Und wie gesagt ich sage nicht dass die das machen müssen
Bloß weil ich das haben will
Es wäre aber für mich eine wichtige Funktion
Und eine Funktion die für mich nicht so ganz nachvollziehbar eben fehlt
Weil wozu gibt das Notizprogramm wenn ich Notizen nicht durchsuchen kann
Das ist so basic feature
Das wäre so das was ich einbauen würde direkt nachdem ich das Icon festgelegt habe
Ein Notizprogramm ohne Suchfunktion ist unsinnig
So gibt es noch irgendwelche Sachen die wir ausprobieren können
Eins muss man aber nochmal wirklich
Wie gesagt ich verfolge das schon eine ganze Weile
Im Vergleich zu den ersten OnCloud Varianten hat sich unglaublich viel getan
Die erste OnCloud Geschichte die ich damals installiert habe
Die hat Dateien gelöscht
Beim Sinken
Und das ist tatsächlich mittlerweile zuverlässig und funktioniert
Ich habe damals versucht
Mit einem der ersten OnCloud Versionen
Habe ich versucht von meiner iOS Notizen App
Über WebDAF Sachen zu sünden
Das hat prinzipiell auch funktioniert bis zu dem Zeitpunkt wo manchmal Dateien verschwunden sind
Das war halt gerade bei einem Notizprogramm ziemlich doof
Weil da verschwinden nicht einfach Dateien sondern da verschwinden halt dann
Da habe ich nicht so viele Dateien dafür steht da relativ viel drinnen
Das war echt doof
Das war unglaublich
Zum damaligen Zeitpunkt
Da hat sich viel getan das ist sehr zuverlässig mittlerweile
Aber was ich halt sagen will ist nur
Die meisten neuen Features sind für mich persönlich jetzt halt nicht so wichtig
Ich brauche die ganze Collaboration Geschichte nicht
Auch die ganze Chatgeschichte und sowas ist für mich jetzt relativ wichtig
Jetzt relativ überflüssig
Es gibt bestimmt genug Leute die das verwenden
Für mich wäre es halt deutlich wichtiger dass ich meine Notizen durchsuchen kann
Gibt es nicht Bountys für die Funktion
Ja ja ja
Also ich denke mal dass die auch sowas haben
Viele haben ja so Code Bounty Programme mittlerweile
Mal gucken wie der Editor leckt beim aufgehen
Wo kann man eigentlich Dark Seam einstellen
Gibt es da ein offizielles
Ah jetzt ist es Dark Seam
Dyslexia font
Was ist dyslexia
Guck schau mir das sowas
Das ist das was ich meine was halt einfach unpolished ist
Warum ist das hier unten noch weiß
Mich darf es halt dass ich so Sachen immer nach zwei Minuten benutzen finde
Und warum ist das überhaupt nicht gesiemt
Es ist einfach unpolished
Ich glaube das kann man sagen ohne dass man da jemand auf den Schlips tritt
Da fehlen halt so die letzten 20 Prozent
Feinschliff nennen wir es einfach mal Feinschliff
So Leute was macht eigentlich der Raspberry
Wie warm ist er denn mittlerweile geworden
54 Grad gut ich glaube wärmer wird er nicht mehr
45 Grad wir haben jetzt eineinhalb Stunden haben wir CPU volle Pulle laufen
Ich denke mal 54 Grad mit dem Gehäuse ist top
Mehr geht nicht
So jetzt habt ihr die Auswahl Leute
Wollen wir noch irgendwie irgendwas machen
Wisst ihr was ich geh jetzt mal aufs Klo und hol mir was zu essen
Dann gucken wir noch eine Runde Essen Stream
Gucken wir noch ein bisschen Videos
Essen Videos
Ich futter was und wir können auch ein bisschen hier FAQ gedönst machen
Also wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt Leute sagt mir gleich Bescheid
Ich geh jetzt mal kurz pinkeln
Also es kann durchaus sein dass wenn ihr es jetzt schreibt dass ich es nicht sehe
Und ich gucke gleich in den Chat und dann gucken wir uns das ganze nochmal an
Also dann
So, ich will ab, das ist ein Raspberry Pi 4, ja warum heißt das eigentlich B, es gibt
da nur B, für was steht das B eigentlich, steht das etwa für USB-C?
So, gucken wir jetzt ein bisschen Essen-Video, so also ich habe jetzt hier ein Brötchen
und ein Toastbrot, ich werde erstmal was futtern, ich hab übelst Hunger, also wenn
ihr was wissen wollt haut's in den Chat, wir haben jetzt, ich hab eigentlich Zeit, 4 Stunden
Stream, ich hab eigentlich Zeit, ich muss nichts machen, also wenn ihr jetzt noch ein
paar Sachen habt, können wir ruhig noch ein bisschen huge IQ-Talk machen, mich würde
echt mal das aktuell laufende System im Bundestag interessieren, Performance von so einer großen
Nextcloud umgehen, was die haben, Nextcloud im Bundestag, ernsthaft?
Essen, Essen, Essen, Essen, Essen, du kannst Stellenanzeigen zerlegen, oh das machen wir,
was machen wir danach, wir gucken uns Stellenanzeigen an, ja, Zeig Essen, ich muss mir Essen angucken,
ja, mach ich, mach ich, Michael schick mal, schick mal den Link, ReapFood, wo ist er denn,
ne, er ist nicht, er ist in Kambodia, wo ist das denn, ah Vietnam, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
gnae, eindeutig für ein bisschenbreaker, ok, ok, eine ahí,Group on, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
von Nudelsuppen. Ist hier überhaupt nicht angesagt, ist aber übelst nice.
Welche Shell nutzt du da auf deine Mancharo? Ich habe als Terminal ein ganz normales
Gnome Terminal und ZSH als Shell. Es gibt übrigens ein richtig gutes
Ramenrestaurant in Frankfurt.
Ups. Das da. Das ist wirklich nice, wenn man sowas mag.
Leider, leider ist sowas hier in Deutschland viel zu teuer.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, in Japan kann man sowas wahrscheinlich für
umgerechnet wie 5 Euro futtern oder so. Hier bezahlt glaube ich 13 oder sowas.
Aber das schmeckt wirklich sehr nice.
Weiß gar nicht, ob die eine Speisekarte haben.
Was auch immer.
292 kenne ich aus, ja. Ja der ist wirklich nice.
Was hat er da jetzt reingeschmissen? Irgendwie so Hot Sauce oder?
Wir haben bei uns um die Ecke ein vietnamesisches Nudelsuppen-Restaurant.
Schmeckt auch immer gut.
Also würde ich jetzt auch futtern. Das letzte Mal, das letzte Mal, wo er da seine
kalte Nudelsuppe hatte, das war nicht so meins.
Warum essen sie selbst Suppe mit Stäbchen teils Löffel? Wahrscheinlich, weil es am
einfachsten ist.
Du lebst, ja? Ich lebe nicht nur, ich esse sogar.
Ich glaube, wenn du dort, ich glaube, wenn du in solchen Regionen Chili kriegst, dann ist es
wahrscheinlich echt scharf.
Er schwitzt ein bisschen, oder?
Moment, das ist Frühstück?
Die hauen sich sowas schon zum Frühstück rein. Da muss ich hin.
Gebratene Schweine mit Reis zum Frühstück. Huge!
Jetzt bin ich sofort dabei.
Und das sieht so aus, als wäre es eine dünne Version eines chinesischen Chashu. Und es gibt ein
kleines Dippingsauce mit diesem.
Das hier.
Ein bisschen Reis mit dem.
Ja, Bacon zum Frühstück, Futter ist auch.
Wow, ich kann nicht glauben, dass ich das sage, aber das könnte besser sein als Nudelsuppe.
Es sieht ein bisschen geschwitzt aus.
Ich finde es geil, wie er immer ausplippt beim Futtern.
Oh, ist das gut.
Also Leute, ich würde es sofort zum Frühstück futtern.
Ich meine, für vegane ist es nichts. Das ist wohl so, ja.
Ja, also ich würde es, ich könnte es den ersten Tag auch erstmal 24-7 essen.
Wie viel, weißt du, wie viel futtert er eigentlich immer?
Ich habe das Gefühl, er ist ein Competitive Eater, der futtert immer Massen.
Zwei, zwei Euro, oder weniger, 1,70 Euro.
1,70 Euro, bei uns bezahlt er für sowas 13 Euro.
Okay.
Was, die kann ich mir ganz schön gut vorstellen.
Was ist das? Das Muschel, sind das Muschel oder sowas?
Ja.
Oh, das wäre nichts für mich.
Oh, wie geht es dir?
Oh, wow. Okay, also er benutzt einfach seinen vorderen Tee, um ihn zu zerspringen und zu öffnen.
Okay, ich brauche zwei Hände für das. Ich konnte endlich dieses Ding öffnen.
Das ist bestimmt eine Übungssache. Danach erstmal zum Tharnarzt.
So süß. Ich sehe, warum das ein ein bisschen ein Spaßstück könnte sein, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die Leute hier das Ding öffnen können, denn das Ding war so dicht mit einem Kung-Fu-Grip. Wow, gut job, Kumpel.
Dieses Kindes Kung-Fu-Grip ist definitiv super.
Das ist auch ein wilder Alter.
Also Reis und Fisch sind ein paar Ingenieure, die hier in Kambodien sehr oft genutzt werden.
Weil es eine geografische Location im Nikon-River ist.
Und wahrscheinlich der nationale Dicht in Kambodien ist der Amak.
Und typisch der Fisch-Amak, das ist eine Fisch-Kurri, die meistens in Bananen gegrillt wird.
Und es hat ein Bunch von Speisen und Erben drin.
Aber in diesem Restaurant, die haben dort gebraten. Ich weiß nicht, wie das schmeckt.
Das ist Reis, Banane? Okay.
Mal sehen, ob das gut ist.
Okay.
Es ist sehr kokonatisch. Es schmeckt wie eine schmutzige Fisch-Kurri.
Es ist sehr kokonatisch, also ist der Aroma fantastisch.
Super schmutzige Fische. Und es gibt auch Eier hier.
Wisst ihr, wie das aussieht? Als ist man da, nach einer halben Schürze, pappsatt.
Das sieht aus, als ist es sehr gehaltvoll.
Schau her.
Was ist das? Ein Salat oder? Ja.
Ich glaube, das Zeug ist bestimmt alles übelst scharfe.
Der isst das alles am selben Tag. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie der das reinkriegt.
Er geht wahrscheinlich essen, danach macht er Workout, bis zum nächsten Essen.
Essen verbrennen, Essen verbrennen.
Was willst du machen? Als Food-Blogger, da musst du durch.
Also noch zweimal Toastbrot, dann bin ich fertig. Also bis zum Ende des Videos bin ich aufwendig zu essen.
Na, da haben sie es mit dem Recht verlinkt, das kannst du doch vergessen.
Da ist Vorfahrt, wer als erstes fährt. Wer als erstes fährt und nicht umgefahren wird bei, hat gewonnen.
Wo gibt es Essen? Ich brauche mehr Essen. Mehr Essen.
Da ist auch Schale drum, oder? Oder Panzer?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die das immer hinkriegen.
Ich hätte überhaupt keinen Bock, jede zweite Portion, die ich in den Mund schiebe, erstmal wieder was ausspucken zu müssen,
weil da irgendwelche Schalen, Panzer oder sonst was dran sind.
Wow, das ist schon eher was für mich.
Das sieht aus wie eine Bratwurst. Das hätte auch das Ende von der Bratwurst zeigen können, oder?
Ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube das wäre nicht so meins.
Wobei ich die Sache finde ich cool. Das machen sie in Korea ja auch, dass da sauviel Zeug in Salatblätter gewickelt wird.
Und das finde ich eine super Idee. Wenn ich mir vorstelle, wenn irgendwas auf dem Grill liegt und man schneidet das klein,
bei uns machen wir das immer so, also generell hier so in Deutschland, dann nimmt man das Zeug vom Grill,
schneidet das klein und hat dann noch Baguette oder Knoblauchbaguette oder irgendwie sowas dabei,
da finde ich das eigentlich mit dem in Salat wickeln viel besser. Du schneidest das einfach klein, nimmst dann irgendwie Platz Salat,
machst dann noch irgendwie ein bisschen Chili-Kram rein, machst dann ein Stück Fleisch rein, futterst das komplett.
Das ist wahrscheinlich sogar noch deutlich besser und gesünder, als wenn du da massig Baguette beifutterst.
Baguette.
Das würde Schmerz auch reinhauen. Das würde Schmerz ohne, ohne, oh.
Ich glaube, das ist echt hot. Das ist bestimmt scharf wie Sau. Aber es schmeckt gut.
Ich glaube, das ist wirklich was. Die Kombination hier, die ist glaube ich, die schmeckt gut und ist wahrscheinlich sogar noch relativ gesund.
Ich bin jetzt fertig, oder?
Nein.
Wie soll man das essen, ohne sich einzukaufen? So wie er. Halb auf die Erde knien und alles freudig tropfen lassen.
Lobt er alles, was er isst? Ja, zum größten halt schon. Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn du Food-Vlogger bist,
die Leute gucken dir einfach lieber zu, wenn das Zeug dir schmeckt, als wenn du es eklig findest.
Ich glaube ihm sogar, dass es gut schmeckt. Er hat auch ein paar Videos, wo die Sachen nicht so gut sind.
Es ist nicht so komplett unglaubbarer Hype. Ich habe ja früher fast jedes Video von ihm geguckt.
Manche Sachen flamet er auch.
Genau, wir fahren jetzt alle hin und checken das Out. Es gibt wahrscheinlich auch nur einen Stand davon.
Rollergrill war da gerade.
Sagen wir mal, da fahren alle Motorrad, oder? Oh, das ist jetzt echt nichts für vegetarisch.
Das ist nicht so meins.
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube das ist nicht meins.
Ich meine, probieren würde ich es mal, aber ich glaube das ist nicht meins. Das schon eher.
Ich frage mich nur, was das mal für Tiere ursprünglich gewesen sind. Wahrscheinlich, das ist ein Hühnerfuß.
Das sieht aus wie ein Hühnerfuß.
Es ist ein Frosch. Okay, man weiß, dass die Franzosen da gewesen sind. Eindeutig.
Der hat ja gesagt, es waren früher die Franzosen da, deswegen gibt es da auch Frösche zu essen.
Ne, TRO-AMP kenne ich nicht.
Ich würde mir auch einen Kanzler-AMP vor selbst bauen.
Frosch ist wie Hühnchen, okay. Hab ich noch nie probiert.
Das sieht tatsächlich gut aus. Also den würde ich das Frosch wiederholen. Aber der Frosch, ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaube der Frosch wäre nicht meins.
Das muss nicht sein.
So wirklich essen tut das auch nicht, oder? Da wedelt nur damit rum.
Also Hähnchenfuß.
Jetzt ist der Frosch. Okay, das Hähnchen.
Ob Fuß oder Flügel ist kein großer Unterschied. Am Flügel ist wenigstens noch ein bisschen was dran.
Also ein Fuß. Wie man mal abessen so abgehen kann. Naja, wenn man Foodlogger ist, Food wie Logger, da muss man doch schon ein bisschen Showtube rum machen.
Tromm, ich habe mich übrigens verlesen. Weißt du, was ich gelesen habe? Kennst du einen guten Channel, wie man sein eigenes Smartphone bauen kann?
Ich habe Smartphone gelesen, nicht Smart Home. Ja, Smart Home kann ich dir ein paar Channels empfehlen.
Also Smart Home gibt es ein paar Channels. Ich zeige dir gleich mal ein paar.
Naja, was? Ah, ich war es nett.
Ja gut, die sind da halt hart im Leben, ja.
Das würde ich wahrscheinlich den Popcorn hier bevorzugen.
Was ist das für ein Kleimzeug? Strictly Dumpling heißt der.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Okay, also Heimautomatisierung Channels, da kann ich dir einmal den hier empfehlen.
Der ist ganz gut zum Einstieg und er hat relativ gute Guides. In letzter Zeit macht er relativ wenig, was mich interessiert, aber der ist ganz gut.
Dann gibt es hier den Typ. Den da? Der ist auch nicht schlecht. Also generell für Heimautomatisierung insgesamt.
Wie heißt der andere? Ist das der? Ja, der ist auch ganz gut.
Das ist so, wenn es ganz grob um so das Heimautomatisierungsthema geht, finde ich die ganz gut, die drei.
Natürlich, wenn du spezifische Sachen dir angucken willst, da gibt es immer andere.
Also wenn du dich für Microcontroller und Programmieren in der Richtung interessierst, gibt es wieder ganz andere Channels.
Es gibt auch viele, die hätten meiner Meinung nach mehr Abos verdient.
Schonmal das Blackout Hörspiel gehört. Was für ein Blackout Hörspiel?
Du schreibst ja so, als müsste man wissen, was das Blackout Hörspiel ist. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Es ist nicht nur rausgeschmissenes Geld, sich eine Komplettlösung zu kaufen.
Die Komplettlösungen sind auch schlechter als das, was man selbst bauen kann und noch deutlich unsicherer.
Vor allem, weil die alle irgendwelche komischen Cloud-Geschichten machen mittlerweile.
Und man kriegt es mit Komplettlösungen selten so hin, wie man es haben will.
So, wir wollen uns mal eine Runde Stellenanzeigen angucken.
Wir gucken jetzt mal in Frankfurt. Wir suchen jetzt einfach mal nur nach IT.
Wir suchen einfach nur IT. Wir suchen einfach mal alles, was es gibt.
3053 Jobs. Easy. Alles dabei. Easy as a fuck.
Ach so, genau. Wir wollten von Michael mal gucken.
E-Tech Service Consulting. Und da fängst du demnächst an? Oder hast du dich beworben?
Oh, schau mal, schöne Grinser auf der Startseite. Das muss ja so sein. Die sind immer glücklich. Ja, super.
Das sind irgendwelche Stock-Icons auf jeden Fall. Die kommen mir bekannt vor.
Aktuelles Vorstellungsgespräch. Ja, was machen die denn?
Service. Jobs. Also, wo hast du dich beworben? Zeig mal her. Da?
Ach so, du weißt nicht, warum weißt du nicht, was die machen?
Moment, wer von uns beiden war jetzt im Vorstellungsgespräch?
Okay, Vorteile.
Viele Möglichkeiten zur aktiven Mitgestaltung und Einbeziehung der Entscheidung.
Okay, das ist gut oder schlecht, man weiß es nicht.
Werkstatt der Arbeitszeiten von pro Stunde möglich. Das ist jetzt für dich egal. Flache Hierarchien.
Ja, da weißt du nicht, ob das alle Vorteile für einen selbst sind. Das kann je nachdem gut oder schlecht sein.
Das sagt jetzt noch mal gar nichts aus.
Modernes Arbeitumfeld. Arbeiten in einem modern ausgestatteten Büro in der Klienzone zum Einkaufszentrum.
Wenn es für dich ein Vorteil ist, ist es einen deutschen Plus.
Ein Großartiges, das sagen alle. Das sagen alle. Da würde ich nichts drauf geben. Das sagen wirklich alle.
Subventioniert das Essen, Kantine. Das ist nicht schlecht.
Ich würde sagen, von allen Vorteilen, die sich hier aufgelistet haben, ist das hier wirklich ein Vorteil.
Subventioniert das Essen ist nicht verkehrt.
Du bekommst nicht gratis Futter, doch du bekommst gratis Smoothies und Snacks und Subventioniert das Essen.
Das tut es doch ganz gut.
Wir suchen eine aufgeschlossene Persönlichkeit.
Michael, bist du eine aufgeschlossene Persönlichkeit?
Die sich mit Engagement und Eigeninitiative in unser Team einbringt. Blablabla
Ihre Aufgaben, Fachinformatikerinnen, Fachinformatikerinnen blablabla
Die benutzen dazu eigene Methoden.
Okay, das ist absolut nichts sagen, das ganze Ding, aber okay.
Du willst jetzt von mir wissen, was die machen.
Okay, ich sag dir, was die machen.
Die machen komisches Prozessgedöns.
Komisches Prozess-Consulting-Gedöns, würde ich mal sagen, kann man jetzt schwer sagen.
Sie entwickeln Software und sie bieten...
Was zum Teufel, ich hab keine Ahnung, was sie machen.
Das ist irgendeine Consulting-Firma, oder?
Wenn die was von Prozessen, Standardisierung und Services reden,
das hört sich an wie irgendeine Consulting-Firma.
Beratung, das ist irgendein Consulting-Laden.
Consulting-Laden, der auch eigene Software verkauft für die Bereiche, in denen sie konsulten.
Was natürlich clever ist, weil dann können sie dir quasi raten,
kauf doch unsere Software, nachdem du sie konsultet hast.
Das ist eigentlich richtig big brain.
Du lässt dich beraten und am Ende der Beratung kommt raus,
am besten kaufst du die Software von eTek.
Das ist eigentlich big brain.
High IQ move.
Open data check.
Ja, das ist irgendein Consulting-Laden.
Anti-Techi, das frag ich mich auch.
Warum bist du da gewesen, hast du überhaupt keinen Plan von dem Laden?
Also, dass du da hingehst und keinen Plan von dem Laden hast, kann ich noch irgendwie nachvollziehen,
aber dass man sich dann auch so gut verstanden hat und es dir auch nicht geschafft hat,
irgendwie ein bisschen was über sich zu erzählen, ist schon merkwürdig.
Das ist irgendeine Consulting.
Die machen irgendwelche Business-Consulting-Geschichten
und entwickeln auch Software dafür, die sie dann den Leuten antreten wollen.
Mit irgendwelchen komischen Zertifizierungen und was auch immer.
Die haben mir nichts über sich erzählt.
Wahrscheinlich wissen die selber nicht, was die machen.
Was kannst du das Gleiche mit BMC Solutions geben?
Kann ich also.
Wieder BMC.
BMC ist für mich Baseboard.
Base Management Controller.
Wie heißt das Ding bei IBM?
Nee, doch nicht.
Okay, dann nicht.
Was du?
Das einzige, was sie gesagt haben, sie arbeiten fast ausschließlich mit PHP.
Das heißt jetzt erstmal nichts.
Normalerweise sind die bei solchen Vorstellungsgesprächen immer ganz scharf drauf,
nochmal zu betonen, was für ein geiler Laden sie sind.
Also, was suchen die hier denn?
IT System Engineer.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Enterprise Architekt, das brauchen wir nicht.
Project Management, okay, geh mal weg.
IT Site Lead.
Das ist quasi so eine Niederlassung Chef oder sowas.
Ja, Michael, normalerweise drücken sie einem das ganz gerne aufs Auge, wie toll sie sind.
Ja, da muss ich Neo Recht geben.
Das wäre tatsächlich nicht schlecht gewesen.
Ich mein, wenn du zu denen gesagt hast, ich hab überhaupt keinen Plan, was sie hier machen,
wär vielleicht ein bisschen blöd, aber wenn du sagst, du hast die Webseite gelesen
und zu manchen Sachen hast du jetzt noch Fragen, was das genau bedeutet,
dann hätten die sich bestimmt gefreut.
Ach so, BMC Solution in Stuttgart.
Und da sind die doch, oder?
Ach nee, die hier.
IGIT, die Webseite, MonkaS.
Optimiert für Microsoft Internet Explorer 800 x 600.
Okay, wir stehen für Software Engineering.
Wobei, die Webseite ist gar nicht so schlecht, weil ich glaube, die ist relativ,
gucken wir mal in den Source.
Es ist WordPress, es ist WordPress.
Okay, ich find's doch schlecht.
Was, bei offenen Stellen?
Wo siehst du das jetzt?
Ich blicke hier auf der Seite gar nicht durch, wo hier überhaupt irgendwie was ist.
Bei dem Typen da.
Oh, ja, ich seh's, ich hab's erst gar nicht gecheckt.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, ob der so guckt, als ist er einfach nur glücklich
oder als will er mich beißen.
Könnte beides sein.
Vielleicht sollten wir mal unseren lokalen Witcher da hinschicken.
Also, weiß nicht, das sieht irgendwie gefährlich aus.
Hier findest du eine vielfältige Ausfallaufnahme.
Okay, was haben sie denn schönes?
Webentwicklung.
Okay, aber du wolltest ja wissen, was die machen.
Native Apps machen sie.
Oh, er macht Native Apps.
iPad, iPhone, los.
Web Apps.
Bootstrap.
Frontendentwicklung.
JQuery, hui.
Moment.
Node.js im Frontend?
Wait, wait.
Was wollen sie uns sagen?
Node.js hat im Frontend eigentlich...
Also zumindest nicht dort, wo es ausgeführt wird.
Man benutzt das in der Frontendentwicklung auf dem Rechner des Entwicklers,
aber nicht so wirklich im Frontend.
Okay, also lesen wir uns mal durch, was die tollsten machen.
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Okay, die Frontendentwicklung ist die technische Umsetzung des Erscheinungsbildes
sowie des interaktiven Feindes eines Webanwend...
Ach du Große.
Entscheidend für den Erfolg ihrer Webanwendung ist das User-Interface-Design.
Das könnte Nextcloud auch noch brauchen.
Unser Fokus bei der Frontendentwicklung liegt auf Web-to-Print,
Unternehmens- und E-Commerce-Portalen.
Hierbei setzen wir auf Technologien wie HTML5, JavaScript, CSS3, JQuery, Bootstrap...
Also es wird schwierig, auf diese Sachen nicht zu setzen,
weil Web-Entwicklung geht halt ohne Nummer nicht.
JQuery, ja gut, ist zwar mittlerweile nicht mehr so der neueste Shit,
aber es ist halt wahrscheinlich noch gut zu verwendbar.
Bootstrap ist auch ziemlich nur nach 15 CSS-Zeug.
Ich würde mir eigentlich eher Gedanken darüber machen,
wenn jemand, der für mich ein individuelles, hochwertiges Frontend entwickelt,
das gerade mit Bootstrap macht.
Okay, Angular, ja gut.
Ja, also wenn du wissen willst, was die machen,
das sieht für mich nach einem Laden aus der Web-Anwendung entwickelt.
Und die eine ziemlich merkwürdige Homepage haben.
Guck mal, sie haben Microsoft als Partner.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie für Microsoft Webseiten gemacht haben.
Die haben bei Microsoft wahrscheinlich ein paar Office-Lizenzen gekauft.
Fuck, die kenne ich.
Das ist eine Zumutung, diese Software, Leute.
Die kenne ich.
Oh yeah.
FNT, Alter.
FNT ist so ein Inventarisierungssystem.
Es hat das schlechteste User-Interface, was ihr je gesehen habt.
Also ich übertreibe jetzt nicht.
Ja, sowas da zum Beispiel.
Also was sie sich bei diesem Programm gedacht haben, ist mir echt schleierhaft.
Das kann übrigens nicht mal TAPS.
Das sieht so aus, als kann es TAPS, aber das funktioniert nicht.
Also du kannst TAPS aufmachen, aber wenn du dann BACK drückst,
dann landest du dann auf der anderen Seite,
nicht auf der, wo du vorher warst.
Guckt euch das an.
Ja, das ist es.
Das Interface, das Interface.
Das tut weh, das tut so weh, das Interface.
Racktables, ja Racktables, kosten wenigstens nichts.
Holiday-Check haben sie entwickelt, okay.
Haben sie das auch mit Bootstrap gemacht haben?
Technologien.
Objective C und Xcode und Git, Jira und Confluence.
Wer hat denn das geschrieben?
Ich meine, Objective C, klar, es ist eine etwas ältere iOS-Anwendung.
Xcode, ohne Xcode kannst du gar keine iOS-Anwendung erstellen.
Git, ja gut, ist für die Anwendung doch scheißegal mit welchem Versionsverwaltungssystem,
was für ein Ticket-System verwendet wird,
ist auch egal und ob die nur Confluence verwenden oder nicht,
ist doch auch wurscht, das hat doch mit der App nichts zu tun.
Was ist denn das für ein Blödsinn?
VTF, das hat mit der App überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Nichts davon hat was mit der App zu tun.
Das Einzige ist Objective C.
Das sind noch nicht mal Buzzwords.
Das sind zumindest planlose Words von denen, die die Webseite schreiben.
Wisst ihr, wenn jemand beispielsweise eine Handy-App entwickelt und sagt Technologien,
dann würde ich verstehen, dass es in Objective C geschrieben ist.
Ich würde erwarten, dass dann sowas drinsteht wie z.B. FFmpeg,
wenn es Video, Audio, Video-Zeug drin hat, dass FFmpeg drin steht
oder dass Grafik-Framework drin steht, wenn es verwendet wird oder sowas.
Oh, doch nicht Git.
Okay, weg.
Okay, also was suchen die hier?
Wartet mal kurz.
Die Logofarben, ja, so halbwegs.
Dein Aufkommen.
Dein Profil.
Sehr gute Kenntnis, objektorientierter Softwareentwicklung.
HTML5, JavaScript, PHP und CSS.
Also HTML, JavaScript, CSS ist absolut Grundlage für Web-Anwendung.
Ohne geht es nicht.
Erfahrungen mit Plattformen wie Android oder IOS wünschenswert.
Okay, grundlegend ist einfach Web-Serve.
Soap.
Gibt es wirklich noch Leute, die Soap-APs machen?
Na gut, warum nicht?
Hohe Qualitätsergebnisse.
Das ist so ein Satz, den Jits schreiben viele gerne rein.
Hohe Qualitäts- und Eigeninitiativen, sowas steht dann da immer drin.
Das ist so komplett Füllworte.
Kommunikation und Teamfähigkeit, sehr gute deutsche und englische Kenntnisse online bewerben.
Man kann anhand der Website überhaupt nicht erkennen, ob es ein guter oder schlechter Laden ist.
Ganz ehrlich, kann man echt nicht ableiten.
Nur, dass diejenigen, die die Homepage schreiben, glaube ich, relativ wenig Ahnung haben von dem, was der Laden eigentlich macht.
Okay Leute, wir müssen ein bisschen einschränken.
3053 Jobs sind zu viel.
Macht mal einen Vorschlag.
Nach was für einem Job wollen wir suchen?
Wir haben es letztes Mal immer bei mir.
Na, Consulting.
Nee, es muss was sein, wo ich was zu sagen kann.
Ich weiß, DHL hat immer noch, zumindest das offizielle, was du findest, hat bei DHL immer noch Soap.
Wobei DHL mittlerweile, die haben eine neue AP-Schnittstelle.
Ich habe das hier in meinem Versand-Tracker eingebaut.
Die neue DHL-AP ist auch mit Jason überrest.
System-Administrator.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
128.
Für Microsoft im Bereich Operational Services.
System-Administrator.
Ich habe mit diesem Laden noch nie was zu tun gehabt.
Aber ich habe gehört von ein paar Leuten, die da gearbeitet haben, dass es wohl ziemlich sackt.
Kann ich aus persönlicher Erfahrung nicht nichts zu sagen, aber...
Oh, guck mal, der Bund. System-Administrator an der Uni.
E-Shelter. Die kommen mir bekannt vor.
Das kommt... E-Shelter.
Wer war das nochmal? Die kenne ich irgendwo her.
Shelter.
Hat es nicht einen Rechenzentrum-Anbieter oder sowas?
Die kommen mir bekannt vor. Ich glaube, da hatten wir mal was. Ich glaube, bei denen hatten wir mal was gemietet.
To the Cloud.
Ja, genau, die haben einen Rechenzentrum.
Warum suchen wir gerade nach Jobs? Weil der Chat gefragt hat, ob ich nicht mal wieder...
Also quasi der...
Wollte, dass wir uns mal wieder IT-Sachen angucken.
Oh, Skills. Linux.
Leute, ich filter das mal nach Sachen, wo ich auch was zu sagen kann.
Gleich dann.
Was? System-Administrator, Robotic Process Automation and AI.
Das muss ich mir angucken. Was wollen die? Was will denn die Bank damit?
Linux-Systemadmin... EU-Networks.
Moment.
Die kommen mir auch bekannt vor.
Die kommen mir bekannt vor. Woher sagt mir denn der Name irgendwas?
Es könnte sein, dass wir Glasfaser-Leitungen von denen haben.
Easy killer. Das ist jetzt nur Zufall.
Managed Now Monitoring.
Schwerpunkt Telefonie.
Du bist bei denen bestimmt gebannt. Aber gebannt bin ich nur bei MSI.
Für Servos-Systeme.
Die hätten sich auch Servos-Technologie nennen können, oder?
Servos-Technologie hätte irgendwie besser geklungen als Zertus.
Die Caritas in Frankfurt.
Windows. Ne, das guckt man gar nicht.
Grieb.
Oh man, wie ist man? Fuck, ist viel zu weit weg.
Du bist echt bei MSI gebannt, ja.
Ich hab über RGB-Beleuchtung gemeckert. Das fand MSI nicht lustig.
Also irgendwo hört auch mal der Spaß auf, ne?
Der über RGB-Beleuchtung sich lustig macht, den kann man schon mal banen.
Okay, warum braucht eine Bank einen Systemadministrator für Robotic Process Automation und AI?
Das müssen wir uns jetzt mal angucken.
Jump on.
Jetzt das Thema, wo andere von komplexen Zusammenhängen sprechen, sehen sie logische Verknüpfung.
Ah, yes. Alles, wir sehen überall logische Verknüpfung.
Mit ihrer analytischen und gleichzeitig kreativen Denkweise bringen sie Prozesse voran und entwickeln sie ständig weiter.
Das passt.
Gibt es irgendein IT-begeisterter Mensch auf dieser Welt, der sich diese zwei Sätze durchlässt und sich dann denkt, das passt?
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Unsere IT Area Service freut sich. Was? Unsere IT Area Service? Was soll denn das für eine Bescholle?
IT Area Service?
Ich kann mir da gar nichts runter vorstellen. Ist das die, die lokal hinlaufen und Druckerpatronen tauschen oder wie?
Weil Area Service?
Nix. War bei MSI. Die haben mich auf Twitter gebannt, weil ich über RGB-Beleuchtung gemeckert habe.
Das kann man ja machen.
Also ihre Aufgaben. Sie haben Lust auf betreuende, interessante Anwendungen im agilen Fintech.
Das ist eine Wortgeschichte, eine Wortkreation. Mittlerweile ist das voll angesagt. Das mögen sie. Fintech.
Und dann haben wir vielleicht den perfekten Job für Sie. Sie interessieren sich für neue zukunftsweiche Technologien, haben Spaß,
haben drei neue Lösungen im Bereich Robotik, Process, Auto, Ripper und AI zu identifizieren und zu implementieren.
Außerdem kennen sie sich im Windows- sowie Unix-Umfeld bestens aus, übernehmen die Administration und den Second-Level-Support.
Rollouts? Handeln sie souverän? Was? Handeln?
Rollouts? Handeln sie souverän?
Greifen den Stakeholdern unter die Arme?
All you can eat.
Last Partner sind sie auch?
Was? Bei Governance und BCP-Prozessen ein zentraler Player?
Kein Ersatz.
Last Partner und Least sind sie auch bei Governance und BCP-Prozessen ein zentraler Player?
Alles klar.
Das können nur wieder irgendwelche realitätsfernen Personalleute geschrieben haben, dieses Ding hier.
Niemand, den ich kenne, der sich für diese Sache interessiert, würde auch nur im Traum so einen Satz rausbringen.
Und fördern aktiv mit ihren Dokumentationen und smarten Präsentationen ein Netzwerk zum Austausch über die RPA- und AI-Lösungen in der Bank.
Ich verstehe das mit den Robotics auch nicht. Vielleicht wären wir jetzt ja noch schlauer daraus.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das mit Robotics zu tun hat.
Mehrjährige Erfahrung bei Winner's Unix.
Ih, warum wollen die immer Java haben?
Gut, ich weiß, es ist Enterprise und vor allem bei Banken und so ist Java, aber muss...
Okay, Bewerbung ist raus, Leute. Instant.
Ich schreibe einfach rein.
Ich habe jahrzehntelange Erfahrung im Fintech-Umfeld als zentraler Player.
150k.
Weil wenn man schon so zentraler Player ist, da muss das sicher auch lohnen.
Man müsste das echt mal probieren, wenn man einfach nur die Stellenanzeige umschreibt.
Für den Anschreiben, wie das ankommt.
Und dann müsste man noch dahinter schreiben.
Und dann müsste man noch zu hinter geschrieben, das passt, Fragezeichen.
Okay, weiter.
Die haben schon mal schöne Image-Fonts am Start, das sind einfach nur Images.
Monitoring, Administration, Operational Service.
Okay, 24-7-Support.
Schichtarbeit, mal gucken.
Die heißen wirklich SVA System Vertrieb Alexander GmbH. Was ein Zungenbrecher.
Hast du schon mal deine Firma gewechselt? Ja, einmal habe ich die Firma gewechselt.
Ich habe gelernt, habe ich bei einem Provider und jetzt arbeite ich bei einer Bank.
Okay, also die SVA System Vertrieb Alexander GmbH, was ein Name.
Ist einer der führenden deutschen System-Integratoren.
Porsche, unabhängige Kernthemen des Unternehmens. Blah, blah, blah, blah.
Business Continuity, IT Service Management, SSAP.
Was? Den Satz kapiere ich nicht.
Darüber hinaus bietet SVA Unterstützung im Betrieb der Infrastruktur durch Operational Services mit System-Engineers schon ab First-Level und Service...
Ah, und Service Made in Germany, okay.
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
Installations-Administration von CheckMK.
Das verwenden noch Leute? CheckMK, das habe ich zum letzten Mal gesehen vor 10 Jahren oder so.
Das ist ein Nagios-Fork, wenn ich nicht ganz... Oder? Das ist doch ein Nagios-Fork gewesen.
Ja, genau, das war ein Nagios-Fork ursprünglich.
Ich kann überhaupt nichts zu sagen, Easy Killer. Ich kann wirklich nichts zu sagen.
Ich habe das vor 10 Jahren oder so das letzte Mal gesehen.
Gibt es da ein paar Bilder dazu?
Oh, das sieht immer noch voll Nagios-Style aus.
Das sieht voll Nagios-Style aus.
Programmierung von Checks für Nagios-CheckMK.
Verstellen und Pflegen von Regeln im Continuous-Management-Tool wie Solst. Oh, mal einer der Solst-Dec verwendet.
Aktuell ist er eher Ansible oder der Shit.
Tut aber gut seinen Dienst.
Genauso wie Nagios. Ganz ehrlich, Nagios ist zwar bestimmt nicht mehr der neueste Shit, aber Nagios tut einfach.
Das bringen sie mit.
Freude an der Arbeit im Team. Das hängt ganz entscheidend vom Team ab.
Starke Service-Orientierung, gute Kommunikationsfähigkeit, Deutschkenntnis auf Level C1. Was ist denn das?
Das heißt, ist das wie Muttersprache oder noch drunter?
Ich kann mir diese Level immer nicht merken.
Erfahrung mit CheckMK, Nagios oder Derivaten?
Ganz am Anfang, also bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber, habe ich mich mal fast eineinhalb Jahre um unser Nagios-Zeug gekümmert.
Und ich muss sagen, wenn man sich ein bisschen an die Nagios-Config gewöhnt hat, ist das eigentlich ganz angenehm.
Programmierkenntnisse, Bevorzug, Pausen und Bash, Konfigurations-Management, Bevorzug, Solst-Dec.
Da müsste ich jetzt sagen, könnte ich nicht mithalten, weil ich hab mit Solst-Dec, ich weiß was es ist.
Hab ich keine Ahnung von, hab ich noch nie was mitgemacht.
Lendungskenntnisse, Bevorzug, Retard und CentOS, das ist Standard.
Wie gesagt, im Enterprise-Umfeld, weil sich vorher einer darüber aufgeregt hat, ich würde so oft Umfeld sagen, ist Retard ziemlich normal.
Zusätzliches Basiswissen in einem oder mehreren erfolgt mit dem Enterprise Storage-Virtualisierung SAP.
DB2, Oracle, Backup-Lösung, IBM Spectrum Protect, hab ich auch noch nie was von gehört.
Ich find die Stellenanzeigen gar nicht so schlecht.
Das ist jetzt nichts, wo ich sagen würde, wow, da bist du ja voll hin und weg und voll begeistert.
Aber wenigstens, komm, die schreiben einfach wie es ist und die haben auch nicht irgendwelche überzogenen Dinger.
Das macht doch einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Ich mein, letztendlich wird das hier sowas sein.
Wahrscheinlich ist das so, das ist halt so halbsupport.
Oder 80% Support, man, so lese ich das jetzt.
Aber warum nicht? Ich find's nicht verkehrt.
Aber ich mein, das ist natürlich unter unserem Niveau-Chat, weil wir sind ja Enabler im Hyperscale-Enterprise-Umfeld.
Das ist das hier, das hier für uns natürlich nichts.
Aber natürlich sind wir zentrale Player.
Zentrale Enable-Player.
Zahlen bestimmt also 30k als Lohn.
Easykiller, ganz ehrlich, ich finde, das liest sich tatsächlich ein bisschen wie sowas in der Richtung.
Als suchen die einen Support-Mann, weil die schreiben ja auch hier Quereinsteiger und sonst was.
Als suchen die quasi Junior-Admin-Einsteiger, die einfach suchen und...
Ja, jetzt doch vielleicht auch nicht so die wahnsinnig Ansprüche haben.
Aber kann man machen.
Die verschleiern das hier irgendwie nicht, hinter irgendwie 30 Millionen Bass zu schreiben, manchmal wie es ist.
STBA42, vier Monate, dankeschön.
Big Prane-Sub.
Die kenn ich, ich weiß nicht woher.
Der Name kommt mir übelst bekannt vor.
Ich glaube bei denen haben wir Glasfaser-Leitung gekauft.
Nagios, Syslog, Network-Management.
Fiber-Networks.
Haben sie das stehen gehabt?
Ja, hatten die Fiber stehen?
Ah ja, dann sind das die, von denen wir Glasfaser gekauft haben.
Fujitsu, Systems-Management.
Manage Now Monitoring.
Soll dann das sein.
Ob Hardware oder Cloud Solutions, SAP oder AI oder...
Das ist ja schon ziemlich random alles zusammengewürfelt, oder?
Gut, das ist ja auch Absicht.
Sie wollen ja auch sagen, sie sind global überall dabei.
Aber das ist schon ziemlich random.
Hardware, Cloud, SAP, IoT, AI.
Als globaler Konzern bietet Fujitsu das gesamte Spektrum an IT.
Unser Ziel ist es unsere Kunden pragmatisch im Alltag zu...
Und sie gleichzeitig für die digitale Transformation zu rüsten.
Okay, also.
Administration und Weiterhaltung von System-Management Infrastruktur.
Ja.
Installation und Überwachungstunnel.
Entsprechend einfach IOR.
Entwicklung, Anpassung, Skript.
IOR mit Arbeiten.
Normal.
Okay.
Kundkennensinn, Betriebssystem.
Optionale Kundkennensinn-Tools.
BMC Patrol.
TrueSight oder Service Tracker.
Halt man das echt so?
Ach, Tracer.
BigBrain Aussprache.
Service Tracer.
Kommunikationsfähigkeit, Englisch.
So, also.
Die Anforderung ist jetzt nicht sonderlich hoch.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch in so einem 30K-Support-Job.
Dank hoher Eigenverantwortung und Flexibilität haben sie die Möglichkeit, wirklich etwas zu bewirken.
An der Stelle will ich mal eine Sache loswerden.
Weil da schreiben ja so viele.
Es gibt durchaus Leute, die sind da gar nicht so scharf drauf,
dass sie eine hohe Eigenverantwortung haben und flexibel sind und was bewirken können.
Sie wollen eigentlich nur hingehen, arbeiten, Geld verdienen und wieder heimgehen.
Sie wollen gar nichts bewirken.
Und deswegen schreiben so viele.
Ich meine, für die meisten wird es kein allzu großer Vorteil sein, dass man hier irgendwie was bewirken kann.
Die meisten Leute wollen einfach Geld verdienen, weil sie Geld verdienen müssen.
Durch flexible Arbeitszeiten, das kann was Gutes und Schlechtes heißen.
Ja, Nilo ist so.
Es kommt halt auch auf den Laden an.
Also bei mir ist es, also persönlich, jetzt kann er immer nur von mir ausgehen.
Ich habe da, also je nach Umfeld, aber ich bin der Sache prinzipiell gar nicht abgeneigt.
Also ich gebe gerne mein Senf dazu, wenn ich sehe, dass irgendwas nicht funktioniert,
oder wo ich mir denke, das könnte man anders machen, da gebe ich gerne mein selbst Senf dazu.
Aber viele Läden wollen das irgendwie gar nicht, weil wenn man 20 Mal was gesagt hat
und 20 Mal ist es im Sand verlaufen und 20 Mal bekommst du keine Rückmeldung oder irgendwas,
irgendwann hast du wenig Bock, ja, irgendwann hast du wenig Bock noch mitzumachen bei so was.
Und das kann man den Leuten ja auch nicht wirklich vorwerfen.
Wir hatten auch letztens so eine, wir werden besser Aktionen auf der Arbeit.
Da habe ich mich angemeldet, ich glaube, das habe ich ja schon erzählt, oder?
Da habe ich mich für angemeldet und da haben wir ein halbes Jahr, haben wir uns Dinge ausgedacht,
die man verbessern könnte in einem gewissen Bereich.
So und jetzt, sie haben dann groß erzählt, so nach dem Motto, ja, es werden alle Punkte angegangen
und jetzt kommt halt mit der Zeit raus, dass sich halt einfach nichts tut in dem Bereich.
Das ist auch keinem wirklich großartig interessiert.
Also eine Sache, die wir vorgeschlagen haben, wurde gesagt, wollen wir überhaupt nicht.
Bei der anderen Sache wird es jetzt genau anders gemacht, als wir vorgeschlagen haben.
Und eines der ersten Sachen, die ich damals gefragt habe, wo es darum ging, wer mitmachen will,
habe ich gefragt, wie ist denn da so die Rückendeckung bei dieser Aktion?
Weil ich habe schon viele Aktionen mitgekriegt in dieser Richtung und die sind meistens im Sand verlaufen.
Wie ist denn diesmal?
Und da waren alle ganz euphorisch und haben alle erzählt, so nach dem Motto,
diesmal ist das anders, diesmal haben wir hier von höchster Stelle Rückendeckung
und das soll jetzt passieren und soll jetzt sein.
Da habe ich mir gesagt, wisst ihr was, ich mache mal wieder mit.
Aber jetzt ist bei mir die Motivation erstmal eine Weile wieder weg.
Und ich glaube, es gibt viele Leute, die was bewirken wollen, aber einfach keinen Bock mehr darauf haben.
Und es gibt auch genug, die sagen, Leute, ich will einfach arbeiten, mein Geld verdienen
und ich will gar nichts bewirken.
Ich will einfach meine Arbeit ordentlich machen und Kohle verdienen und Gutes.
Ich sage ja auch immer, es ist nicht verkehrt, wenn man sich mit seinem Arbeitgeber identifizieren kann,
also sprich, wenn man gut findet, was sie machen oder wenn man sich da irgendwie aufgehoben fühlt.
Das ist nicht verkehrt.
Es ist für die Motivation mit Sicherheit auch gut, aber es ist nicht unbedingt notwendig.
Also sprich, man kann auch ohne Probleme irgendwo arbeiten und Geld verdienen,
ohne dass man den Laden toll findet oder ohne dass man toll findet, was der jeweilige Laden macht
oder dass man dahinter steht.
Man kann es einfach ganz pragmatisch sehen und sagen, ich gehe dahin, um Kohle zu verdienen
und gehe dann halt, wenn es Zeit ist, wieder heim.
Das ist auch nichts Verwerfliches dran.
Es ist beides, vollkommen legitim.
Man muss dann aber, finde ich, auch gucken als Arbeitgeber, dass man eben die Leute,
die wirklich dann auch was machen wollen und sich einsetzen,
dass man denen zumindest mal Gehör schenkt.
Sonst haben die irgendwann auch keinen Bock mehr.
Durch flexible Arbeitszeiten und Orte, wenn die wirklich was gemeint hätten,
was für mich gut ist, dann hätten sie geschrieben mit Homeoffice-Möglichkeit.
Dann wüsste ich, okay, da hat man was davon.
Ansonsten flexible Arbeitszeiten und Orte klingt eher so,
wie man muss random ran, eventuell Schichtarbeit und man weiß nicht genau wo.
Gemeinschaft und Wertschätzung ist eins, so wie Firmenfeiern und Team.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir schon mal genau, wer diese Stellenanzeige geschrieben hat.
Entweder irgendein Management-Typ oder irgendein Personalmensch,
der das wirklich geil findet.
Keiner in der IT, den ich kenne, mag wirklich Firmenfeiern.
Team-Events ist so ein bisschen 50, aber Firmenfeiern,
wo es dann nicht darum geht, wo es so halbe wie Repräsentierenfeiern sind,
dann, ne.
Ah ja, ah ja, gut.
Irgendjemand hat im Chat gerade geschrieben, ziemlich generic,
ja, liest sich ziemlich 015.
Okay, next.
Okay.
Two.
Tief.
Nice, nice.
Teamplayer.
Also Leute, ganz ehrlich, das wäre nix für mich.
Sowohl von dem, was sie suchen, als auch, was sie wollen.
Linux Ubuntu Server, easy, kann ich.
Aber ich komm keine Schmerzen mit.
Kann ich wahrscheinlich
Jetzt, ohne, ohne... Ich weiß selbst, worum es stinkt, aber wahrscheinlich besser als die meisten, die sich hier drauf bewerben, aber alles andere kann ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung von Windows, keine Ahnung von Hyper-V, keine Ahnung von Microsoft SQL, keine Ahnung von Exchange.
So gut wie keine Ahnung von ESX-Administrationen, auch keine Ahnung von V-Center, Zütrix und VM9.
So, was bieten sie denn? In einem dynamisch engagierten... Okay, das schreiben wir alle spannende Aufgaben, blablabla.
Okay, das ist 0815. Kannst vergessen.
Next.
Die Servos-Technologie GmbH.
Ah ja, wer kennt das nicht? Wer kennt das nicht, ja?
Normal. So stehe ich auch immer vor einem Rack. Vor allem im Notebook, auf den Fingerspitzen.
Die sieht irgendwie sehr streng aus, da hinten.
Das sieht nicht aus, wie jemand aus der IT. Das sieht eher so nach Prozessoptimierung aus oder so.
Alt heißt das Wort, nee. Oh ja, hier. Das muss das auch noch mal... Aber was haben die hier?
Adobe Stock. Okay, das Zeug heißt schon... Hä? Moment, ich will das aufmachen, das da. Wie? Geht nicht?
Ei, ei, ei. Ich wollte mir jetzt den Typ da angucken, was der macht. Was ist das? Die
Doppel-Null-Agenten im Arbeitsbereich IT-Dienstleistung. Okay, vielleicht wird es ja noch besser.
Und zwar ganzheitlich und wertschöpfen. Das ist unser Ziel. Dafür ziehen wir alle an einem
Strang am liebsten mit dir, weil du gerne in unterschiedlicher IT-Umgebung unterwegs bist.
Vom Helpdesk bis zum Monitoring. Vom Helpdesk bin ich ungern unterwegs, ehrlich gesagt. Von
der Projektplanung, Kundenmittel bis zum Rollout. Also vier ITler sind schon... Oh, ganze vier Stück?
Hui! Huge! Kein Wunder, da musst du ja auch wirklich alles machen. Mal davon abgesehen,
das kann gar nicht... Also das kann ganz gut sein. Es ist nicht schlecht, wenn man alles machen muss,
pauschal. Wenn es nämlich wirklich nur vier Leute gibt in der IT. Ich habe zwar keine Ahnung,
wie die mit vier IT-Leuten, die Doppel-Null-Agenten im Bereich IT-Dienstleistung sein wollen, passt
irgendwie nicht so ganz zusammen. Aber okay, das kann gut sein. Also wenn man sich mit den Leuten
gut versteht, das muss nichts Schlechtes sein, wenn man wirklich bei jedem Mist... So war das bei uns
ganz am Anfang auch, wo ich noch Azumi war. Da waren vier Leute oder fünf Leute oder so am Start.
Du hast alles irgendwie gemacht. Das war gar nicht schlecht. Das war gar nicht so übel. Es kommt
halt ein bisschen darauf an, wie das Umfeld mit einem umgeht. Gehalt weit über dem Durchschnitt.
Gleich mal safen hier. Vertrag unbefrist, Homeoffice ab und an möglich. Und sonst tolle Benefits plus
standortspezifische Feinheiten. Dein Chrome laggt, also bei mir laggt nichts. Aufgaben. Irgendwie
klingen die Jobs in der IT- und Informationstechnologie immer gleich. Das liegt, da haben sie Recht,
aber das liegt zum größten Teil daran, dass mittlerweile nur noch Personal-Buzzword-Dinger von
irgendwelchen Personalleuten Buzzword-Anzeigen geschrieben werden oder gar nicht genau weißt,
was die eigentlich wollen. Wie viel besser ist es dann, wenn du gleich aus erster Hand weißt,
wie ein Tag bei uns aussieht? Dein neuer Job ist entstanden, weil unsere Teamverstärkung
braucht, rund um die Themen IT-Inforschung, Systementwurfs, Immigration, Serverlandschaft,
Projektarbeit, Realisierung, neue Lösung. Dein künftiger Kollege Daniel sagt dir,
was er im Einzelnen macht. Ideas. Rich Prime, Dankeschön. POG. Für diese Woche ist die Planung
für eine Migration der alten Lösung geplant. Okay, es ist sehr ultra spezifisch. Eine Planung
für eine Migration der alten Lösung. Ah ja, alles klar. Der Terminwarnhut steht heute
an, um die offenen Punkte zu besprechen. Der Chef bzw. der Anspruch, er fordert das Gespräch,
diskutiert und entschieden. Nach dem Gespräch, wenn die Systeme überall... Irgendwie liest
sich das voll wie sowas, wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe. Also damals, als es noch klein
war. Einfach fünf Leute, die sich um jeden Scheiß kümmern müssen. Und es irgendwie
geht. Nach dem Gespräch werden die Systeme überprüft, es gibt Klärungsbar. Okay, das
kommt vor. Schnell mal einen Kollegen anrufen und fragen, was er dazu meint. Weiter geht's.
Die Kundendokumentation läuft automatisch während der Arbeit mit. Ich habe es noch nie
erlebt, dass eine Dokumentation automatisch passiert. Zu den meisten Sachen gibt's gar
keine Dokumentation. Eine Zusammenfassung der Arbeit kommt dann ins CRM-Distem. Warum
ist das auf einmal so laut? Gut zu wissen, selten mal eine Reise oder Rufbereitschaft
und Konzentration. Ich finde die Anzeige nicht schlecht. Aus einem Grund, die versuchen
erst gar nicht so auf, wir sind Marktführer im Bereich XY und Hyperscaler, Enabler, Technologien,
Speed-Architekturen, blablabla. Die sagen einfach, wir sind IT-Lienstleister für im
Endeffekt so Leute für alles. Ich finde die Anzeige gar nicht so blöd. Aber wahrscheinlich
auch nur, weil das halt so ist, wie das bei dem Laden war, wo ich meine Ausbildung angefangen
habe. Da war das halt mehr oder weniger so. Du hast die Lizenz zur IT. Ein bisschen cringy
geschrieben ist es ja schon. Warum tippst du ständig eine Einzelne, die überlöscht
sie dann wieder? Da haben wir sogar ein extra Kommando für, warum ich das mache. Du hast
die Lizenz. Dein Weg, IT-Studium weiter mit dieser Zertifizierung. Das Einzige, was ich
zu bieten habe, ist das da und das ist seit 15 Jahren oder so abgelaufen oder noch länger.
Ne, seit, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, so lange nicht. Seit, ob es seit 11 Jahren abgelaufen oder
so. Deine zu viele Analysen, Deutsch, Englisch oder MS Office. Oh ja, da sind sie bei mir
genau richtig. Ich glaube, der Laden, also so mein Bauchgefühl wird mir sagen, der Laden
ist gar nicht schlecht. Ich glaube, der Laden ist gar nicht schlecht. Ein solider Arbeitgeber.
Lockeres IT, wo dir die Chemie stimmt. Okay, bla, bla, bla, bla. Ich glaube, die sind gar
nicht so übel. Okay, Frankfurts Dog-Foto. Moment. Warum soll ich Team-Viewer runterladen?
Was hat das auf der Webseite zu suchen? Da haben noch Team-Viewer. Haben die sich vertan
mit dem Icon da oben? Das Icon soll da nie im Leben, soll das Icon da oben hin. Wir gehen
jetzt erstmal auf unsere Linux-VM und gehen auf die Seite nochmal. Ach, hier gehts. Bei
mir und bei Windows ist die Seite kaputt. Null W. Guck mal. Bei mir ist die Seite kaputt.
Aber unter Linux, Firefox gehts. Oh nee, ein abgelaufenes Zertifikat. Please.
Yourserver.de?
ja. Okay. Accept. Oh, okay. So wirklich gut funktionieren tut es ja nicht, ja.
DreiEistraße9? Wo ist das denn? Wo ist das denn? Es sagt überhaupt nichts. Ach, hier
am Südbahnhof. Ach nee, doch am Südbahnhof. Ach, da ist das ja voll um die Ecke. Na gut,
aber da will ich nicht hin. Aber ganz ehrlich, Leute, man merkt, dass die Anzeige nicht einfach,
ja nicht einfach irgendwie so nach so nur nach 15 Zeug zusammengewerkelt ist, ja. Ich finde
die gar nicht schlecht. Oh je. Ja gut, da bin ich natürlich nicht dabei. Na, wenn ich
Feierabend habe, dann gehe ich heim und treffe mich nicht erst noch zum Umdrück. So weit
über Durchschnitt. Ich glaube, die sind gar nicht schlecht. Ich glaube, die sind gar nicht
so übel. So, nächste. Ganz ehrlich, die Grinser auf dem Foto sprechen mich deutlich weniger
an als das hier. Aber auch wenn Stockfoto sind, ja. Wenn die nicht mal ein richtiges
Zertifikat haben. Das ist halt noch so ein richtiger, so ein richtiger Frickelladen,
ja. Da macht jeder noch alles und jeder findet überall dran rum. Was nicht schlecht sein
muss. Okay, was suchen die hier? Die Caritas in Frankfurt. Oh. Systemadministrator, Systemadministratorin.
Ah, wenigstens D. Sonst wäre jetzt die Anzeige gleich raus. Suchst du für dich oder einfach
so? Einfach so. Ich meine, wenn jetzt, wenn es das irgendwie mega geiles mal gibt, würde
ich mich da auch drauf bewerben oder wenn es hier irgendwie sich was ergibt auch, aber
ich suche eigentlich nichts. Männchen stärken, Wege finden. Blabla. Wohlfallsbande katholisch.
Oh ja, das ist ja genau das Richtige für mich. Weil ich ja so, so unglaublich gläubig
bin. Blabla, blabla, blabla. Citrix Server. Windows. Oh je, es ist, es ist Windows. Dabei
sind sie fliege. User, rechte Vergabe, Active, direkte. Oh Gott, oh Gott, hör mir auf. Wann
hast du zuletzt Overwatch gespielt? Oh, ein halbes Jahr oder so. Ich hab mal zur Duo-Q
zu, als, als nicht Duo, als als Rollselekt rausgekommen ist, hab ich mal ein bisschen
paar Runden gespielt. Nee, es ist Windows. Das ist überhaupt nichts für mich. I-Til-V3-Zertifizio.
Weiche. Die sollten doch eigentlich wissen, wo der Teufel drin steckt als katholische,
als katholische Organisation, wie was mit der katholischen Kirche zu tun hat. Und wenn
irgendwo der Teufel drin ist, dann in I-Til-V3. Ein abgeschlossener Ausbilder. Blabla, sehr
gute Kenntnisse, Praxiserfangen, sehr Active. Active, direktorie. NTFS, rechte Vergabe, okay,
es ist Windows Admin. Es ist Windows Admin, also definitiv nichts für mich. Oh, jetzt
kommt Grip. Nee, Grieb, Grieb. Oh, Aja-Ja-Musik, ja. Ach so, das beaten wir. Das erste. Okay,
ich guck noch mal. Wenn's aufgeht. Will nicht. Ah, jetzt. Genial. Eine wertschätzende Unternehmenskunde
auf Grundeinrichtung. Ey, so schlecht ist es doch gar nicht. Wenn's um Nächstenliebe
geht, ey, wenn die das wirklich machen, was die hinschreiben, es gibt doch wirklich Schlimmeres.
Vergrütung nach TV-ÖD. Was ist TV-ÖD? Öffentliche Dienstpunktinfo. Okay, das heißt, man verdient
nichts. Man verdient schon was. Ja. Was, man braucht Bibelkenntnissen? Das wär's
doch, ey, das wär doch geil. Bibelkenntnisse. Okay, next, wir machen Grieb, Grieb.
Drops. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie kann ich hier filtern? Ich hab die Seite geprickt.
Drinnen. Nein. Nein. Wo kann man hier überhaupt, ich
check hier nicht, was man da sortieren kann. Wo kann man hier nach zivil filtern? Auf aktuelle
Stellen. Okay, okay. Auf aktuelle Stellen, aktuelle Stellen. Ich schau ziemlich bescheuert,
dass man das später nicht filtern kann, ne? Ihre Interessen kämpfen. Ah, hier, Zivilika,
ja. Okay, und schon sieht die Seite gleich viel ekliger aus. Okay. Kirchenhilfkraft.
Und, und, und wo kann ich jetzt suchen nach? Scheiße, das ist ja eklig, die Seite. Entsäulnungsgrund
ist höchste natürlich. Technology. Okay, fahrt näher. Kein Bock. Was wollten wir noch
gucken?
Ähm, gab's noch was, was wir gucken wollten? Okay. Oh, jetzt, jetzt gibt's natürlich
huge money. Max MonkaS. Warum MonkaS? Warum MonkaS? Warum nicht? Behind you. Ja, hinter
mir steht mein, ähm, Mikrofonständer. Da. Offene Stellen. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Er macht diese Seiten hier, bitteschön, immer. Da enemy. Kein Wunder, dass du da nichts
findest. Ähm, Premore, kommt darauf an, also kommt überhaupt an, was man macht. Kann man
Kann man das nicht ordentlich filtern nach irgendwas?
Ein...
Was ist das denn hier?
IT-Administrator für zentrale Netze.
Aha!
Ach so.
Man sollte vielleicht...
Kann man...
Man kann nicht immer nach Ort filtern, oder?
IT und Telekommunikation. Boah.
Follow-Data ist halt überfristet. Guck mal.
Hinweis.
Das Referat.
RZ-Lan, WLAN und zentrale Netzdienste.
Das klingt schon so...
So Beamten...behördenmäßig.
Also folgende Aufgabe erwarten ich.
Erstellung und Pflege von Konzepten für die zentrale Netzdienste.
IP-Adress für KB, DH, CP, DNS und NTP.
Das ist nichts, was man irgendwo reinschreiben muss.
Erstellung und Pflege von IPv4 und IPv6-Adresskonzepten.
Das klingt...das klingt mal sehr lahm, irgendwie.
Mindestens 9 Jahren, ja.
Hab ich locker.
Okay, also...
Ach nee, das ist nicht das, was man kriegt.
Sehr gute...was ist das für eine beknackte Anzeige?
Das ist eine total beknackte Anzeige.
Da sagt er gar nichts.
Ach so, doch hier.
Mit ihrer Perwärmung...
Zwei Schichtbetrieb, okay.
Und Tschüss.
Entgeltgruppe 12...
TV-ÖD?
Okay, wir gucken mal wenigstens, was wir verdienen würden.
Entgeltgruppe 12...
Was ist das da oben?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6...
Was ist das?
Die Jahre?
Die Jahre, wo man dabei ist?
Was, die Stufen?
Ja, aber da steht überhaupt keine Stufe dabei.
Ah, nach Jahren.
Oh, das ist doch gar nicht so übel.
Aber das sind bestimmt keine 6 Jahre, oder?
Das sind bestimmt keine 6 Jahre.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so ein komisches System, wie...
2 Jahre, 2 Jahre...
Und dann hier 3 Jahre...
Und hier 5 Jahre, irgendwie so komisch.
Ja, genau, 15 Jahre.
Genau, genau, irgendwie sowas.
Wobei das hier geht.
Das hier geht, das hier geht in Ordnung.
Da muss man...
Das scheint ganz okay zu sein.
Ich meine, es ist die Frage, sind das 12 Monatsgehälter?
Sind das 13, 14 Monatsgehälter?
Sind das wahrscheinlich 12?
12 ist halt...
Das ist halt wenig, das ist zu wenig.
Dann kriegste...
Wobei, es geht, es geht eigentlich.
Für, für...
Wenn du einsteigst, wenn du einsteigst,
das geht, das doch, das geht.
Ja, wenn du einsteigst, dann kriegste...
42k im Jahr, das ist für einen Einstieg absolut in Ordnung.
So schlecht ist das gar nicht.
Ich meine, das hier ist natürlich schon...
Das ist natürlich schon...
Das ist doch in Ordnung!
Also ich hab jetzt eigentlich gedacht...
Man verdient da nichts.
Hoffentlich schaust du auch für den richtigen Bereich, achso, aha, ach stimmt wahrscheinlich
gucke ich falsch, ja, tvö die bunt, muss man mal gucken, Moment, äh, 12, 14, 15,
12, Stufe 1, ah, ok, das sieht schon wieder ein bisschen, na doch, ist doch das gleiche,
das ist ok, ich finde das, das macht eigentlich ganz, eindrucks, ganz ok, ah, 45k zum Einstieg
ist echt in Ordnung, kann man nichts sagen, also mir wurde gesagt, mit einer Ausbildung
kannst du maximal bis E9 kommen, na gut, hier steht eindeutig, es wird nach, nach Entgeltgruppe
12 berechnet und wenn da Entgeltgruppe 12 steht, dann hat es diese, muss da Entgeltgruppe
12 sein, oder sie sagen, klar, ich kann mir nicht gebrauchen, ähm, beim BND, da habe
ich jetzt noch nicht geguckt, was hat denn da BND, BND jobs, zeig mal her, ok, haben
wir einen Standort, Pullach, Teufel ist Pullach, Junior Cybersicherheitsanalyst, License to
Hack, Konfiguration, Administration von Rechnersystem, Arbeitsort Berliner, das wäre für mich schon
mal nichts, ja da müssten die, also da müssten die mir echt viel bezahlen, ich finde das
immer geil, na, berufliche Gleichstellung und im gleichen Atemzug sagt man, ja, aber,
aber wir bevorzugen jemand, wo steht was, wo, wo steht was es zu bedienen, verdienen
gibt, ah hier, wie, das ist noch, noch weniger, das ist ja deutlich weniger als bei den anderen,
ja, ne, dann nicht, gut, ich mein, also gerade die hier, die müssen da auch ordentlich was,
was rüber wachsen lassen, weil die brauchen Leute, Mindestlohnagenten beim BND, ja, man
muss, naja, wenn man, wenn man Mindestlohnagent ist, dann ist man ja hoffentlich wenigstens
Patriot und überzeugt, ja, dann macht man das auch umsonst, so, bei der Gelegenheit,
wie warm ist eigentlich unser Raspberry eigentlich, ok, also der Raspberry rechnet jetzt seit
dreieinhalb Stunden unter Volllast, dreieinhalb Stunden Volllast rechnet er und er wird 55
Grad, ich glaube, man kann sagen, was, Nip hat, Nip hat mal wieder gewonnen, oh mein,
Nip ist doch nicht mal Nip, Nip ist doch jetzt bei, bei Dignitas, oder, die, die ehemaligen
Nip Leute, ok, Ubuntu, Power off, Power off, bam, weg, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok sunset
mal keinen so schlechten Eindruck gemacht von der Kohle. Man müsste mal gucken, in welchem zeitlichen
Abstand das dann passiert mit mehr Geld, aber so schlecht fand ich das jetzt gar nicht.
Wie ist die M2 SSD an dem S3D par eingeschlossen? Per Adapter auf USB.
So Leute, das war ein ganz schön langer Stream. Guck mal hier, 5 Stunden 55.
So lange war ich lange nicht mehr on. Müssen wir noch dringend irgendwas klären Leute? Gibt
es noch was, gibt es noch was was spannendes, was man noch, was man noch besprechen müsste?
Wie ist das ausgegangen mit der Nextcloud? Es funktioniert ganz gut,
aber es fehlt noch so der Feinschliff. Nächstes Video.
AX7 habe ich mir noch nicht überlegt, aber für meinen YouTube-Channel eignen sich meine
Livestreams nicht. Das ist nicht das, was die meisten Leute dort interessiert.
Dofe Frage, aber wie ressourcenlos ist der Paket-Track so? Meinst du meinen? Meine komische,
unfertige, du meinst nicht meinen, oder? Du meinst nicht meinen komischen, unfertigen Versand-Tracker?
Doch, der braucht so gut wie nichts an Ressourcen. Was hältst du von zertifikaner
Tier wie z.B. CCNA? Kommt immer darauf an, ob du mal an Leute gerätst, die auf so was
stehen. Ich persönlich finde es ziemlich unnütz. Zumal es gerade wie bei Microsoft-Zertifikaten
halt teilweise lächerlich ist. Wusstest du dir, dass bei einem Azure-Zertifikat gezählt wird,
wie viele Klicks ihr im UI braucht, ob ihr besteht oder nicht? Du musstest exakt den
Microsoft-Way machen, ansonsten blickst du raus. Ich halte da wenig von. Zusammenfassung
zum Thema Office 365 Alternative? Näh, nicht wirklich. Keine gute Alternative. Es funktioniert,
man kann zusammen Dokumente bearbeiten, es fehlt aber noch der Feinschliff irgendwo.
Welche Informatik-Bereiche würdest du machen, wenn ich nicht das mache, was ich jetzt mache?
Dann würde ich programmieren mittlerweile. Ich meine, wie gesagt, ich habe ja mal bei
einem Provider angefangen, ursprünglich, da habe ich auch mal eine Ausbildung gemacht,
aber auf reine Server-Administration-Geschichte habe ich keinen Bock mehr.
Helpdesk. Ich kriege es ja täglich mit. Ich sitze ja auf der Arbeit in einem anderen Büro,
also in einem anderen Büro, als mein restliches Team sitzt und dort, wo ich sitze, sitzt halt
auch unser First-Level, so eine Mischung aus First- und Second-Level-Support. Eine Mischung
aus First, Second und Monitoring-Team, so eine wilde Mischung sitzt da und was ja teilweise
für Leute anrufen, da hätte ich echt keinen Bock drauf. Ich mache da ab und zu mal,
dass ich mich dazu überrede, mal ins Telefon zu gehen, wenn gerade mal alle weg müssen,
um manche Sachen, nee, den ganzen Tag müsste ich das nicht machen.
Was machst du aktuell? Habe ich ein Video zugemacht, wenn es dich genau interessiert,
kannst du dir das hier angucken bei mir auf YouTube.
Ja Easykiller kann ich euch vorstellen. First-Level-Support ist der größte Crap, den es gibt. Vor allem,
wenn man halt jemand ist, der Leute nicht mag. Ihr wisst ja, ich mag Menschen nicht und
da ist First-Level-Support kacke. First-Level-Support für mich ist für mich eine Zumutung und für
den, der anruft, eine Zumutung. Den Chat, klar, den Chat mag ich. Den Chat ist beste.
Ja und nee, es wird ein bisschen damit rumgebastelt, aber nichts, wo man sagen könnte, da laufen
jetzt super wichtige Sachen drauf. Wie geht man am besten als angehende Informatiker
mit einer abgeschlossenen Ausbildung eine Gehaltsverhandlung? Da bin ich glaube ich
nicht der Richtige für. Ich hätte da bisher immer Glück. Ich kriege ja seit letztem Jahr
October, also ich habe es ja auf Twitter geschrieben, kriege ich ja wieder mehr Kohle. Einfach nur
weil ich mal gesagt habe, es wird mal wieder Zeit. Also ich habe da echt Glück. Ich musste
da noch nie so richtig knallhart verhandeln hier. Bam, auf geht's Leute. Auf jeden Fall
ist es nicht verkehrt, wenn du weißt, was du kannst. Das kann man so generell durch
die Bank weg eigentlich sagen. Und vor allem, wenn du einschätzen kannst, wie das halt im
Verhältnis zu der Masse der Leute ist. Also wenn du weißt, die brauchen dich in dem Bereich
und in diesem Bereich bist du saubermäßig gut und in diesem Bereich gibt es halt auch
nicht so viele Leute, die ähnlich gut sind. Das ist zumindest schon mal wichtig zu wissen.
Und meistens, doch ich kann dir einen Tipp geben. Meistens verhandelst du gar nicht direkt
mit dem, der dann am Endeffekt wirklich unterschreibt, dass du mehr Geld kriegst, je nachdem wie
groß die Firma ist. Das muss man sagen. Also es kann aber durchaus sein, dass du nicht
direkt mit dem verhandelst, der am Ende wirklich unterschreibt, dass du mehr Geld kriegst.
Aber derjenige, der dem verkaufen muss, dass du mehr Geld kriegst. Also sprich, wenn du
mit deinem Teamleiter jetzt über mehr Geld verhandelst, dann ist es nicht dein Teamleiter,
der am Ende und wirklich konkret final unterschreibt, dass du mehr Geld kriegst. Aber du musst weniger
dein Teamleiter überzeugen, weil wahrscheinlich ist er sogar schon überzeugt. Du musst ihm
aber gute Argumente geben, wie er seinen Chef davon überzeugen kann, dass du mehr kriegen
sollst. So und die musst du eigentlich überzeugen und das machst du am besten, indem du quasi
deinem Chef gutes Material zur Verfügung stellst, wie er das gut verkaufen kann. Weil
er freut sich letztendlich auch, wenn er sich nichts aus den Fingern sorgen muss. Weil
es ist für deinen Chef auch blöd zu sagen, so hier gibt nichts, ich kann nichts machen
und so. Das macht er meistens auch, je nachdem was du für einen hast, wahrscheinlich auch
nicht gerne. Wenn der gute, wenn der stichhaltige Sachen weitergeben kann, ist es für alle
Beteiligten einer der besten. Ja, also Quai, bei mir ist das das letzte Mal auch ähnlich
gewesen. Ich hab auch nur mal so ganz grob gesagt, hier so nach dem Motto, es wird mal
wieder Zeit, hier das, das und das. So mehr oder weniger zwischen Tür und Angel, wir
haben da gar nicht wirklich großartig drüber gesprochen und irgendwann kurz bevor ich heim
gehen will, kommt er an und drückt mir einen Umschlag in die Hand und sagt, hier guck
mal rein. Und ich sag, ah ok, ah cool, gib mir Geld. So ungefähr lief meine letzte Gehaltsverhandlung.
Deswegen ich bin nicht der Richtige, wenn es darum geht, wie man richtig krass verhandelt.
Aber ich kann mich bei mir eh nicht großartig beschweren. Ich mein, die Kohle ist jetzt
nicht so, dass man sagen würde, es ist voll übertrieben viel, aber für das, was man,
für das was von einem verlangt wird und so das Gesamtpaket ist das wirklich in Ordnung,
was man kriegt. Ich hab's euch ja letztens mal gezeigt, ich weiß es ja nicht, also ich,
ich weiß nicht, wie viel ich verdiene. Ich muss jedes Mal nachgucken und wir haben uns
ja letztens das angeguckt im Stream, das was zumindest im aktuellen Tarifvertrag drin
steht, das heißt, die, die dabei gewesen sind, wissen es ungefähr, das ist ein Ticken mehr
als das, was im Tarifvertrag steht, aber das ist schon mal eine ganz gute Hausnummer. Legst
du dein Geld an? Ja, aber nicht so, nicht so gut, wie ich könnte. Ich hab viel zu viel
Geld rumliegen, sagen wir's mal so. Ich, ich mache ein paar Sachen ja, aber ich müsste
viel mehr Sachen machen. Das meiste liegt einfach nur sinnlos rum. Ja, Jinkly, das ist,
das ist wohl wahr, außer, außer du bist damit zufrieden und hast keinen Bock dich weiter
damit zu beschäftigen, so war's bei mir halt zum letzten Mal. Einfach alles in ETFs, da
hab ich tatsächlich auch schon dran gedacht, aber nicht alles. Bei mir kommt aber noch dazu,
was, was auch bei mir, seitdem ich das mal realisiert hab, für ein sehr so ausgeglichenes
Leben irgendwie sorgt, ja, also wo ich mir wenig Gedanken machen muss, einfach, ich
hab immer noch die Möglichkeit mit meinem YouTube, Twitch, RefLink, sonst was, Geschiss,
Kohle zu machen und man verdient ja auch immer noch ein bisschen was dabei, das ist schon
mal nicht schlecht und ich verdient was von der Arbeit, das heißt ich bin auf keines
von beiden so richtig krass hundertprozentig angewiesen, dass das jetzt, dass ich damit
quasi alles machen könnte, was ich wollte, weil ich hab immer noch was anderes und außerdem
ist bei mir ja auch so, ich, ich brauch nicht so viel Kohle, also ich muss mir keine Rolex
kaufen, ja. Könntest du zu hundertprozentig von YouTube und Twitch leben? Na jetzt so
gerade definitiv nicht, so garantiert nicht, will ich auch gar nicht, will ich gar nicht,
ich will das gar nicht so ernst nehmen, wie manche halt auf YouTube, guck mal, wie, der
eine Typ letztens, ne, wisst ihr wo das hinführt, wenn die Leute quasi auf YouTube angewiesen
sind und YouTube zu ernst nehmen, dann führt das zu solchen Ausgeburten, wie der eine,
der den Tod seiner Freundin gefakt hat, um Videoclicks zu generieren. Habt ihr das mitgekriegt?
War das nicht, das war letztes Jahr schon glaub ich, ne, Ende letzten Jahres oder so?
Der irgendwie gefakt hat, dass seine Freundin gestorben ist und die Familie der Freundin
hat auch gedacht, sie ist gestorben und, ähm, dann hat er irgendwie noch ein Video gemacht,
wo er am Grab war und geweint hat, wo man sich auch denken kann, alter wie gestört
kann man sein und danach hat er noch ein Video gemacht, wo er versucht hat irgendwie ihren
Geist zu kontaktieren und sowas. Solche Ausmaße nimmt das an, wenn man YouTube zu ernst nimmt
und komplett von YouTube abhängig ist. Genau, du musst es halt machen, das ist egal, ob
du Fulltime YouTube Mensch bist, Fulltime Twitch Mensch bist, das ist vollkommen wurscht,
du musst halt, und sobald man muss, ähm, ja stellen sich, ist es halt, wird es halt
schnell von Spaß zu Stress, ja. Viele Sachen, die man gerne macht und auch oft und lange
gerne macht, sobald man die wirklich immer machen muss, fängt es an, wo es keinen Bock
mehr macht. Ja, du kannst auch mal öfters, ja, können könnte ich schon, ja. Deswegen
finde ich es nicht verkehrt, so wie es bei mir gerade ist. Ich verdiene mit vier Tage
pro Woche, also ich bin vier Tagen auf der Arbeit, verdiene ich ganz okay, ach, ich meine,
reich wirst du davon nicht, aber es ist schon in Ordnung und also das Gesamtpaket ist echt
okay und, ähm, je nachdem, was ich so YouTube und Twitch und sonst was mäßig mache, gibt
es ja auch nochmal ganz gut Kohle, deswegen ich bin da wirklich sehr ausgeglichen, was
so meine finanzielle Geschichte angeht. Dazu kommt noch, dass ich ja das Haus hier, meine
Mutter hat das Haus vom Opa geerbt, aber im Prinzip habe ich ein Haus, ja, ähm, ich
bin da, was die finanzielle Sache angeht, bin ich, fühle ich mich echt entspannt. Viermal
acht Stunden, ne, viermal 7,48 sind es glaube ich. Wie ist das eigentlich mit der Rente,
wenn du nur Teilzeit arbeitest, zahlst du freiwillig? Nö, mache ich nicht, aber ich
habe noch, ich habe ja, äh, bei meinem Arbeitgeber noch, ähm, so eine betriebliche Altersvorsorge
abgeschlossen, wo die einen Teil bezahlen und ich einen Teil bezahle und damit, von
da kriege ich quasi eh schon fast mehr Geld als von meiner normalen Rente. Wenn ich meine
Rente gehe, gibt es eh kaum was, kann es voll knicken, ja. Ähm, ich muss euch aber ehrlich
sagen, also ich habe nicht vor, bis, was auch immer Rentenalter ist, wenn ich meine Rente
gehe, bis 70 oder so zu arbeiten. Garantiert nicht. Also wenn das so läuft, wie ich mir
das aktuell vorstelle, mit 50 ist Schluss. Wie gesagt, ich brauche auch nicht viel Kohle,
genau, dann wäre ich Fulltime Streamer. Wie soll das klappen? Naja, aus der Kombination,
dass ich erstens nicht wahnsinnig viel Kohle brauche, dass ich ein Haus habe und dass ich
auch schon ordentlich Kohle mittlerweile auf dem Konto liegen habe, die ich mal anlegen
müsste, ich weiß, ähm, da müsste ich eigentlich über die Runden kommen. Ich meine, ich kann
keine riesen Sprünge machen und irgendwie, äh, jeden zweiten Wochenende irgendwo hinfahren
oder so oder hinfliegen oder so. Okay, ich meine, ich habe mittlerweile, sag mal, wenn
ich das, wenn ich mal, wenn ich die beiden, wenn ich die beiden Konten zusammenzähle,
habe ich ungefähr über den Daumen gepeilt, ungefähr 100k, ungefähr ein bisschen aufgerundet
so in dem Dreh. Mittlerweile schon quasi, ja, angespart könnte man es eigentlich auch
schon nennen. Es war nicht alles, was da um was, es liegt jetzt nicht alles auf dem Konto
rum. Ähm, ein paar Sachen habe ich investiert, ein paar Sachen habe ich auch verliehen, aber
das größte Teil liegt halt noch rum. Und, ähm, bis ich in Rente oder bis ich, es sind
ja noch 15 Jahre hin, bis dahin habe ich dann nochmal ein bisschen was angesammelt und ich
habe ein Haus und ich kann, ich verdiene ja dann immer noch ein bisschen hier auch was
mit meinem Online-Kram. Also meine Hoffnungen sind, dass ich über die Runden komme. Irgendwann
kommen die Kinder und die Kohle brauchen, ja Leute, sollte ich mal irgendwann auf die,
mich in der geistigen Umnachtung befinden, doch noch Nachwuchs zu zeugen, dann habe ich
Pech. Dann habe ich gelitten. Einfach mal mit dem Finanzthema beschäftigen, ja, da
hast du vollkommen recht. Ähm, es ist ein Thema, was mich halt nicht interessiert und
was mir voll auf den Sack geht, aber ich weiß, dass ich mich damit beschäftigen muss, weil
die Kohle sonst, ne, nicht weg ist, aber unsinnigerweise weniger wird. Kinderarbeit, easy, Kinderhaut.
Ne, aber das habe ich nicht vor. Das habe ich echt nicht vor, Nachwuchs zu zeugen. Erstens,
es fehlt ja schon an zwei grundlegenden Voraussetzungen. Erstens will ich auf gar keinen Fall. Zweitens
fehlt mir auch jemand, mit dem ich es auch nur in Erwägung ziehen würde, Nachwuchs
zu zeugen. Beziehungsweise umgedreht auch jemand, der es mit mir in Erwägung ziehen
würde, Nachwuchs gibt es ja aktuell nicht. Also insofern, die Frage stellt sich bei
mir gerade weniger. Wie alt bin ich? Ich bin 35. Ah, yes. Squeeze it. Weil du nie zum
Punkt auf die Weihnachtsfeier, das, genau das ist es. Ist das Chromium? Ja, ist es.
Mein, bei mir liegt es eigentlich hauptsächlich daran, dass ich ultra faul bin, was zwischenmenschliche
Interaktionen angeht. Ist halt nun mal so. Was hältst du von Chromium aktuell? Naja,
das gleiche wie von Chrome. Also, Guck, ist ein ganz guter Browser. Es ist, bei mir ist
wirklich schlimm, ne. Also ich bin so unmotiviert, was zwischenmenschliche Sachen angeht, ist
der Wahnsinn. Ich war das schon immer, aber noch nie so unmotiviert. Sobald sich auch
nur ein bisschen was abzeichnet, was eventuell was werden könnte, kümmer ich mich einfach
nicht mehr drum. Ich hab euch doch vor, wann war das vor zwei Jahren von dem Weihnachtsgrill
erzählt, oder? Können sich vielleicht noch die einen oder anderen dran erinnern. An
das Weihnachtsgrill. Warum ist da nichts draus geworden? Zum größten Teil, weil ich mich
absolut nicht drum gekümmert hab. Weil ich das einfach komplett ignoriert hab. Kümmer
dich drum, du wirst es mal bereuen. Warum? Warum soll ich das bereuen? Wie können wir
dich für solche Sachen motivieren? Warum solltet ihr mich für sowas motivieren? Der
Q-Chat. Spenden. Genau. Bei einer Million Abos, war ich dann ein Speed-Dating-Livestreamer.
Wir möchten dich glücklich sehen. Ich bin glücklich. Ich brauch keinen FPS-Grill. Wenn
ich da irgendwie das Bedürfnis großartig verspüren würde, würde ich mich wahrscheinlich
auch mehr um zwischenmenschliche Sachen kümmern. Und das nicht einschlafen lassen, wie beim
Weihnachtsgrill vor zwei Jahren. Aber ich hab ja den Chat. Eine Million Abos hat nicht
so gut Kosten. Es gibt ja Leute, für die sind inzwischen menschlich einfach... Ja, ich
find das ultra anstrengend. Ich find Zwischenmenschen dann ultra anstrengend. Hast du schon von
Anytype ein... Das sagt mir irgendwas. Das sagt mir irgendwas. Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Das hab ich mir letztens angeguckt. Ich weiß aber nicht mehr, was es ist. Was ist es denn?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was es ist. Ich erkenne es nicht. Ich check's nicht. Übrigens, was
wir uns demnächst auch mal im Stream angucken müssen, ist... Das da. Das ist ein neuer...
Das ist von den... Soweit ich das gelesen hab, von den Gründern von Node.js. Die haben
jetzt eine neue JavaScript. Nicht Runtime. Das ist die Google Runtime. Eine neue JavaScript.
Ja, Runtime. Die Native Type Script kann. Und die angeblich viele Vorteile gegenüber
Node.js haben soll. Das wollte ich mir mal angucken, ob das wirklich was dran ist, dass
das so huge ist. Oh, das kenn ich. Das war doch mal... Vor einer Weile haben sie das doch
mal alle gestreamt. Vor einer Weile haben sie das doch mal alle gestreamt. Softlunar69,
Twitch Prime. Dankeschön. High IQ Sub. So. Ich war jetzt ganz schön lang on für meine
Verhältnisse. Du streamst ja immer noch. Ich weiß auch nicht, was da mit mir los ist
heute. Heute ist ganz schön lang. Ganz schön lang. Guck mal. 6 Stunden 21. Was ist da los?
Exquisite Livestream. Excellent. Ich hab letztens auf der Arbeit wieder irgendwelche Twitch
Memes von mir gegeben. Ich krieg's aber nicht mal zusammen. Ich hab irgendwie... Wie war
das? Der Azubi ist zu mir gekommen. Ich hatte ja vorletzte Woche mal wieder Azubi. Nächste
Woche übrigens wieder. Der ist mit irgendeinem Problem zu mir gekommen. Hat irgendwas nicht
hingekriegt. Und ich krieg's nicht mal zusammen. Aber ich glaube, ich hab irgendwie sowas gemacht
wie... Also ich hab ihm irgendwie gezeigt, wie es geht. Hab irgendwas eingetippt. Und
beim Enter drücken hab ich dann gesagt, ah, excellent. Five Head. Er hat halt null reagiert.
Der hat sich wahrscheinlich gedacht, was redet er? Vielleicht hab ich's einfach nicht richtig
verstanden. Das passiert mir öfters mittlerweile, wenn ich so in Gedanken bin und mir nicht
auffällt, dass ich quasi nicht vor dem Rechner sitze und Twitch Chat vor mir habe. Dass ich
manchmal Twitch Chat Sachen sage. Cringe vom Boomer ausbilder, ja. Weil es ja auch so
richtig Boomer-Style ist, excellent Five Head zu sagen. Ist ja allseits bekannt, dass Boomer
gerne Twitch gucken. Während der Arbeitszeit mit dem Chat sprechen... Es gibt teilweise
echt lustige Situationen, ne? Ich hab letztens auf Twitch, äh, nicht auf Twitch, auf Twitter
geschrieben. Alter, siehs sinngemäß, der Kollege neben mir, der schläft jetzt schon
seit vier Stunden und... Dann hat danach jemand, der auch neben mir sitzt, per Skype geantwortet,
so nach dem Motto, es sind nicht nur vier Stunden, es wäre viel mehr. Also es ist schon
teilweise echt komische Wege wie Nachrichten nehmen mittlerweile, die man irgendwo hinschreibt,
ja. Und ich muss manchmal echt aufpassen, weil ich weiß, dass jetzt die ein oder anderen
von der Arbeit dann auch das Lesen... Ja, Heinrich, kann schon sein, ne? Mich irritiert
das übrigens immer noch, weil mein Anzubi heißt auch Heinrich. Während der Arbeitszeit
mit dem Chat sprechen, ja. Der Chef guckt die Videos, ja. Manche. Ich hab sogar irgendwo,
ich hab mich schon lange mal überlegt, das müsste man eigentlich erst noch mal bringen,
ich hab irgendwo noch nen USB Stick, da ist ein Battlefield 3 Gameplay von meinem Chef
drauf. Hilly, ich glaub Kark Island Hilly Stels. Irgendwo hab ich ja nen USB Stick, der ist
zehn Jahre alt oder so. Das müsste ich echt mal ausbuddeln, das Teil. Hast du doch schon
hochgeladen? Was? Echt? Hab ich? Nee. Nee, hab ich nicht.
Nee, das kann ich glaub ich nicht, da ich das schon hochgeladen hab.
Ich wohne in Frankfurt, ja. Also Leute, sechseinhalb Stunden on gewesen. Ich glaube jetzt reicht's.
Gibt's irgendjemand, den wir hosten können? Ist der Friseur vielleicht am Start? Ei, Frisie.
Der Friseur am Start. Nein.
Gibt keiner, den ich hosten kann. Gut. Also Leute.
Wir sehen uns. Bis dann, macht's gut. See you.